Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freakshow und wir schreiben den 21.
Hälften im Jahre des Herrn.
Das stimmt. Und wir schreiben außerdem noch die Sendungsnummer,
die ist, was ist denn das überhaupt?
536.000, nee, 286.
286er, guck. Damals. Also als ich mein erstes...
286, ist schon gar nicht so wenig. Ist dir schon mal aufgefallen?
Also zwei, du musst ja einfach mal so die, du machst irgendwas einmal und dann
machst du es nochmal und dann machst du es nochmal und dann machst du es nochmal, nochmal, nochmal,
dann nochmal, dann nochmal und jetzt bist du irgendwie gerade mal bei,
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal bei 10 angekommen.
Könnten jetzt auch die Sendung damit verbringen, bis 286 hochzuziert.
Warum denn eigentlich nicht?
Ja, wir können ja die Freakshow in so einen Nummernsender umwandeln.
Es gab oder gibt ja wirklich einen Podcast, der Nummern verliest.
Wie hieß der nochmal? Erinnerst du dich daran?
Den hatten wir irgendwann mal auf der Subscribe. Nummernsender hieß der doch, glaube ich.
Kann gut sein.
Nach den Original-Nummernsendern, wo immer keiner so genau wusste,
was das war. Also es war wahrscheinlich einfach Krypto.
Hieß das nicht Nummernsender? Wikipedia kennt es nicht.
Zahlensender.
Zahlen, Zahlensender.
Ah ne, Moment mal, Zahlensender ist über Lost, das ist wieder was anderes.
Nein, nein, Number Stations, also das ist genau das, Zahlensender.
Und so hieß auch, glaube ich, der Podcast.
Zahlensender Podcast.
Den ich gemacht habe, aber...
Den du gemacht? Ach, du warst das.
Was? Ja.
Na gut, das fand ich ja. Mensch, Zufall. Echt? Das ist ja schrecklich.
Ach so, warte mal, es gibt einen Zahlensender Podcast zu Lost,
Aber den hast du nicht gemacht.
Nein, nein.
Sondern du hast für dich die Zahlen vorgelesen.
Ja.
Wo ist der noch online?
Ehrlich gesagt, er ist so ein bisschen missing in action und ich weiß nicht
so genau warum und ich hatte bisher keine Lust, mich drum zu kümmern.
Ha, ich habe mal sowas ähnliches gemacht und zwar habe ich Worte vorgelesen.
Also schöne Worte.
Ne, neue Worte.
Neue Worte.
Ich habe das auch irgendwie in meinem Archiv gefunden. Ich muss mal kurz schauen,
ob ich das gerade zur Hand habe.
Das war so eine meiner frühen Podcast-Experimente, wo man alles mal so ausprobiert hat.
Und ich muss gleich nochmal schauen. Vielleicht sollten wir uns nochmal kurz
vorstellen. Also ich bin Tim und Ralf ist Ralf und Roddy ist Roddy.
Hallo.
Genau, so. Und das kennt ihr ja schon, ja.
Und während ich jetzt nebenbei, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich irgendwo ein Archiv davon hatte.
Find's natürlich jetzt hier mal auf Anhieb wieder nicht.
Aber ich hatte, ich weiß nicht, es gab irgendwie eine Webseite,
die immer neue Worte vorgestellt hat.
und die fand ich teilweise sehr schön und dann habe ich die einfach so vorgelesen
und habe da mein Großmembran-Mikrofon so zum Einsatz gebracht.
Weil mit so einem Großmembran-Sink klingt da einfach alles besser.
Die seidige Stimme kommt da so richtig.
Genau. Und ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Also der Zahlensender war so, dass im Prinzip waren die Zahlen immer so eine
Aufforderung herauszufinden, was das soll.
Und das wurde immer aufwendiger, weil viele Leute es tatsächlich geschafft haben
und dann der Meinung waren, in derselben Art und Weise mit Zahlen in den Kommentaren zu antworten.
Oh weh.
Ja.
Also waren das Dinge, die quasi so Google-stabil waren, wo man also mit normal
Googeln dann nicht dran gekommen ist? Also jetzt, wenn du Pi eingibst,
dann weißt du halt, was passiert und die andere Eulasch-Gezahl und was da alles so gibt.
Oder ging es darum zu gucken, wie entwickelt sich irgendwie eine Folge?
Immer plus zwei, plus vier, plus sechs, plus acht, so IQ-Test-mäßig?
Nee, das waren schon, ja, wie sage ich das jetzt?
Berühmte Zahlen der Weltgeschichte.
Nee, es ging nicht um die Zahlen selber. Es waren mehr so Encodings und so ein Kram.
Ah, okay.
Also es war immer so, wenn du es rausgefunden hast, war es relativ offensichtlich,
dass du die richtige Lösung hast.
Nun.
Ich finde es nicht.
Ja, so ist es mit alten Podcasts.
Ich war mir relativ sicher, dass ich es vor der Nase hatte, aber ich finde es
irgendwie gerade nicht. Naja, mal gucken. Es war eigentlich ganz schön.
Ich wundere mich, habe ich das nicht mit.
Das macht mich ganz verrückt. Warum?
Warum habe ich das nicht? Weil ich hasse es, wenn Dinge verloren gehen im Internet.
Das ist mir völlig ein fremdes hier genau, Neue Wörter Podcast.
Wo habe ich denn das hingelegt? Genau, das waren die Wortwarte.
Die Wortwarte haben dann immer danach gesucht und Neue Wörter Podcast.
Neue Wörter.
Ist die Wortwarte so ein Ort, wo man mit einem großen Teleskop Wörter findet oder wie?
Das sind alles so Experimente der Frühzeit des Internets. Das ist mittlerweile
alles komplett überholt.
Aber naja, gab es halt alles irgendwie mal.
Müsstest du dann mal das Internet Archive anwerfen?
Ja, aber vor allem, ich müsste ja mein eigenes Archive haben.
und das ist irgendwie, was ich gerade nicht so richtig verstehe.
Aber neue Wörter ist natürlich ein anderer Suchbegriff als neue Worte.
Einen Versuch habe ich noch. Ah, hier ist es. Neue Wörter.
Hahaha, wusste ich es doch. Hier, gucke mal.
Und wie viele Episoden? Drei. Nein.
Neue Wörter. Hier, neue Wörter vom 2. Februar 2006.
Das ist hier nicht gerade besonders gut sortiert, aber ich kann zumindest mal
ausprobieren. Soll ich das mal einspielen?
Ja komm, jetzt wollen wir es auch hören.
Jetzt wollen wir es auch hören. Das war so ein richtig schmutziges Wort.
Ewiges, ewig angeteasert. Jetzt musst du auch liefern.
Okay, dann gucke ich mal, ob hier in dieser Datei auch wirklich das drin ist. Upsa.
Was versprochen ist.
Bildschirme färben sich schwarz.
Das sieht nach Audio aus. Das sieht nach Audio aus, das scheint genau das Richtige
zu sein. Achtung, jetzt geht's los. Habe ich das hier auch aufgedreht?
Ich glaube ja. Neue Wörter vom 2. Februar 2006.
Abstandsregelsystem. Edware Warner. Barbie Kamikaze.
Bitterblocker.
Brandentertainment-Aktion Cyberstart Datenurin Easy Listening Salon-Pazifismus
Eltern-Gamer Flummi-Preis-Syndrom,
Powerpoint-Karaoke. Oh, war neu. PTC-Nichtschmecker.
Riot-Göre. Ski-Racer. Stop-Over-Programm.
Verweicheiern.
Wohlfühlfeeling. Oh, okay. Also, jetzt kommt es gerade wieder. Neue Wörter.
Nun reicht es aber.
Ja, also die Wortwarte, die haben sozusagen neue Wörter, die irgendwie in der
Zeitung sozusagen in der Welt aufgetaucht sind, gescannt.
Und da haben das in so einem kleinen Blog irgendwie aufgetan und ich habe wirklich
nichts anderes gemacht, als die aufzuzeichnen.
Und siehst du, sowas wie Gamer-Eltern und wie PowerPoint-Karaoke war mal neu.
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, die meisten haben sich nicht durchgesetzt.
Da war schon viel dabei, was ich jetzt auch im Jahr 2024 zum ersten Mal gehört
habe. Aber ein paar eben schon.
Ja. Nochmal eins oder findest du es schon langweilig?
Ich glaube, wir haben das Konzept verstanden. Ich fand es schön.
Vor allem das Wohlfühlfeeling.
Mit dieser jugendhaften Stimme.
Das Wohlfühlfeeling klang sehr nach Politiker, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Ich glaube, das sind halt einfach eher so Presse.
Heinis.
Naja, ich meine, guck mal, die Journalisten leben ja auch in dieser Zeit.
Und dann sind sie ja auch ein Kind dieser Zeit. Und dann greifen sie ja irgendwie
auf, was sie so sehen. Und dann finden sie dafür Worte.
Und gerade diese ganzen Neologismen, die dabei so entstehen,
dann stehen ja nicht unbedingt in der Presse, sondern das ist ja dann auch nur so eine Wiedergabe.
Irgend so ein Fußballer oder Trainer oder so hat wohl mal gesagt,
vom Feeling her hatte ich ein gutes Gefühl.
Ja, das kenne ich auch. Der Fußball ist überhaupt sehr reich an Wort- und Satzschöpfungen.
Aber es waren auch praktisch alles komposita, so zusammengesetzte Wörter aus
bekannten Einzelwörtern.
Und das hat man, glaube ich, schon mal irgendwann, dass es, glaube ich,
keine Sprache auf der ganzen Welt gibt, die so reich ist an Kompositorwörtern
und so dankbar, dass du eigentlich ständig dir halt neue Dinge zusammen erfinden
kannst einfach und keiner stört sich daran.
Das ist etwas, was das Deutsche wirklich auszeichnet.
Das wird dem Deutschen immer nachgesagt, aber ich frage mich,
ist es nicht eigentlich im Englischen genauso?
Ich meine, man schreibt sie bloß nicht zusammen, aber es werden ja da auch am
laufenden Meter irgendwelche, also du hast ja fast jeden Tag so einen neuen
Begriff, gerade so im Tech.
Da wird halt einfach drei Worte zusammengeworfen mit einer Abkürzung und dann
ist das halt ein neues Wort,
ein neuer Begriff und der ist dann im Deutschen halt ein Wort oder mit Bindestrichen,
wobei sich da die Deutschen ja auch immer nicht ganz so einig sind,
auch die Engländer nicht, also auch das Englische, schreibt mal was zusammen.
Also es gibt ja auch richtig zusammengesetzte Worte.
Aber wenig.
Ja, wenig, aber es ist halt auch ein bisschen unklar, wann du es so machst und wann du es so machst.
Ja, aber im Englischen sind die Leute auch entspannter. Also du kannst immer
argumentieren, das ist jetzt Neuseeländisch gewesen oder so.
Ich sage ja nur, es ist jetzt nichts Ungewöhnliches, dass man einen neuen Begriff
dadurch schafft, dass man einfach irgendwelche anderen drei Wörter zusammennimmt
und dann im Kontext zusammen aufzählt.
Das ist richtig, aber ich glaube, die Deutschen schreiben es ins Extreme.
Ja, das weiß ich halt nicht. Ich glaube, es ist nur deshalb,
weil wir eben konsequent das immer alles in ein Wort schreiben und dann gucken
sich alle mal das Deutsche an.
So ein langes Wort.
Einwortbeschreibung.
Ja, und ich meine, dass du das Spiel im Prinzip ewig weitermachen kannst,
aber das kannst du ja im Englischen auch.
Aber da ist der Trend halt, wie du schon richtig sagst, eher dazu,
dann eine Abkürzung daraus zu generieren, die irgendwie verbreitet wird und hängen bleiben soll.
Ansonsten ist es halt irgendwie eine Beschreibung oder ein Begriff,
der entsteht, aber halt nicht ein neues Wort, wenn es nicht ein Wort ist.
Und vielleicht ist das auch gesünder als so, wie es Deutschen machen.
Du musst ja nur mal die, keine Ahnung, hier einen Bundestagszusammenfasser aufmachen
und mal gucken, wie so die neuen Gesetze heißen.
Da wirst du ja auch bekloppt bei.
Naja, aber da wird auch ordentlich abgekürzt. geabkürzt.
Also gerade dort. Und ich meine solche fiesen Worte wie Azubi.
Also ich meine, das ist ja auch eigentlich eine Abkürzung, weil die ein neues
Wort geworden ist und so.
Also ich glaube, das können wir schon auch.
Nun gut.
Strafrechtspflegestatistikgesetz.
Genau, wir verlesen neue Gesetze. Auch eine Marktlücke.
Neue Gesetze vom 21. November 2024.
Strafrechtspflegegesetz.
So, wie fühlen wir uns denn eigentlich heute? So in der neuen Dystopie?
Welche von den vielen meinst du?
Alle gleichzeitig.
Tja, also ich bin in einem so tiefen Tal des Elends, dass meine Stimmung,
glaube ich, gerade in so einem Abwehrmechanismus, der eigentlich,
bin ich, ganz gut gelaunt sich ansiedelt.
Leute hören sich ja auch auf Podcasts an, um mentale Reinigungen zu erfahren.
Und wir sollen jetzt mental reinigen, oder wie?
Naja, wir können ja mal ein bisschen versuchen, für alle so ein bisschen zu fühlen.
Also das Wohlfühlfeeling sozusagen neu zu entdecken.
Das Wohlfühlfeeling. Also ich
würde jetzt ungern über Geschehnisse in den Vereinigten Staaten eingehen.
So weit muss man ja gar nicht mal gehen.
Ansonsten, naja, keine Ahnung.
Ja, weiß nicht.
Seid ihr noch optimistisch?
Ich bin tendenziell immer optimistisch.
Nur jetzt gerade nicht.
Naja.
Wir haben eine Optimismuspause eingelegt.
Wir haben eine Optimismuslücke.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Es kommt halt immer darauf an, worum es geht.
Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt in die Politik guckt, dass die SPD sich jetzt
weigert, irgendwie den Schlaueren der beiden Kanzlerkandidaten zu nehmen.
Beziehungsweise der Schlau ist da glaube ich schon wieder eine schwierige Kategorie
an der Stelle. Aber ja, den Beliebteren.
Also ich meine, ob Pistorius jetzt schlau ist oder nicht, das sollen andere
Leute beurteilen, aber ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, dass er relativ gut bei relativ
vielen Leuten angekommen ist, während ich niemanden kenne, der begeistert von Scholz ist.
Aber vielleicht lebe ich da auch in der falschen Blase. Keine Ahnung.
Also was mich jetzt, um vielleicht ein bisschen mehr den Pfad der Technik als
der Politik einzuschlagen, ich habe so das Gefühl, dass diese ganze Technik
sich nicht mehr so richtig bemüht, um uns irgendwie,
zu bereichern, sondern uns irgendwie nur noch,
einzuzocken und abzuzocken und nur noch zu verraten und zu belügen vor allem
die ganze Zeit. Das ganze Internet belügt einen.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, auf der Hardware-Seite gibt es Hoffnung.
Oh, Spoiler.
Ich würde auch sagen, ich habe heute ein oder zwei Themen dabei,
wo das Herz hoffentlich bubert, ob neuer Möglichkeiten dank Technologie.
Ich dachte, wir könnten hier so einen kleinen Emotionalstrips machen und anderen
Leuten damit helfen, aber ich glaube, das wird nichts.
Der Zug ist aus der Halle, also da ist jetzt nichts Neues dazugekommen,
was man nicht schon vor fünf Jahren hätte beklagen können.
Ja gut, das ist ja dann so dieses irgendwie, ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt. Ich war ja froh.
Dass es dafür dann irgendwann einen Ausdruck gab, nämlich N-Shitification.
Aber ich glaube, seit es diesen Ausdruck gibt, ihn auch alle kennen,
glaube ich, ist das Thema dann auch mal durch.
Okay, dann mach ich mal was Konkretes,
wo gerade diese Frage der Identification jetzt so ein Thema ist.
Jetzt haben wir ja irgendwie, X finden ja jetzt noch mehr Leute scheiße als ohnehin schon.
Und es gibt ja jetzt diesen...
Ex-Odus.
Den Begriff gibt es aber auch schon seit zwei Jahren.
Ja, den gibt es schon länger, aber jetzt ist er, sagen wir mal,
das erste Mal auch medial relevant geworden, weil offensichtlich auch Journalisten mit exiten.
Also ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, das ist jetzt schon irgendwie abgeschlossen
oder so, aber es ist ja so ein fortwährender Prozess, dass halt Leute irgendwie
keinen Bock mehr auf Masks Twitter haben und nach der Nummer natürlich schon gar nicht.
Und jetzt teilt sich das sozusagen auf und X wird jetzt irgendwie so eine Art,
stellt sozusagen seine Technologie von Mastodon, nämlich True Social,
wieder auf Twitter-Technologie um und da ist dann so dieser ganze rechte Güllerotz,
der ist dann sozusagen dort geparkt.
Und alle anderen flüchten sich jetzt gerade zu Blue Sky.
Und die Debatte ist raging on,
ob denn jetzt sozusagen Blue Sky nur die nächste Entgertification-Hölle von
irgendwelchen durchgedrehten Tech-Bros wird oder nicht.
Also ich muss sagen, seit dieser, wie hieß er, Jack?
Dorsey.
Jack Dorsey. Solange wie der bei
Twitter am Ruder war, ging das mit der Entgertification relativ langsam.
Und die Plattform war lange benutzbar, zumindest so lange wie es die API gab.
Der eigentliche Twitter-Client war ja schon länger nicht mehr so richtig benutzbar.
ob Blue Sky jetzt denselben Bach runter geht kann ich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht
einschätzen aber ich habe das Gefühl,
lieber ein Netzwerk von dem als jetzt zum Beispiel Threads von,
Zuckerberg genau wo du schon von Anfang an irgendwie für Reichweite dann auch
mal Geld in die Hand nehmen musst,
statt dass die Leute, die was von dir sehen wollen, das einfach sehen können.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich glaube, das muss man abwarten, ob Blue Sky jetzt the
next big thing wird oder halt auch einfach nur inzwischen halt irgendwo anders hin.
Weiß ich nicht, finde ich zu früh.
Also es ist, mir ist ja jeder lieber, der von Twitter weg ist,
ist glaube ich das wichtigere Thema als zu Blue Sky hin.
Ja, gut. Also ich habe selber versucht, so ein bisschen so ein Bild davon zu bekommen.
Ich habe da eine technische und eine gesellschaftliche Perspektive drauf.
Und aus der technischen Perspektive finde ich es gut,
dass es noch einen alternativen Ansatz gibt zu einer Idee eines dezentralisierten Netzwerks.
Man kann jetzt kräftig darüber diskutieren, ob der Blue Sky Ansatz,
also dieses Ad-Protokoll, was dem zugrunde liegt, diese Kriterien erfüllt oder nicht.
Und ich verstehe mich jetzt auch nicht als Experte, aber soweit ich das halt
bisher verstanden habe,
gibt es in diesem Ad-Protokoll halt schon einen Unterschied zwischen dem Netzwerk,
was quasi die User Experience darstellt und den in diesem Protokollsystem agierenden Entitäten,
den Usern, die also quasi auch mit ihren ganzen Daten auf einen anderen,
PDC heißt das glaube ich, Personal Data Container Server umziehen können.
Also es gibt da sozusagen so eine Entkopplung. Es ist halt nicht wie bei Twitter
oder bei Threads, dass das irgendwie so alles so ein monochromatischer Blob
ist, wo irgendwie alles dran hängt und wenn du da raus bist, dann bist du raus.
Und es ist aber auch nicht so wie bei Masfordon, wo du zwar umziehen kannst,
aber wenn du umziehst, musst du immer deine Möbel zurücklassen.
Sprich dein Content.
Genau, weil du bist halt auf dem Server und du kannst dann zwar sagen,
dieser Account ist jetzt umgezogen auf den anderen Server und dann kannst du
da anfangen zu posten, aber du nimmst halt deinen alten Content nicht mit.
Sondern du belässt den auf den Server und wenn der Server halt weg ist,
und das werden wir halt sehen, dass diese Server weg sind, dann ist halt auch
der Content irgendwie weg.
Ja, finde ich komisch, dass das nicht geht, aber es wird Gründe geben.
Es wird Gründe geben, weil es halt einfach so ist. Vielleicht wird sich das
ja auch ändern, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, wäre ja auch nochmal eine Maßnahme.
Aber es ist eben, Masterdown ist halt sehr auf diesem Prinzip des Servers,
der halt so der Server ist und mit dem Server hast du halt die Domain,
mit dem Server hast du die,
Administrator und die User Experience wird ja quasi auf jedem Server immer wieder
komplett repliziert. Also du hast ja,
Du loggst dich ja dann auf dem Host ein und kannst da die Tweets lesen und du
hast dann da dasselbe User-Interface, weil dann da die selbe Software läuft, wenn das so ist.
So richtig viele unterschiedliche Implementierungen von Masodon gibt es ja jetzt
auch nicht, soweit ich weiß.
Also es gibt halt so die Referenzsoftware, die halt alle verwenden und es gibt
dann halt irgendwie, ich weiß, es gibt irgendwie eine in Elixir geschriebene
Variante, die aber glaube ich dasselbe User Interface benutzt und so weiter
und vielleicht gibt es auch noch ein paar andere, die ich jetzt nicht kenne.
Ist ja auch egal, also kann man natürlich auch anders implementieren.
Nur so ist halt da das Datenmodell. Und das ist meine technische Perspektive darauf.
Ich finde es gut, dass wir quasi mindestens zwei unterschiedliche Konzepte haben,
die jetzt sagen, so könnte man das machen und so könnte man das machen.
Ja, der Schönheitsfehler bei Blue Sky ist halt,
diese PDS-Konstrukte, die gibt es so und die könntest du, wenn du wolltest,
dezentral hochziehen, aber die sind dann ja alle wieder über zentrale Relays zusammen verbunden.
Und diese Relays werden, mein Kenntnisstand, jetzt November 2024,
ausnahmslos eben von Blue Sky Central betrieben.
Und wenn der mal ausfällt, wie vor ein paar Wochen mal passiert,
für irgendwie ein paar Stunden oder Tage, ist das komplette Netzwerk einfach mal tot.
Also du kannst dann zwar noch irgendwie ein bisschen was bei dir vielleicht lokal machen, aber...
Das war aber ein Internetausfall. Also das war eine Leitung,
die da gekappt wurde. Also nicht die selber weggewehrt.
Ja gut, aber wenn du alle Relais ins gleiche Datacenter stellst...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so der Fall war. Also ich glaube, das Problem war nicht
global. Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Also so hatte ich es vor ein paar Tagen gelesen, dass das eigentlich so der Lackmustest war.
Okay, wie dezentral ist denn Blue Sky eigentlich? Und in der Theorie könnte
es das sein, aber in der Praxis ist es das de facto nicht.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn so ein Mastodon-Server nicht erreichbar ist,
dann kannst du da deine Tweets halt auch nicht lesen.
Genau, aber der ganze Rest macht fröhlich weiter. Und Blue Sky war einfach mal down.
Komplett. Wenn ein Mastodon-Server ausfällt, dann juckt das den Rest des Netzes überhaupt nicht.
Ja, irgendwie Twitter-Vail, sag ich nur.
Also ich meine, das sind halt... Der Fail-Vail. Ja, der Fail-Vail,
ich meine, den hatten wir am Anfang auch ganz viel.
Das sind Probleme, die kann man irgendwie überkommen. Inwiefern das jetzt die
Architektur als solche getroffen hat, kann ich nicht sagen, aber ich sehe da
jetzt erstmal kein prinzipielles Problem,
wo irgendwie ein Ausfall von Servern und Vernetzungsstrukturen,
also keins dieser Systeme ist da jetzt generell irgendwie vorgefeit.
Ja, aber der Punkt, den halt viele Kritikerinnen machen an der Stelle ist,
es gibt derzeit verdammt wenige Anzeichen, dass die Blue Sky Betreiber es wirklich
ernst meinen mit, hey, das ist wirklich dezentral.
Das Protokoll kann das, die Architektur könnte das, aber es gibt wenige Schritte
in die Richtung, das irgendwie mal zu entforcen und zu begünstigen. Das ist der Punkt.
Sie hängen sich ein Label um, was de facto nicht umgesetzt wird.
Ja. Das kann man sagen, ja, ist so.
Naja.
Aber es ist dann halt, wenn du sagst, es ist ein anderer Ansatz von dezentral,
würden die sagen, das ist aber nicht dezentral.
Das kannst du eben nicht vergleichen, weil die behaupten, sie seien dezentral,
sind es aber de facto nicht.
Naja, du kannst dich natürlich darüber unterhalten. Bedeutet dezentral nur dann dezentral,
wenn du tatsächlich auch bei einer feindlichen Übernahme das Netz zumindest
zu teilen weiter betreiben kannst ohne den feindlich übernommenen Zentraldienst.
Und wenn ich mir das so angucke, sieht es danach momentan nicht aus. Also keine Ahnung.
Also ich kaufe das Argument insofern noch nicht, als dass es ja quasi schon
so ist, dass ihre Basis ist dieses Ad-Protokoll.
Und du könntest jetzt im Prinzip auch eine andere Implementierung machen,
die nicht Blue Sky ist, die aber quasi mit Blue Sky deren Usern und Daten und
so weiter interagieren kann über dasselbe Protokoll.
Das existiert derzeit noch nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das kommen wird, aber es ist halt so ausgelegt.
Und das ist schon mal ganz interessant. Und es gibt ja noch ein paar andere
interessante Aspekte, die sie da drin haben.
Es gibt dieses Konzept dieser Stackable Moderation. Also du hast so Moderationsmodule.
Das heißt, du kannst dir quasi auch die Moderation as a Service quasi dazuholen.
Du kannst sagen, ich will gerne, dass mein Nachrichtenkonsum hier nochmal von
dieser Entität moderiert wird und das kannst du dir so zusammenbauen,
das finde ich ist ein sehr interessanter Ansatz und du hast halt aber auch die
Möglichkeit sowohl einfach die Raw Timeline zu bekommen, wie das manche bevorzugen,
aber du kannst ja halt auch irgendwelche Algorithmen dazu holen,
wenn du das eben möchtest und dir dann eben Timelines entsprechend von dem Algorithmus
zusammenstellen lassen, aber du bist nicht gezwungen das zu tun.
Und ja, Listen funktionieren jetzt auch schon ganz gut. Also es gibt so verschiedenste
Aspekte, die da ganz gut funktionieren.
Es gibt auch Aspekte, die nicht so gut funktionieren. Ich finde zum Beispiel
den Client, der funktioniert halt nur auf dem Telefon gut und sonst nirgendwo.
es gibt mittlerweile ein paar webbasierte Applikationen so, die irgendwie ja,
so mehr oder weniger funktionieren, so richtig umhauen tut mich das alles noch
nicht, das ist alles noch kein Ivory und kein,
Icecubes, so, aber das kann halt auch noch passieren, gerade jetzt,
wo das Netzwerk Thermik bekommt, also.
Ich will jetzt gar nichts verkaufen. Ich bin da völlig offen.
Ich wollte nur mal sagen, es gibt eine technische Ebene, wo jetzt Mastodon eine
Alternative vorgesetzt bekommt.
Und man kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, ob der eine Ansatz von Dezentralität
den anderen Ansatz von Dezentralität schlägt oder wer was bevorzugt.
Ich kann bei beiden Modellen Vor- und Nachteile sehen und habe da überhaupt
gar keine klare Meinung dazu, was jetzt irgendwie besser, stabiler und zukunftsfähiger ist.
Das kann halt alles sein, aber
wir haben da zumindest mal ein offenes Rennen, das finde ich ganz gut.
Hast du denn mal so Hands-on-Erfahrungen jetzt in den letzten Tagen,
Wochen mit Blue Sky gemacht?
Wie Hands-on?
Ja, so einfach mal genutzt und da was gepostet und geguckt, was passiert da.
Ja, ich lese da schon immer mit und poste ab und zu mal was,
aber ich bin jetzt generell derzeit nicht sonderlich engagiert in Social Media.
Also ich poste jetzt noch mehr auf Mastodon, was aber im Wesentlichen damit
zu tun hat, weil die Tools besser sind.
Ich schreibe ungern am Telefon. Ich verstehe nicht, warum alle so begeistert
sind mit irgendwie Smartphone, Smartphone, Smartphone.
Ich brauche einen richtigen Computer, eine ordentliche Tastatur,
da kann ich irgendwie ordentlich schreiben und wenn der Client scheiße ist,
ist der Client halt scheiße.
Deswegen schreibe ich derzeit lieber auf Mastodon, aber es gibt für mich jetzt keinen Grund,
nicht auch genauso Blue Sky zu bespielen, weil ich dort halt auch schon Community
sehe und teilweise sehe ich die gleichen Leute und teilweise gibt es Leute,
die ich halt auf Mastodon nicht sehe.
Also es gibt wirklich da unterschiedliche Gruppen, was weiß ich,
so Sport, Fußball ist zum Beispiel, die Bubble ist auf Blue Sky schon relativ
stark und das zeichnet sich jetzt auch ab, dass das sozusagen da der Go-To-Place ist,
St. Pauli ist ja jetzt hier gerade mitgekommen.
Fliegenden Fahnen irgendwie abgewandert und hat X den Rücken gekehrt und setzt
auf Blue Sky, all diese ganzen Sachen.
Also derzeit haben die ja irgendwie ein Zugewinn von einer Million User pro
Tag, da geht's gerade richtig wild ab und wenn da mal irgendwie 45 Minuten der
Service ausfällt, weil irgendwie auch noch ein Provider sich die Karten gelegt
hat, dann denke ich da ehrlich gesagt nicht groß drüber nach.
So, das ist nur die technische Betrachtungsweise, ja.
Also ich mach relativ, also es ist Relativ regelmäßig, so einmal im Monat vielleicht,
mache ich halt so ABC-Test, dass ich also einen und denselben Post,
wo ich denke, der ist anknüpfungsfähig und massentauglich und könnte Leute interessieren,
sowohl auf Mastodon als auch auf Blue Sky, als auch auf Threads absetze und
gucke da mal so, was passiert.
Ich habe halt sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Follower-Zahlen da,
aber das kann man ja gewichten.
Also ich habe jetzt 6000 auf Mastodon, 500 auf Threads, wo ich sagen würde,
die sind auch alle irgendwie echt, so meiner Wahrnehmung nach.
Und 1000 auf Blue Sky, obwohl ich da eigentlich nichts mache, außer einmal im Monat.
So, jetzt auch die letzten Tage kriege ich pro Tag irgendwie 100 Follower dazu,
wo ich mich frage, warum eigentlich?
Vielleicht bist du in irgendeinem Startup-Pack mit drin.
Ja, aber dafür müsste ich ja irgendwie wieder Street Credibility erarbeitet
haben. Auf jeden Fall habe ich da halt 1000 Follower.
Du hast doch schon Street Credibility.
Naja, scheinbar nicht. Denn was auch immer ich da poste, es passiert nichts.
Es ist eine große, dunkle Void. Kein Like, kein Retweet, keine Interaktion, keine Antwort, nichts.
Es ist also, ich habe 1000 Follower, ich schreibe dasselbe rein wie in den anderen
Systemen, es passiert nichts.
Wo ich also auf Mastodon irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 20, 30 Likes habe und lustige
Debatten brennen und sowas und ich verstehe das nicht so richtig,
was ich da entweder jetzt irgendwie falsch mache oder nicht verstehe oder welcher
Algo da irgendwie querschießt.
Also ich habe 75 Follower, aber ich habe noch nie etwas gepostet bei Blue Sky.
Ja, aber ich würde jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, unsere Street Credibility in Sache
Social Media ist nicht so weit auseinander. Also warum habe ich jetzt 1000 Follower und du 75?
Ich habe 5000 und ich habe ich kriege Reaktionen darauf, wenn ich was schreibe,
ich schreibe bloß selten was.
Also das findet schon statt und wie gesagt, das hängt ja ganz von deiner Community ab.
Also was zum Beispiel auch gerade, und das freut mich auch sehr,
was gerade auf Blue Sky umzieht, ist meine ganze Ukraine-War-Bubble.
Das war ja lange, lange Zeit so ein Problem, dass die alle von X nicht wegzukriegen waren.
Was ich auch irgendwie verstehe, weil die haben da irgendwie ihre etablierten Netze halt.
und also das Argument mit oh, ein Netzwerk mit dem ich mich nicht groß beschäftige,
antwortet mir nicht, wenn ich einmal irgendwie reinrufe und mein Testpost kriegt
nicht 30.000 Likes, also.
Naja, aber einer wäre ja schon mal was.
Naja.
Und so schlecht sind die nicht. Also.
Du musst mehr Engagement zeigen in deinen Social Media Aktivitäten.
Irgendwas ist da komisch.
Okay, gut. Also jetzt Technik. Ich will das mal ganz bewusst trennen.
Und jetzt haben wir irgendwie diesen gesellschaftlichen Aspekt und das hat natürlich
was damit zu tun, welche Leute haben jetzt hier einen Einfluss auf dieses Projekt
und wo geht das vielleicht hin?
Stichwort so Entschittification und was ist hier zu befürchten?
Je nachdem, wenn du jetzt irgendwie zuhörst, kannst du halt irgendwie Loblieder
über das Blue Sky Projekt hören oder irgendwie totale Doomsday Artikel,
da gibt es irgendwie alles.
Aber vielleicht nochmal so zum Sortieren, also gegründet war,
also die ursprüngliche Idee war ja tatsächlich von diesem Jack Dorsey,
der irgendwie, ich weiß nicht was mit dem Typen nicht stimmt,
mit dem ist definitiv nicht alles okay.
Ja, also diese ganze Silicon Valley, Techbro,
Libertarian, Krypto, Bubble, die haben alle, alle irgendwie,
irgendwas ist da nicht in Ordnung mit denen.
Und die haben alle zu viel Geld und zu viel Einfluss und sind viel zu wichtig für das, was sie sind.
Und manche Leute wie Musk mit denen geht es halt irgendwie komplett durch.
Und der Jack Dorsey ist irgendwie so ein bisschen so dazwischen.
Und er hat immerhin mal die Idee gehabt und ich weiß nicht genau,
was ihn da getrieben hat, es mag schon noch so diese alte Internet-Hippie-Nummer
gewesen sein, die glaube ich auch in ihm irgendwie drin ist, so ein bisschen,
abgesehen von dem ganzen Geld und den ganzen Machtspielchen,
die dann halt auch noch stattfinden.
und hat halt gesagt, naja, so wie wir jetzt Twitter gerade bauen,
ist das ja nicht wirklich internetkompatibel.
Und da kommt ja diese Idee mit diesem Ad-Protokoll her.
Also dieses ganze Projekt, das hat glaube ich auch irgendeinen ursprünglichen
Namen, den habe ich jetzt vergessen,
hat er quasi so anfinanziert und da haben sich ein paar Leute damit irgendwie
beschäftigt und er war dann halt Founder, aber er ist da irgendwie ausgestiegen.
Die haben irgendwie so ein bisschen Geld bekommen, davon haben die ja da irgendwie genug.
Und dann haben sich halt ein paar Leute drum gekümmert. Und dann haben sie halt
irgendwie ihren Twitter-Blues und dann Elon Musk und dann war das irgendwie
alles viel wichtiger und im Zentrum ihres Lebens.
Und dann ist halt dieses Blue Sky Projekt so ein bisschen nebenbei weitergelaufen
und hat sich aber so technisch da etwas maturiert. Und...
Und mittlerweile, also die Chefin von dem ganzen Laden ist eine sehr junge Frau,
diese Jay, wie heißt sie, nicht Graeber, die habe ich jetzt gerade irgendwie
mal so im Interview gesehen.
das ist irgendwie so eine ganz zarte leise Person, die irgendwie.
Normale Dinge sagt und so klare wie soll ich sagen so eine klare Vision hat
und das alles so in rosigen Farben darstellt und ehrlich gesagt,
ich nehme mir das auch ab,
also ich glaube, die arbeitet wirklich gerne an diesem Projekt,
die war auch mal irgendwie so als Programmiererin bei so einem Krypto-Projekt dabei, bei Zcash.
Das ist immer schon so ein bisschen so eine Sache, aber ehrlich gesagt,
ich kenne so viele Leute auch aus meinem Umfeld, die in den letzten Jahren bei
irgendeinem Krypto-Projekt mitgemacht haben.
Das geht glaube ich mittlerweile schon als Standard-Jugendsünde mit durch.
Die Frage ist nur, wie hast du dich dann halt weiter entwickelt?
Wenn du divested hast, ja. Ansonsten nein.
So, aber wer halt da auch noch mit dabei ist, jetzt habe ich aber gerade hier
wieder mal diese Liste verloren, wo war denn das?
Ich fülle mal kurz die Lücke, um noch zu ergänzen, dass Jack Dorsey ja mittlerweile
den Aufsichtsrat von Blue Sky verlassen hat.
Mit dem Statement, so die machen dieselben Fehler wie wir damals bei Twitter
und ruft jetzt, hat seinen Account
dort auch gelöscht und ruft jetzt alle Leute auf, auf X zu bleiben.
Soviel dazu.
Ja, das ist doch schon mal was Gutes.
Meine Herren.
Genau.
Also auf gut Deutsch, der hat sich wirklich auch den Verstand weggeguckt.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Interessant ist aber, wer jetzt auf diesem Board ist und jetzt
finde ich das gerade irgendwie nicht.
Und zwar ist da unter anderem der Entwickler von eJubberD, glaube ich.
Board of Director,
wo steht denn das hier Company,
Protokoll oh man bin ich gut vorbereitet.
Du hast das Thema aufgemacht.
Ja, ja, ja ich finde es auch alles ganz furchtbar ich dachte auch gerade ich
habe hier die richtige Seite wo das steht, aber,
Jeremy Miller, das ist der Erfinder von Jabba und XMPP.
Okay, der kennt sich vielleicht ein bisschen mit verteilten Protokollen aus.
Naja, also der ist auch schon mal an was gescheitert sozusagen mit XMPP.
Also das lief ja eine Weile, aber es war halt genauso so ein bisschen,
also auch Jabba war halt nicht so richtig zukunftsfähig.
Das war halt alles irgendwie so XML über Verbindungen und alles war immer connected
und so diese ganze Non-Connectedness und all das, das war halt bei Jabba nie so richtig mit drin.
Und Und was ich damit nur sagen will, ist, ich habe so den Eindruck,
dass die Leute, die da derzeit das Ding irgendwie technisch inhaltlich voranbringen,
Die machen gerade erstmal nicht so jetzt, die stinken jetzt erstmal nicht so.
Aber, und das wird von einigen auch zu Recht angeführt, sie haben jetzt so eine
Finanzierungsrunde gerade abgeschlossen und da kommt halt die Kohle wieder von
so einer Kryptobude, von irgendwie so Blockchain Ventures,
Blockchain Capital heißen die glaube ich so.
Blockchain ist allein schon so ein Deppenmarker.
Naja, you know. So und ich frage mich halt, okay, was heißt denn das jetzt eigentlich?
Heißt das, dass sie jetzt alle böse sind und irgendwie nur vorgeschobene Nerds,
die irgendwie schöne Visionen für die Zukunft geben,
um sozusagen so Hänsel und Gretel ins Knusperhäuschen zu locken und dort werden
wir dann genauso durchgeweigt wie auf Twitter und Facebook und Threads und was hast du nicht gesehen?
Und das ist sozusagen so der nächste Rattenfänger, der auf uns wartet?
Oder ist es nicht einfach nur so, dass selbst Projekte, die technisch ganz interessant
sind und in eine gute Richtung gehen können und auch von zählen Leuten irgendwie
zumindest derzeit halbwegs geführt werden,
am Ende sich nicht dieser Problematik entziehen können, dass diese ganzen,
ich sag mal, latent rechten,
libertären Gruppen, die sehr viel Geld haben durch diese ganzen Krypto-Spekulationsblase
und aus anderen Gründen Geld haben,
weil sie halt vorher in irgendwelchen anderen Startup-Projekten und Venture-Capital-Geschäften
viel Geld gemacht haben, jetzt quasi...
Ihr Geld nicht nur auf Sachen schmeißen, die potenziell Geld bedeuten können,
sondern vermehrt auch ihr Geld einfach auf Sachen schmeißen können,
die irgendwie Social und Gesellschaft sind.
Die wollen irgendwie alles überall dabei sein und das ist so ein bisschen auch
so das Problem, glaube ich, dass wir derzeit so haben,
dass so richtig freie Medien im Prinzip auch so eine freie Finanzierung bräuchten,
die den Leuten Möglichkeiten, aber auch Luft zum Atmen gibt,
die ihnen aber nicht gewährt wird, weil es einfach diese Funds nicht gibt,
weil es einfach nicht genug Leute gibt, die sehr viel Geld haben.
Und so George Soros mäßig das sozusagen verteilen, um coole, offene,
politisch stabile Projekte zu fördern, sondern du hast halt irgendwie sehr viel
von diesem ganzen Scheißgeld mit diesen Leuten, die gar nicht mehr hinwissen,
wo mit ihrer Kohle, die sie auf alles regnen lassen, aber besonderes Interesse
haben an allem, was irgendwie an dieser Gesellschaft dran ist,
weil sie irgendwo überall ihre Finger drin haben wollen und den Diskurs mit beeinflussen.
wollen. Das müsste irgendeinem Zeitpunkt, auch wenn sie es jetzt noch nicht tun.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich meine, ich glaube, dass diese Social Media Venture
Capitalists die neuen Verleger sind, die am Ende dann,
entscheiden, was denn jetzt die gesellschaftliche Diskussion ist.
Und ja, keine Ahnung.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn Blue Sky zu viel Venture Capital einwirbt,
dass sie von der Venture Capital Dampfwalze dann auch überrollt werden und selbst
wenn da jetzt gute Leute sind,
wenn der Venture Capitalist am Ende irgendwie sein Geld sehen will und seinen
Einfluss geltend macht, dann
sind die auch irgendwann draußen und dann geht es den Ding den Weg allen,
Keine Ahnungsdingen. Also ich bin da ganz deiner Meinung.
Genau. Dann gibt es ja noch diesen Mike Masnick in diesem Board of Directors.
Das ist der Gründer von TechDirt.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Weblog, was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht lese.
aber er ist irgendwie derjenige, der den Begriff Streisand-Effekt mal ausgerufen
hat. Ist ja auch schon mal.
Ja, ist eine Weile her, aber ja.
Ja, ja, ist schon eine Weile her. Also, naja, halt so Leute,
die irgendwie auch so Teil des Gesamtsystems gewesen sind, zumindest zu irgendeinem
Zeitpunkt jetzt halt an der Stelle auch sind. Also, naja.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall at tim.britlove.org auf BlueSky und das finde ich übrigens
auch geil, dass du deine eigene Domain als Handle haben kannst,
die nicht an irgendeinem Server klebt.
Ja, das ist nett.
Und es gibt auch at Meta-Ebene.me Freakshow.fmh, ich habe die ganzen anderen noch nicht umgezogen.
Das wollte ich jetzt erst mal ausprobieren, aber das könnt ihr ja mal machen.
Ich bin nur unter dem üblichen Handle zu erreichen.
At Rudi. B-S-K-Y Ja, na gut, da hast du halt die Domänen geholt.
Das ist auch noch ganz interessant, womit sie Geld verdienen wollen und Geld
verdienen, also was sie so sagen und was sie so tun derzeit.
Wie groß ist da die Schere auseinander?
Naja, also was sie derzeit, also sie tun das, was sie auch sagen.
Also sie sagen, dass sie mit Domain verkaufen.
Also sie haben halt derzeit so mit Namecheap, glaube ich, irgendeinen Deal.
und wenn du halt einen coolen Nickname haben willst, der quasi als Domain sich
ja manifestiert und du hast dann diese Domain noch nicht,
dann kaufst du dir einfach durch Blue Sky quasi Affiliates irgendwie bei Namecheap
diese Domain, die dann quasi mit Klick-e-die-Klick eingerichtet ist für Blue Sky,
um dann sozusagen deinen Handle zu repräsentieren, über den du dann eben die
Kontrolle hast, solange du für diese Domain zahlst und daran verdienen sie mit.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht viel Geld, also keine Ahnung, wie viel Geld das
ist, Aber das wird jetzt nicht reichen, um irgendwie über Jahre ein Development zu unterstützen.
Und das andere, was diese Jay Graber sagt und was es aber derzeit noch nicht
gibt, ist, dass sie halt die Dienste, die heute sind, wollen sie halt weiterhin
auch frei, also kostenlos beibehalten.
Aber es wird dann eben Value Added Services geben, also es wird sozusagen Pro-Accounts
geben, die dann halt eben mehr können, wo halt irgendwelche Features dabei sind.
Das, was ich immer wollte, dass Twitter es tut.
aber nie getan hat. Und das ist im Prinzip ihre Ankündigung.
Na mal sehen, ob das gut geht oder nicht.
Ja und ob am Ende nicht dann auch Werbung dann doch wieder mit im Spiel sein wird.
Aber dann kann eben auch, wenn da genug User sind, kann es halt auch sein,
dass eben irgendwie auch ein anderes Netzwerk sich an dieses Ad-Protokoll ranmacht.
Du kannst mit deinem Content und du kannst mit deinem Nickname da auch sein
und darüber auch wahrgenommen werden, ohne, dass du quasi jetzt an dem Blue
Sky Apparat als solchen mitmachen musst.
Also ich habe eine Bridge nach Mastodon schon gesehen.
Ja, nicht als Bridge, sondern als gleichwertiger Teilnehmer.
Also ich kann es allerdings nicht mehr genau nachvollziehen, was da jetzt genau war.
Ob da jetzt jemand nur irgendwie seinen Kram, seinen eigenen Stream nochmal
nach Mastodon gepipet hat oder so.
Ja, es gibt so Activity Pub zu Add Protocol Gateways. und du kannst das halt dann darüber machen.
Also das habe ich auch schon mal ausprobiert, das funktioniert im Prinzip,
du kannst Leuten von Mastodon aus auch auf Blue Sky folgen.
Es gibt auch ganz brauchbar bedienbare Clients, die jetzt auf alle drei Netzwerke gleichzeitig posten.
Also dann ein Posting auf Threads, Blue Sky.
Ja, wie heißt dieses Ding, was du mir da vorgeschlagen hast?
Sag nochmal. Oh, cool, oh, irgendwas mit oh.
Ja, da kommen jetzt regelmäßig neue raus, müssen wir mal gucken, was heißt.
Ja, da sind sie meistens halt immer nur so iPhone-only und das stimmt.
Keine iPad, keine Mac-Version.
Nach Windows fragt ja gar keiner.
Gut, also würde mich auch mal hier
Leute, die ihr zuhört, mir auch mal interessieren, wie ihr das so seht.
Ich will jetzt keinen heiligen Krieg hier ausrufen, sondern mir geht es da wirklich
um so eine abgewogene Sichtweise und ich gebe auch zu, ich muss mich da in diese,
Untiefen der des Ad-Protokolls und der Struktur und was das alles für die Implikationen hat, nochmal rein,
lesen genauer und vor allem besser verstehen, wie da so die Dynamiken sind und
es kann sehr wohl sein, dass da irgendwo ein Designfehler drin ist, der alles verhindert.
Aber wie gesagt, auch Mastodon ist nicht ohne seine Probleme und das finde ich
ist ein offenes Rennen derzeit.
Es kann auch beides parallel existieren, das nochmal ganz nebenbei.
Ja, wird es auch. Also Mastodon, glaube ich, stirbt so schnell nicht.
Ja, aber Mastodon wächst nicht so schnell, weil es einfach immer noch so ein
paar ganz grundlegende Probleme gibt, die halt nicht gelöst sind.
Also es ist halt einfach gar nicht mal so einfach mal irgendwie so einem Mastodon Account zu folgen.
Mit diesen Domains und dann bist du dann auf dem Server eingeloggt,
weil dann die URL dahin ging. Dann ist aber da nicht dein Account.
Dann musst du dann den Handel merken. Dann musst du dich in deinem Server einloggen.
Also wenn man das jetzt über das Web macht und so.
Clients machen es dann teilweise ein bisschen leichter. Aber es ist immer noch
irgendwie so ein bisschen weird, weil du halt immer diese ganze E-Mail sozusagen da hast.
Immer diese ganze Domain, die da noch mit dran klatscht.
Ja gut, aber ich meine die Blue Sky Handles sind ja jetzt auch nicht kurz.
Da ist nur das Ad woanders. Also das finde ich jetzt kein Argument.
Also der normale Weg ist doch, du hast irgendwie deinen Stream,
irgendjemand anders retweetet, retutet was und du siehst, okay,
der postet häufiger interessanten Kram und dann drücke ich auf Follow und dann folge ich dem.
Nee, ich sehe das halt auch auf Webseiten und dann habe ich das im Copy-Paste
und dann versuche ich irgendwie meinen Client dazu zu bekommen,
dass ich das jetzt irgendwie abonnieren kann.
Also wenn es einfach wäre, dann würde ich sagen, es ist total einfach,
aber es war nicht immer total einfach, sondern es hängt immer sehr davon ab,
was hast du für einen Client, wo bist du jetzt gerade, bist du jetzt im Web
und im Web ist es schon richtig anstrengend und,
bei Blue Sky gibt es halt nur einen Handle.
Aber ich habe also auch Twitter nie im Web verwendet, weil ich das immer irgendwie
anstrengend und nie gut fand.
Also insofern ist Client auf dem Telefon für mich so der Normalfall.
Also ich bin da bis zu einem gewissen Grad echt entspannt, weil ich glaube,
wir werden das auf Mastodon einfach aussitzen,
wie sich alle anderen in den nächsten Jahren Stück für Stück immer wieder zum
Horst machen und wie Fax und E-Mail werden wir immer noch da sein als solide
Basis, auf die man immer wieder zurückgreifen kann und die nicht so einfach kaputt gemacht wird.
Ich habe dazu vor zwei Monaten einen Vortrag gehalten. Ich habe den hier gerade
mal reingeworfen mit Felix Ostrovski zusammen, mit dem ich damals OpenBioSocial
als Mastodon-Instanz hochgezogen habe mit dem schönen Titel von kommerziellen
zu kulturellen Netzwerken.
Und dann habe ich relativ am Ende, mache ich eigentlich nur eine zentrale These
und einen zentralen Punkt und das ist, liebe Medienschaffende,
liebe Politikerinnen, liebe NGOs, liebe Universitäten, Forschungsinstitute, was auch immer,
bespielt mit euren PR-Abteilungen, was immer ihr wollt.
Wenn ihr meint, ihr müsst noch auf X sein, so be it.
Wenn ihr meint, ihr müsst jetzt Blue Sky oder Threads machen, meinetwegen.
Aber leistet euch doch einfach ein Plus Eins dazu, mindestens ein freies Netzwerk eben zu unterstützen.
Und Mastodon ist da sicherlich keine schlechte Wahl. Wenn ihr das Geld habt,
drei, vier andere Kanäle zu bespielen von Instagram und TikTok und YouTube und
was nicht alles, dann wird euer Social Media Team es schaffen,
noch einen einzigen freien Kanal dazuzunehmen. Just do it.
Wer beispielsweise, wenn ich was zu sagen hätte, irgendwie in der Politik,
würde ich sagen, wer öffentliche Fördergelder bekommt, muss auch ein öffentliches
soziales Netzwerk supporten. Punkt.
Mit seiner Online-Kommunikation.
Hier genau, das war der Client, den du, glaube ich, Open Vibe,
genau, der macht jetzt Master of the Blue Sky Nostre und Threads in einer App.
Aber das ist halt nur wieder Telefon und ist so auf dem Rechner nicht wirklich zu benutzen.
Entschuldigung, dass ich das immer wieder sagen muss, aber man muss mehr über
Macs reden. Wo, wenn nicht hier.
Ist das dein Versuch, eine Überleitung zu machen?
Nein, das können wir gleich als Überleitung benutzen, aber ich möchte trotzdem
immer wieder klar machen, dass ich weiß, dass viele Leute das Telefon benutzen,
ich tue das auch, aber the desktop will never die.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ich bin, was so ein Netzwerk anbelangt,
auch nicht so ein heftiger Produzent.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, ich haue lieber wenige gute Posts raus,
als ständig mein Essen zu fotografieren oder sowas in der Art zu machen.
Aber gut, das sollen dann meine Follower sagen, ob mir das gelingt oder nicht.
Gut, dann womit wollen wir weitermachen?
Wollen wir dann überleiten oder wollen wir erstmal über Macintosh reden?
Ja, mach mal. Ja, dann reden wir mal mehr über Macs.
Gut, sehr gut. Ich hab uns was mitgebracht.
Okay, es ist ja, bevor du mir das zeigst, also...
Wir durften vorher nicht lunzen.
Ja, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass du dir irgendwas anderes gekauft hast als ein Mac Mini.
Richtig, alles andere würde auch nicht in diese Kiste.
Ja, also das war mir auch schon vorher klar, dass du jetzt da kein MacBook rausholst.
Aber wir machen jetzt ein Realtime-Unboxing hier.
Ja, naja, nicht so ganz. Ich meine, ich habe das Teil ja schon in Betrieb gehabt.
Also die graue Versandhülle ist jetzt schon hinfort und jetzt haben wir also
den ganz originalen neuen Mac Mini Cup-Würfel vor uns, der doch größer ist, als ich dachte.
Ich dachte, die seien noch dichter dran am Apple TV.
Und deswegen habe ich ihn mitgebracht, er ist auch schwerer, als ich dachte.
Ja. So, wo ist denn hier dieser skandalöse einen Ausschalter an der Unterseite. Da ist er.
Man kommt wirklich nicht dran, wenn das Teil liegt. Man muss es anheben.
Man muss es anheben, ja.
Ja, aber ansonsten geiler Formfaktor. Nichts dagegen.
So. Das ist in etwa so schwer, wie ich dachte.
Im Audio-Podcast sagen wir, wie etwas aussieht.
Das ist jetzt so ein Achtel von Tims Studio Mac, der jetzt hier steht.
Also es ist 5 Zoll mal 5 Zoll mal 2 Zoll.
Und ja, ihr habt sicherlich alle von dem Mac Mini jetzt schon tausend Bilder gesehen.
Was ist bemerkenswert an dem Teil? Es ist halt relativ kompakt und es ist halt
ratten schnell, weil da dieser M4 drin ist, der einfach rattenschnell ist.
Dazu kommen wir gleich noch.
Genau.
Dazu kommen wir gleich noch von wegen rattenschnell.
Netz und Ethernet, hast du ihn mit 10 oder mit 1?
Mit 1. Ich habe das Basis-Basismodell geklickt, weil ich das Gefühl habe,
egal welchen Button ich setze, das Gerät dann nicht mehr in eine Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
Die 10-Gigabit-Option, finde ich, die geht gerade noch so, aber alles andere,
was mit RAM und mit SSD zu tun hat.
Deswegen ist das jetzt wirklich die kleinste Konfiguration, die es gibt,
aber auch die kostet ja schon 700 Euro.
Ihr kennt die Rechnung, die sie in ATP da aufgemacht haben.
Wenn du dir den neuen Mac Mini mit doppeltem Speicher und doppelter Festplatte
kaufst, ist es genauso teuer, wie wenn du einen komplett zweiten Mac Mini dir
in der Basisausstattung daneben stellst.
Das heißt also, die ganze CPU und sowas ist dann quasi so Wegwerf nebenbei. Artikel.
Das bringt dir natürlich dann nichts, zwar nebeneinander, weil die ja nicht
irgendwie gekoppelt oder auseinandergenommen oder sonst was kriegst,
aber das finde ich ist schon pervers.
Ich habe hier den modernen Tower auf Hanoi jetzt mal gebaut,
also ein Mac Studio, auf dem ein Mac Mini steht, auf dem ein Apple TV steht.
Und ich muss sagen, der Mac Mini ist im Vergleich zu einem Mac Studio,
Also der wirkt im Vergleich zum Mac Studio sehr viel kleiner als das Apple TV gegenüber dem Mac Mini.
Also Mac Mini ist sehr viel näher an diesem Apple TV als am Mac Studio dran.
Ich finde es faszinierend, wie sehr der ähnliche Dimensionen hat. Also Verhältnis.
Proportionen.
Proportionen, genau.
Der Grauton ist erstaunlich anders. Ich hätte gedacht, die nehmen quasi dasselbe als das Aluminium.
Das ist doch auch das gleiche.
Stell mal die runden Kanten quasi direkt aufeinander, so wie du es gerade eben
hattest. Der Mac Mini ist deutlich heller.
Bremer Stadtrechner, genau.
Nein, der ist nicht deutlich heller.
Echt?
Nein, guck mal, wenn ich hier die Kanten direkt, ich lege jetzt hier die Kanten
so direkt übereinander, da merkst du gar nicht, wo der Übergang ist.
Man sieht schon, wir achten auf die ganz wichtigen Dinge.
Ja, nee, das ist schon das Gleiche.
Ja, okay, gut, das war geil.
Der hat den Winkel.
Er hat recht.
Und ich finde, er ist relativ schwer. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob sie den nicht vielleicht auch sogar künstlich beschwert haben,
dass wenn da so ein HDMI-Kabel, das so ein bisschen zäher ist,
dass der dann nicht schief steht, sondern das Gewicht hat, den dann runterzudrücken.
Er ist tatsächlich komplett leise. Also man kriegt ihn eigentlich,
also überhaupt schwer zum Lüften,
Aber wenn, dann hört man das auch nicht.
Also interessant ist, ich wollte natürlich wissen, wie schnell ist das Teil
tatsächlich im Vergleich und eins der Go-To-Tools für CPU ist ja Cinebench.
Wie ist denn jetzt die CPU-Aufteilung hier von dem, den du jetzt hier hast?
Wie viele Performance und Efficiency kostet?
Also zwei Efficiency und...
Ich glaube, ja.
Also das ist jetzt das Links-Oben-Modell, um da mal in der Apple-Terminologie zu bleiben.
Ja, nicht rechts unten, sondern links oben, genau.
Also vier High-Performance-Kerne und sechs Effizienz-Kerne hat er.
Ah, dafür ist er relativ schnell. Das Ding ist, er ist nur unwesentlich schneller
in Cinebench als das MacBook Pro M1 Max, was ich habe.
Aber es ist schneller.
Ja, aber nur unwesentlich. Warte mal.
Gut, aber trotzdem, wir reden davon, dass das Low-End-Modell der M4-Serie ist
nach drei Jahren schneller als das High-End-Modell der M1-Serie.
Ja, bei dem Ultra gab es doch aber auch noch drüber, oder? Das ist auch schneller
als der Ultra. Pro Max Ultra war doch die Reihenfolge, oder?
Ja, naja, das Ding ist, der Ultra sind ja im Prinzip zweimal ein Max irgendwie
an der Kante zusammengeklebt und,
In Cinebench würdest du das sehen, weil er dann fast doppelt so schnell ist,
weil Cinebench extrem gut parallelisiert und du in Cinebench halt einfach,
wenn du mehr Kerne hast, das siehst du halt sofort, auch wenn es schwache Kerne sind.
Weil also hier einmal, das ist das erste Diagramm,
da habe ich also mal gegengefahren mein MacBook Pro M1 Max gegen den Mac Mini
M4 jetzt und dann konnte ich mich natürlich auch nicht zurückhalten,
meinen Gaming-PC daneben zu halten.
Der hat also die gerade nicht mehr aktuelle Version von einem AMD Ryzen drin
und zwar den 7800X 3D, ganz toller Name.
Was testet denn dieser Cinebench?
Cinebench ist von Maxon, die haben da irgendein 3D-Rendering-Programm.
Okay, also ist das jetzt ein GPU-Test?
Nee, ist ein reiner CPU-Test, weil es ein CPU-Renderer ist.
Achso.
Also Cinebench Version 23 testet nur CPU und rendert eine Szene.
Das ist die immer gleiche Szene, die ist da eingebaut und tut das aber zumindest
im Multicore-Modus halt mit allen Cores, die da zur Verfügung stehen und gibt da ordentlich Stoff.
Aber wie viele Performance Cores hat jetzt dein M1 Max?
Der hat zwei Performance Cores und acht Performance Cores und zwei Efficiency Cores.
Gut, also doppelt so viele, muss man dann mal sagen, als jetzt der arme kleine Mac Mini hier M4.
Das muss er ja schon mit reinrechnen, finde ich.
Aber es gibt einen noch viel interessanteren Benchmark-Test, den ich gemacht habe.
Und zwar habe ich natürlich auch mal ein Spiel ausprobiert.
Und jetzt find mal ein Spiel, was es auf dem Mac gibt und was es auf dem PC
gibt und was einigermaßen anspruchsvoll ist und auch einen eingebauten Benchmark.
Assassin's Creed?
Haben die Benchmark drin?
Wörter?
Nein, die Wörter, genau. Nein, was ich tatsächlich gefunden habe,
ist Shadow of the Tomb Raider.
Ah, okay. Ah ja, das hatte ich irgendwann mal gelesen, dass das für Benchmarks
genommen wird. Wenn das ist das, was ich jetzt erinnere.
Ja, genau. So, und jetzt heißt es ja, dass die Grafik in dem M4 Raytracing kann.
Kann aber Shadow of the Tomb Raider nicht. Gut, der macht auch nicht allzu viel Raytracing.
Insofern ist es halt ...
ist es ein bisschen hinfällig. Aber ich habe halt jetzt verglichen,
dass MacBook Pro M1 Max mit 32 GB speichert, das muss man dazu sagen,
das wird gleich interessant,
der neue Mac Mini und wieder der PC.
Und ich komme halt bei 1080p Auflösung,
Komme ich halt bei dem Mac Mini jetzt auf, wo ist jetzt die Tabelle,
kriege ich 39 Frames pro Sekunde.
Das ist halt sehr zäh.
Ich kriege allerdings bei dem MacBook Pro mit dem Mehrspeicher kriege ich 64 Frames pro Sekunde.
Ja, und der PC macht 300. Aber das ist dann, gut, der hat halt mehr Speicher
auf der Grafikkarte als dieser Mac Mini hier insgesamt hat.
Und dabei zieht er dann auch nochmal bei nicht Strom.
Richtig, Moment, da habe ich auch einen.
Hast du immer so einen Chart gemacht wie Apple mit?
Da habe ich dann auch einen Chart gemacht und der Vergleich,
der ist ja schon fast richtig unfair.
Der Mac Mini ist irgendwo bei 40 Watt, das MacBook Pro ist bei etwas über 60,
67 Watt oder so und der PC verbraucht 370, 380 Watt.
Das meiste davon wahrscheinlich die Grafikkarte.
Das sieht mir auf deiner Grafik eher wie 450 Watt aus.
Oder warte mal, ich gucke kurz in die Tabelle. Was habe ich da hingeschrieben? 470.
Genau.
Es ist ganz lustig, wenn man das umrechnet, dann bekomme ich für die beiden
Macs ungefähr einen Frame pro Sekunde pro Watt.
Und bei dem PC kriege ich 1,6 Frames pro Watt.
Frames pro Watt? Das ist ja mal wirklich eine Einheit.
Also es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt unfair ist. Dazu muss man sagen,
diese AMD-Grafikkarte, die ich da drin habe, die ist jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür
bekannt, dass sie jetzt effizient mit dem Strom umgeht,
der ihr da angeboten wird.
Insofern 470 Watt, das ist ein Heizlüfter, wenn man den anmacht.
Okay, was waren jetzt nochmal die beiden FPW-Werte, die Frames per Watt?
Um die 1 für die beiden Macs und um die 1,6 für den PC.
Okay.
So, ähm,
War noch irgendwas, was ich noch sagen würde? Was kostet der PC?
Der PC, wenn man ihn jetzt bauen würde, so wie er da ist, knapp 2000 vielleicht.
Keine Ahnung, müsste ich ausrechnen.
Muss man auch nochmal Frames pro Watt pro Cent rechnen.
Müsste man auch, ja. Da ist vor allen Dingen auch deswegen eine AMD-Grafikkarte drin.
Wenn da eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte drin wäre, dann würde die mehr Frames für etwas
weniger Watt liefern, aber dann pro Cent mal so richtig einbrechen.
Also das Flaggschiff kriegt man in Europa, glaube ich, immer noch nicht unter 2000 Euro.
Und dieser Tomb Raider ist aber irgendwie ordentlich für ARM optimiert und pipapo.
Gut, das ist ein Thema, da kann man jetzt auch nochmal sich fragen,
ist das Spiel denn auf dem Mac so gut optimiert wie auf dem PC?
Sicherheit nicht.
Da würde ich davon ausgehen, wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Also es scheint eine
kleinere Bude zu sein, die diese Portierung macht.
Was machen die denn bitte in diesem Spiel, dass so ein M4 mit 16 GB RAM nicht
in der Lage ist, da mal mindestens 60 Frames rauszuklocken?
Gut, das ist etwas, der kleine Hinweis, der Hinweis, der so ein bisschen versteckt
ist, den ich auch schon gegeben habe, ist das MacBook, wo ich nämlich 32 GB Speicher drin habe.
In dem Mac Mini sind nur 16 GB Speicher drin und das ist der große Pferdefuß.
Weil wenn man das Spiel tatsächlich laufen lässt, also auf dem MacBook,
der hat ja so einen gemeinsamen Speicher zwischen Grafik und Prozessor,
da zeigt das Spiel an, es benutzt 22 GB Speicher für die GPU.
Okay.
Das ist natürlich die Ultra-Auflösung. Also alles auf Max gestellt natürlich.
Ja, okay, gut, dann kannst du das ja alles gar nicht vergleichen.
Deswegen wird der, wenn man damit spielen will, auf jeden Fall braucht man einen
mit viel Speicher, damit die GPU nicht durch den Speicher aufgehalten wird.
Aber dann wird natürlich der Percent,
sozusagen das Pro-Geld-Element geht natürlich dann durch die Decke.
Ja, also insofern, weißt du, die Grafikkarte, die ich in dem PC habe,
die hat halt 24 Gigabyte Speicher, da passt halt das Spiel, also die gesamte
Grafikleistung einfach rein und dann nudelt er es ab, ohne dass noch irgendwas über den Bus geht.
Das merkt man halt an der Stelle.
Ja und zu dem Thema als letztes noch ist mir aufgefallen, da können wir uns
auch schon mal anschnallen, was da passiert und zwar das Spiel,
was im Prinzip immer als der große Showcase für Raytracing gehandelt wird,
Cyberpunk 2077,
wird nächstes Jahr für den Mac erscheinen.
Und dann können wir mal einen Reality-Test machen, wie gut das Raytracing auf
den Mac-Prozessoren...
Welches Spiel ist das?
Da, Cyberpunk.
Das ist das, man erschießt alle Leute.
Wo man alle umbringen muss, okay.
Ja, man kann aber auch Autos fahren.
Und eine Prinzessin retten.
Und hacken.
Ach, gleichzeitig.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist so eine Art Open World.
Ich schieße und fahre. Pfiffig. Man kombiniert einfach alle vier Spiele in eins.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Du wirst erstaunt sein, wie viele Spiele das inzwischen machen.
Also zumindest, wenn man Tiere als Autos begreift.
Okay.
Ob das Spiel ein gutes Spiel ist oder so, ist eine komplett andere Diskussion.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall der Showcase, mit dem jeder testet,
ob man inzwischen Raytracing eigentlich benutzen kann oder nicht.
Das ist halt das Spiel, was in der Overdrive-Sonst-Was-Einstellungsversion auf
dem Flaggschiff von Nvidia auch nur 60 Frames macht.
Wann kommt das raus?
Auf dem Mac. Naja, auf der Seite steht...
Early next year.
2077 halt.
Ja. 2077. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Also ich glaube, das wird, ja, die Schachtdeckel in Cyberpunk haben nicht richtig die Norm. Egal.
Okay, also Anfang 2025. Könnt ihr euch eigentlich vorstellen,
dass es nochmal ein Spiel gibt, was mir gefallen könnte?
Nein, völlig ausgeschlossen.
Die Chancen stehen schlecht, so wie du über Spiele redest und vor allen Dingen
so wie du immer nicht so genau sagst, was du an Spielen eigentlich gut findest.
Doch, habe ich gesagt. Ich finde Mario Kart super.
Mario Kart, naja, da kommt ja immer mal wieder ein Mario Kart.
Das ist auch so mein Update-Cycle.
Es sind wieder 10 Jahre rum. Es gibt ein neues Mario Kart.
Naja, eigentlich gibt es immer
ein Mario Kart, wenn Nintendo eine neue Konsole auf den Markt schmeißt.
Ich meine, es muss doch mal irgendwas geben, wo man nicht die ganze Zeit rumrennen,
alle erschießen muss. Ich finde das so langweilig.
Also ich für meinen Teil spiele sehr gerne BMNG. Das ist so eine...
Ich crashe Autos, Sandbox. Das macht unheimlich viel Spaß, besonders weil man
auch nur mit Kanone fahren kann und damit rumschießen.
Also so eine, wie man sie von Galären kennt, so ein Metallding mit so Holzrädern und so.
Das fährt sich sehr schlecht, aber das...
Also bei uns zu Hause in der Familie ist jetzt gerade das neue Zelda sehr angesagt.
Und das hat in der Tat einen lustigen neuen Mechanismus. Also das ist die Kategorie...
Was heißt das neue Zelda für die Switch?
Für die Switch, genau. Hier Zelda, wie heißt das, irgendwas, Echos of whatever.
Und das ist ein Spiel der Sorte, du musst alle umbringen und du bist aber selber
die Prinzessin. Also auch wieder Mashup.
Aber das Umbringen ist insofern lustig, als welches.
Das ist jetzt mal Zelda selber.
Das ist Zelda selber zum ersten Mal. Überhaupt kann man jetzt Zelda selber spielen.
Und die hatte halt einen lustigen Skill, nämlich die ganzen Monster haben ja
immer so Spezialfähigkeiten, wogegen die irgendwie besonders resistent sind
oder was sie für Attacken haben oder manche können fliegen oder schwimmen oder wie auch immer.
Und jedes Monster, was du besiegst, nimmst du quasi in deinen Pokémon Zoo auf,
den du willst und kannst das dann gegen andere Monster deployen wieder.
Das heißt also, du sammelst dir, das sind dann sogenannte Echos,
heißt es halt im Spiel, du sammelst dir also ein Bestiarium heran von allen,
die du schon besiegt hast und in jedem neuen Kampf kannst du dann überlegen, okay so,
release the Kraken.
Wie heißt dieses Spiel hier? Schere, Papier, Brunnen.
Wo sind die Schwachstellen und welches jetzt meiner Viecher ist da besonders gut geeignet?
Und dann schickst du die halt aufeinander los. Das macht schon Spaß.
Das ist ein witziger Mechanismus. Plus du kannst auch noch alles mögliche anderes
spawnen, was du halt irgendwo einsammelst. zum Beispiel, dass die Grundmechanik basiert auf Betten.
Ja, Betten. So, du kannst ganz am Anfang, das Erste, was du überhaupt quasi
lernen kannst, ist ein Bett spawnen. So, jetzt wird man sich sagen...
Von was für einem Spiel redest du gerade?
Das neue Zelda.
Das ist das Most Overpowered Item, was es je bei Zelda gab.
Deswegen gingen die so stark gegen Perlworld vor. Perlworld ist auch so ein Spiel.
Und der Clou an dem Bett ist eben, du kannst dich natürlich irgendwie reinlegen und dann heilst du.
Aber du kannst eben auch mehrere Items nacheinander und übereinander spawnen.
Und das heißt, du kannst dir aus großen zweimal ein Meter Betten eine Leiter bauen.
Indem du also einfach drei oder vier Betten in der Diagonale übereinander stapelst.
und dann läufst du halt die Leiter hoch und damit kommst du dann an alle möglichen Orte dran.
Also schon ganz witzig dieses Konzept so.
Du kannst quasi alles lernen und dann deployen und gucken wie kommt man damit durch die Welt.
Sehr, sehr anderer Ansatz als die letzten beiden Zelda-Spiele.
Also gerade wer eher so ein bisschen auf isometrische Grafik steht und Dungeons
und die Dungeons sind dann von 2D nämlich auch dann wird von 3D auf 2D quasi
umgeschaltet also alles sehr nostalgiamäßig. Ja genau das ist es was da gerade
in den Chat reingehoben hat.
Echoes of Wisdom.
Okay, ich bin schon wieder nicht mehr up to date, obwohl meine Jungs den ganzen Kram spielen.
Ich habe ja gerade den Super Mario Brothers Film gesehen.
Der ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Der ist super.
Super würde ich nicht sagen.
Doch, ich fand den super. Ich fand den lustig, ich fand den absolut unterhaltsam,
ich fand den irgendwie extrem, also die Geschichte.
Ich fand es sehr elegant, wie sie quasi so von dieser Spielwelt,
wie sie das in so einem Flow quasi herleiten, wie das alles zusammenpasst.
Und dann ist die Musik da und alles ist irgendwie da, aber nichts nervt.
Ist lustig. Ich muss sagen, also ich bin,
Ich weiß, ich bin immer so ein bisschen zickig, was so Spiele betrifft,
aber bei Nintendo mache ich wirklich eine Ausnahme.
Und das hätte ich nicht gedacht, weil das hat mich auch sehr spät eingefangen,
weil ich hatte früher kein Nintendo.
Also das ging alles irgendwie an mir vorbei, so 10, 64 und so weiter.
Ich war irgendwie immer am Computer und so Spielekonsole hatte ich nie.
und ich muss aber sagen, Nintendo fängt mich immer wieder ein mit seinem Charme.
Also es ist halt einfach so dieses Non-Destruktive, da muss man nicht immer
alle umbringen, da muss man nicht irgendwie mit dem Auto alle umfahren und muss nichts kaputt machen.
Und trotzdem ist es irgendwie für Kids geil und es ist irgendwie aber auch trotzdem,
finde ich, für Große auch immer super charming und lustig.
Und das finde ich einfach irre, wie die das so als Unternehmenskultur über so
einen langen Zeitraum so gut aufrechterhalten haben.
Ohne jemals, glaube ich, so richtig mal ihren Pfad verloren zu haben, oder?
Gab es irgendwann mal so, wo Nintendo mal so...
Nee, Nintendo war schon immer eine Bange.
Vor allen Dingen, was sie auch nie machen, ist die Preise reduzieren.
Naja gut, die Switch ist schon wieder geworden.
Nein, aber die Spiele...
Die Spiele nicht.
Die Spiele kosten immer das Gleiche, das Gleiche wie von Tag 1 an.
Und, aber man merkt auch, die haben, die nehmen sich Zeit, den Scheiß fertig zu kochen.
Ja, Attention to detail.
Also ein Spiel, was Nintendo halb fertig rausgehauen hat, gut,
es wird vielleicht ein Beispiel geben, aber es sind eigentlich sehr, sehr selten.
So, jetzt wollte ich nur abschließend zu diesem MacNini noch was sagen.
Und zwar, also wenn man einen Rechner braucht, wo ein macOS draufläuft und das
soll leise irgendwo in der Ecke stehen und nicht ganz so viel tun,
dann ist es der richtige Rechner für alles andere.
Ist er entweder zu teuer oder zu clunky oder zu, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist doch eigentlich der perfekte Rechner, indem man irgendwie den Eltern hinstellt, oder?
Das gehört auch zum Thema, er steht irgendwo, tut leise Dinge.
Nö, da möchte ich den iMac nehmen.
Also ich habe meiner Mutter auch schon einen Mac Mini hingestellt,
also schon lange vor dem.
Und sie war damit eigentlich auch immer sehr zufrieden, weil der hat halt einfach
funktioniert und trägt mich weiter auf.
Und so gesehen, Eltern hinstellen ist auch eine gute Idee.
aber also er ist wahrscheinlich keine echte Alternative zu so einem Mac Studio,
oder allen anderen Macs, wo irgendwie ein Display drin ist oder so also wenn
man das braucht und das muss transportabel sein,
und dann, und das hatten wir ja auch so ein bisschen erwähnt,
die Preisleiter für, ich mache aus dieser doch eigentlich etwas,
unterkonfigurierten Maschine etwas was ein sinnvolles Spec hat,
wird direkt sauteuer.
Also das ist halt was, wo man so denkt so ja okay.
Und das ist aber nicht nur bei dem Mac Mini so, das war bei dem Mac Studio den
ich mir hier gekauft habe, war auch genauso und das war halt auch so ein bisschen
cringe, weil man sich halt immer denkt so ja,
eigentlich super Preis-Leistungs Verhältnis, aber kaum will man da mal ein bisschen
Bling Bling drin haben, bezahlt man es eigentlich schon wieder alles doppelt und dreifach.
Wo dann immer so ein bisschen das Argument wegfällt was ich ja gerne habe, dass diese Macs,
sich auch so ein bisschen über ihren Werterhalt definieren. Und das stimmt dann wiederum auch.
Du kannst auch nach drei, vier Jahren das zusätzlich investierte Geld auch immer
noch rechtfertigen, weil da war ja mal so teuer.
Und die Leute kaufen den auch gebraucht immer noch zu dem höheren Preis.
Ja, wenn du zu Rebuy gehst, also es ist jetzt kein Endorsement,
aber da kann man halt auch gebrauchte Mac Minis kaufen und die sind vom Preis
her auch immer so, wo du so denkst, vielleicht kaufst du doch neu.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so richtig billiger als, ne?
Also es ist jetzt einfacher geworden, weil einfach die Grundspeicherausstattung jetzt auf 16 hoch ist.
Also dieses vorher so, nee, nimm den lieber nicht links oben mit 8 GB RAM.
Das reicht dann doch vielleicht hier und da nicht.
So, wo das Problem jetzt los ist, finde ich, ist ja für ganz,
ganz viele Menschen einfach in der Standardausstattung völlig ausreichend.
Also Festplatte, das hält ja sehr davon an.
Brauchst es oder hast du sowieso Naja gut.
Aber ich meine, eine 4-Tera-SSD mit Gehäuse kriegst du halt auch schon für 300 Euro.
400 Euro. Kannst du hinten dran packen und gut ist.
Und dongelst du hinten dran und das ist gut, ist ja sowieso ein Rechner,
der nicht bewegt wird. Also außer man schaltet ihn ein, aber.
Es gibt bestimmt bald Gehäuse, wo man das draufstellen kann.
Das gab es doch für ein Studio auch.
Es gibt ein Gehäuse, ich habe es nur noch nicht gedruckt, wo man den so senkrecht
reinstellt und dann sieht er aus wie so ein Mac Pro, so ein Cheese Grater Mac
Pro mit Händel obendrauf und so weiter.
Oh, süß.
Ja, richtig süß.
Sehr schön fand ich auch, ich habe schon zwei Videos gesehen,
Links habe ich jetzt gerade nicht zur Hand, aber findet ihr bestimmt gleich
im Chat, wo jemand einen alten iMac G4 genommen hat.
Das sind die weißen, ne?
Das sind diese weißen mit der Teleskopstange, wo quasi der Bildschirm frei bewegt werden kann.
Ach so ein...
Diese halbrunde Kugel.
Ja, der halbe Fußball, diese...
Genau.
Schreibtischlampe.
Genau, und dann eben so mit der Halterung, die du jetzt so am Studiodisplay
hast, aber den nur quasi in jede Richtung. Genau, die Schreibtischlampe.
Den hatte ich übrigens mal. Das war wirklich ein ganz, ganz feines Gerät.
und ja, gibt es so Videos, so halb Restauration, halb Reaktivierungs Ding.
Das erste, was ich gesehen hatte, war, da wurde das Innere eines vorherigen
Mac Minis da reingebaut.
Das war dann schon eine ziemliche Prozedur.
Ja, aber das ist auch nicht groß, weil da ist ja auch das Netzteil mit drin und allem.
Ja, es passte da rein. Das Besondere mit dem Mac Mini, jetzt mit dem neuen,
den du da hast, war, dass du unten durchs Loch den ganzen Mac Mini mit Gehäuse reintun konntest.
Also du kannst dir wirklich so eine Lampe irgendwie auf Ebay schießen,
dann legst du das Ding mal ein bisschen ins.
Bleichbad und machst den mal richtig sauber und putzt mal alles schön mit Alkohol
ab und guckst dir vielleicht noch drei, vier, fünf Electronic Restoration Videos
an, wie man das ordentlich macht. Da kann ich auch gleich noch einen Kanal zu empfehlen.
Und dann schiebst du unten einfach ein Mac Mini ran und dann musst du nur noch
so Bildschirm musst du gucken, also in dem einen Fall, was ich gesehen hatte,
hat er dann den Bildschirm auch noch, weil der hatte halt nicht die hohe Auflösung
damals, natürlich nicht,
aber er hat dann aus irgendeinem 14, was war das, 14 Zoll?
16 Zoll MacBook, einen alten Bildschirm rausgenommen und ein bisschen fitzelig
da diese Kabel neu durch diesen Fuß durchzuführen.
Auf jeden Fall am Ende einfach geiles Gehäuse, geile Halterung und schicker
Bildschirm und unten halt so ein Mac-Menü drin. War schon echt ziemlich cool.
Ja, also ich bin da auch durchaus angetan. Ich finde das Line-Up ist super.
Trotzdem bin ich auch ganz froh mit meinem Mac-Studio.
Den habe ich ja jetzt seit einem Jahr ungefähr und bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden.
Diese Maschine macht auch überhaupt gar keine Probleme. Überhaupt keine Geräusche.
Ich habe ihn mir in teuer gekauft. Ich habe ja, ich wollte ihn so ein bisschen,
fetter haben und musste dann die entsprechende Strafgebühr dafür bezahlen.
Du musstest fetter bezahlen.
Ja, aber ich weiß halt auch, wenn ich den mal wieder verkaufe,
werde ich halt auch einen angemessenen Preis dafür erzielen.
Und wenn ich ihn kurzfristig verkaufe, dann werde ich sogar einen relativ guten
Preis dafür erzielen, weil es halt einfach immer noch eine konkurrenzfähige Maschine ist.
Okay, Roddy hat jetzt gerade mal ein Bild von dem gerade eben erwähnten Mini-Case
und das ist nicht nur irgendwie cute und süß, sondern das ist beyond awesome.
Das sieht so schrill aus.
Bitte druck dir das doch mal und bring es dann mal mit zusammen. Das ist ja so knuffig.
Fantastisch.
Ja, das kann ich mal machen.
Das ist wirklich lustig. Hello, adorable.
Ja, sehr schön. Da steht der McMini vor allem genau mit der Lüftung.
Das ist ja ganz pfiffig, weiß nicht, das wissen wahrscheinlich auch schon alle,
aber das fand ich jetzt echt gut,
dass sie quasi das Ansaugen und austreten lassen, der warmen,
also Ansaugen der kalten oder kälteren Luft und dann das Austreten der wärmeren
Luft, beides über diesen Ring unten am Fuß realisieren.
Ich glaube vorne ziehen sie die kalte Luft und hinten geht die warme Luft raus.
Ja, ich glaube.
Das heißt, sie haben halt innen so einen Leitweg, wo dann die Luft einmal durchs
ganze Gehäuse geführt wird.
Nicht ganz. Also da ist eine Heepipe drin, die die Hitze vom Silicon wegzieht
und dann ist glaube ich der Weg der Luft gar nicht so weit.
Also sie haben natürlich einen Lüfter, der es ansorgt und hinten wieder rauspustet,
aber ich glaube die ganze untere Hälfte ist nur der Lüfter quasi.
Ja hier ist nochmal wie er dann neben dem echten Cheese Grater steht so Mama
und Kind so nebeneinander es.
Hat so Pixar Vibes.
Sehr schön ja.
Wer es noch schneller haben will, es gibt den Mac Mini ja auch den Pro.
Also mit einem M4 Pro. Aber da geht es, glaube ich, bei 1.2 oder so überhaupt
erst mal los. Mit wenig Speicher.
Der hat aber auch gleich 24 GB RAM und ich glaube auch die größere SSD.
Also das ist eigentlich auch ein Schnäppchen.
Zumal er dann auch noch Thunderbolt 5 hat.
und nicht nur Thunderbolt 4 und das ist natürlich nichts, was jetzt heute sofort
einen Unterschied macht, aber so perspektivisch, insbesondere wenn man den halt
mit vielen großen Bildschirmen betreiben möchte, dann ist das in der Tat eine interessante Option.
Und da mittlerweile sind sie ja auch gut ausgestattet. Also hinten die drei
Ports sind alle irgendwie Thunderbolt und vorne ist einfach normales USB 3. Ja und das,
kann man schon vertreten. Also da ist derzeit relativ wenig Schlechtes dabei.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie keinen großen iMac verkaufen, aber sie werden es sicherlich wissen.
Der M4 Pro hat dann mal eben so 10 Performance Cores statt 4 bei deiner kleinen
Variante plus nochmal 4 Efficiency Cores, also 14. Das ist dann schon mal eine Bank.
Und die sind dann als Einzel-CPUs die schnellsten, die es gerade überhaupt gibt.
Also da sieht dann hier auch mal ein M2 Pro schon ganz schön alt aus.
Tja also für mich wird das wahrscheinlich eher zu dem Zeitpunkt ein Thema,
wo sie dann diesen M4 Max in den Studio tun werden und mal gucken,
ob es dann auch so eine Ultraversion gibt, die ist für mich vielleicht nicht
ganz so interessant aber das wäre glaube ich dann schon,
eher der interessante Punkt Ja.
Ich wollte halt jetzt erstmal nicht nicht so viel Geld drauf werfen,
ich habe lange hin und her überlegt dachte mir, komm jetzt kaufst du mal den
kleinsten, dann hast du irgendwie noch so ein Mac in der Ecke,
der tut dann Mac-Dinge, wenn man das mal braucht und dafür,
legst du jetzt auch nicht ordentlich Geld an, weil dann ist er zwar vielleicht
schneller als das MacBook, was ich habe und zwar deutlich schneller,
aber dann habe ich ihn nicht dabei und dann nervt mich das immer und das ist irgendwie...
Verstehe ich. Gut.
Aber das kann ja jeder entscheiden, wie er möchte.
Genau. Soviel zu den Macs. Kommen wir jetzt vor anderen Themen.
Ralf, it's your turn. Du warst im Urlaub. Im Urlaub.
Ich habe mal eine Woche Urlaub gemacht. Boah, eine Woche. Verrückt.
Luxus.
Quälig verrückt. Eine Woche Herbst Urlaub.
Weißt du noch, wie du heißt.
Und mit der ganzen Familie. Und der Plan war, hey, wir machen mal was ganz Wildes.
Wir fahren in einen Sternenpark.
So, das Konzept von Sternenparks ist vermutlich irgendwie hinreichend.
Nein, das musst du erklären.
Okay, erklären wir es mal. Also, wir leben ja in einer Zivilisation,
in einer Gesellschaft, wo Lichtsmog ein Thema ist.
Das heißt also jetzt nicht nur Smog von irgendwie Industrie und Nebel und so
weiter, sondern Lichtverseuchung.
Das heißt also durch die ganzen großen Städte gibt es kaum einen Ort in Deutschland,
wo es mal wirklich zappenduster ist in der Nacht.
Sondern ständig hat man irgendwo die nächste Großstadt, Autobahn,
was auch immer. Wobei Autobahnen sind ja per se erstmal nicht hell.
Aber im Wesentlichen halt irgendwie Großstädte halt rum. Es gibt aber eben ein
paar Spots, die weit genug weg sind.
Gibt es auch so Light Pollution Maps, kann man sich, gibt es alles gut findbar im Internet.
und ein paar dieser Orte, wo es eben dann doch noch dunkel ist,
haben das quasi jetzt so als Marketing und Tourismus Möglichkeit erkannt und
seitdem gibt es also Sternenparks.
Gibt es schon relativ lange, ich glaube vor 15 Jahren oder sowas sind die ersten
irgendwie aufgekommen.
Und einer von denen ist zufälligerweise in der Rhön. Kennt ihr die Rhön?
Wisst ihr, was die Rhön ist?
Schon mal gehört.
Naja. Das ist so ein persönliches Ding. Ich habe meine halbe Kindheit da verbracht,
weil meine Eltern waren große Wanderfreunde und es ist halt so ein Mittelgebirge,
so ein Dreiländereck zwischen Hessen und Thüringen und Bayern.
Und Wasserkuppe kommt da schon
im Chat, ganz genau. Und die sind halt auch relativ weit ab von allem.
Also Fulda ist da die nächste Stadt und die ist aber auch schon relativ weit weg.
Und von daher ist also jetzt die Rhön einer dieser Sternenparks und wie gerade
im Chat schon geschrieben wurde.
Ich habe mich dann also nicht lumpen lassen und bin dann noch auf den höchsten
Berg von Hessen gegangen.
Und dort oben hatten wir dann also unsere kleine Hütte, direkt quasi im Sternenpark,
auf dem höchsten Berg, wo versprochen wurde, über allen Wolken und sonst was.
Und hatten also den Kofferraum voll mit Teleskop und richtig teurem Ferngläsern
noch und alles sowas, um dort jetzt also mit den Kindern endlich mal so den
Einstieg in die Astronomie zu feiern und zu finden.
Okay, vielleicht noch so ein, zwei Sorte PR-Worte zur Rhön.
Warum ich die Rhön schon bemerkenswert finde, ist, die ist, finde ich,
maximal kindertauglich.
Das heißt also, wenn man irgendwie das Projekt hat, ich will meine Kinder mal zum Wandern bringen.
Ja, Wandern ist ja per se erstmal eine sehr langweilige Angelegenheit und die
Rhön zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass es viele sehr kindertaugliche, spektakuläre,
kleine Berge und Spots und Locations gibt, wo du also einfach viele Ziele hast,
wo du jeden Tag was Neues ansteuerst und das wird nicht langweilig und ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Da kann man also plötzlich dann Felsenklettern machen und Sommerrodelbahn sind
da auch, ist also einiges zu haben.
Und ich habe mal als kleinen Service am geneigten Hörer mal eine Apple Maps
gemacht mit verschiedenen kindertauglichen Locations, wo man da mal vorbeischauen
kann. schmeißen wir vielleicht mal in die Shownotes ab.
Also Ruhen mit Kindern grundsätzlich gute Idee, wenn man mal Wandern ausprobieren
will und Kinder schnell gelangweilt sind.
So, aber das eigentliche Ziel mit jetzt irgendwie ordentlich Sterne gucken,
das war halt nur so, sagen wir mal, semi erfolgreich.
Weil es ist halt Herbst. Und was halt irgendwie einem keiner gesagt hat,
ist, dass halt im Herbst da mal halt einfach überall nur Nebel ist.
Ich habe gerade jetzt mal ein Bild in die Slack reingeworfen.
Das ist nur Nebel, ja.
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie Twin Peaks und auch alles ganz atmosphärisch
und so. Die Stimmung war ganz cool, so Silent Hills Teil.
Das möchte mich also gar nicht beschweren. Gerade dann so die Nachtwanderung
an Halloween war toll da oben mit Nebel, drei Meter Sichtweite.
Aber Sternen gucken ist nicht.
Aber halt so semi geil zum Sterne gucken. Und dann bist du irgendwie fünf,
sechs Tage da und hast fünf Nächte und jede Nacht guckst du raus aus deinem
Wasserkuppen-Scheck und siehst nur Nebel und keinen Stern.
Bis auf eine Stunde. Eine Stunde war es dann mal aufgeklart und dann konnte
man wirklich irgendwie was gucken.
Und dann war das schon beeindruckend, der Unterschied, wenn du sowas hier in
Berlin irgendwie aufbaust, was dann doch rauskommt, gerade so im Bereich von
Planeten und wir hatten auch Glück mit den Konstellationen, dass man dann zumindest
mal Jupiter und Saturn irgendwie vernünftig gucken konnte.
Und das finde ich ist ja schon so ein erhebender Moment. Ich weiß nicht,
habt ihr schon mal so Jupiter-Monde gesehen durch ein Teleskop?
Jupiter habe ich gesehen, Jupiter-Monde habe ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Ich habe mal Saturn mit Ringen gesehen. Das war schon sehr geil.
Stimmt, nee, Saturn war das, genau.
Saturn mit Ringen.
Weil wenn Jupiter...
Also Jupiter sieht man ja auch so am Himmel.
Genau, komme ich gleich zu. Also wenn du Jupiter vernünftig siehst,
dann siehst du auch Dämonen da eigentlich drum rum.
Wenn also irgendwas an Teleskop hast, weil die sind auch so hell und so in einer
Linie drum rum, dass man da also quasi nicht drum rum gucken kann.
Io, Ganymed, Callisto und Europa. habe ich mir gerade einen Podcast zu gemacht.
In Raumzeit, die neueste Sendung.
Siehst du wohl.
Die Galiläischen Monde.
Die heißen wie, warum? Komm, entleiten uns.
Die heißen Galiläischen Monde, weil Galileo die entdeckt hat.
Weil das die vier sind, die man auch mit schlechten, einfachen Mikroskop,
äh, Teleskop sehen kann. Und die hat er halt sehen können.
Wie viele hat er insgesamt? 30, 40? Irre viele.
Aktueller Count ist 95.
Wahnsinn.
Da ist aber auch viel Kleinkram dabei, oder?
Ja, genau, da ist sehr viel Kleinkram dabei.
Das ist vor allem ein Kleinkram.
Aber es ist so Endcounting, also man geht davon aus.
Den ganzen Dreck, der da rumschwirrt.
Die 100 kriegt man irgendwie auch noch, aber sind zwar nicht ganz so spektakulär
wie die Saturnmonde und so, aber auf jeden Fall jetzt auch nicht zu verachten.
So, und was hatte ich da jetzt so an Equipment dabei? Das ist vielleicht auch
nochmal ganz interessant.
Ich habe mich da vor ein paar Jahren mal mit beschäftigt, weil ich also meinem
älteren Jungen halt ein vernünftiges Teleskop mal schenken wollte und bin dann
also bei einer Bauform gelandet, die mir bis zu dem...
Zeitpunkt auch fremd war, nämlich ein sogenanntes Dobson-Teleskop,
was sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass es im Prinzip so völlig low-tech ist.
Das heißt also, es ist ein Spiegelteleskop, also Okular ist vorne,
großer Spiegel ist hinten und das hat in der Bauform, die ich jetzt hier habe,
und das Ganze ist auf einem sehr einfachen Holzstativ,
was man aber eben dann in zwei Achsen bewegen kann, eben links,
rechts, rauf, runter und damit kann man halt sehr stabil, ohne viel Gewackel und,
klappriges Gestell jeden Ort halt am Himmel gut ansteuern.
Und das ist in dieser speziellen Variante, das ist das Skywatcher Heritage 150,
also ein 150 Millimeter Spiegel drin, ist nochmal besonders,
dass man das ausziehen kann.
Das heißt also, das sieht so
ein bisschen aus, wie hinten die Antriebe von einem Y-Wing aus Star Wars.
Also wo hinten ja diese Gestänge sind und dann ist noch hinten so der letzte Rest vom Triebwerk.
Und da sind halt einfach ganz normale Schrauben, die kannst lösen und dann kannst
du das noch mal so in sich zusammenschieben.
Dann hat das nur die Hälfte der Länge. Das ist natürlich gut.
Für den Transport.
Genau, das kriegst du nämlich so gerade eben noch in den größeren Rucksack rein
und kannst damit also dann irgendwo durch die Gegend hiken und hast trotzdem
ein einigermaßen amtliches Spiegelteleskop dabei.
Also so in der Richtung diese Dobson-Teile, da gibt es natürlich jetzt auch
viele, das muss jetzt überhaupt nicht dieses sein, kostet 300 Euro,
finde ich jetzt nicht rasend viel und dafür kannst du aber halt Saturn bedringen und.
Der macht aber keine Nachführung.
Der macht keine Nachführung. Das kann man dann auch alles dazu kaufen,
aber dann wird das so schnell so teuer, dass man dann in ganz anderen Regionen
irgendwie unterwegs ist.
Wie schwer ist es euch denn gefallen, überhaupt das Teleskop richtig auf diesen
Planeten auszurichten?
Weil das ist natürlich bei dieser Vergrößerung dann schon die eigentliche Herausforderung.
Dazu wollte ich jetzt kommen. Gut, dass du das sagst, Tim.
War nicht angesprochen.
Aber ich dachte mir, dass das ein Thema ist, wo du zu connecten kannst.
Also, ich war ja bei Glaubnis.com auch irgendwann mal Kind.
Was?
Da habe ich mich auch sehr für Astronomie schon interessiert.
Ich habe dann auch wirklich Bücher gelesen.
Und mein Vater hat versucht, das auch zu unterstützen und hat mir damals schon
ein ganz brauchbares, normales Teleskop.
Wie heißt die Bauform, wenn es nicht ein Spiegelteleskop ist?
Ein Refraktor. Refraktor, genau, danke.
Kein Reflektor, sondern ein Refraktor.
Ein Refraktorteleskop, also einfach so ein langgezogenes Linsen-Teleskop, wie man das so kennt.
Und das war gar nicht schlecht, das war auch gar nicht billig.
Ich habe nie irgendetwas damit gefunden.
Also Mond, ja, das ging, Krater, ich habe keinen Planeten gesehen,
ich habe keine irgendwie Andromeda-Galaxie, komme aber gleich noch zu, gesehen, nichts.
So, das heißt also, meine ganze Kindheit war eine einzige deprimierende Abfolge
von, ich war irgendwie nachts draußen mit dem Teleskop und nichts halt mehr.
Weil es gab halt auch nur scheiß Sternenkarten, ja, so diese 2D-Dinger,
wo du also gerade ungefähr gucken kannst, so, was sind die Sternenbilder?
Aber da war halt nirgendwo zu sehen, wo ist denn jetzt irgendwie Jupiter?
Und wenn du dann in der Tageszeitung, damals hatte man noch Tageszeitung,
hattest du irgendwie teilweise dann mal so Astronomie-Einheiten,
so, Achtung, Jupiter steht heute im so und so und dann guckte ich da hin und das war alles scheiße.
Oh Gott. Was hätte aus dir werden können.
Was hätte aus dir werden können, ja. So, aber damit es euch mit euren Kindern
daraus ein Anlass ergeht, jetzt mal so ein paar One-on-One-Tipps für den schnellen...
Den schnellen Erfolg beim Sterne gucken. Hätte mir damals mal ein paar simple
Weisheiten gesagt, wäre alles einfacher geworden.
Das erste Mal, was diese modernen Teleskope haben, die haben so Zielvisiere,
wie du sie auch in der Army hast.
Diese Reflektor, das sind ja nicht Laser, sondern so holographische Zielsucher,
wo du so einen kleinen roten Punkt hast.
die Counter-Strike-Spieler müssen jetzt mal kurz im Chat aushalten,
wie diese Visiere heißen.
Wo es egal ist, quasi in welchem Winkel du drauf guckst, der rote Zielpunkt
ist immer an derselben Stelle.
Das ist eine spezielle Bauart von Visieren. Das kommt bestimmt gleich irgendwie im Chat.
Das ist doch aber dann bestimmt ein Laser, oder nicht?
Nee, es geht... Ja, ich glaube fast nicht, dass es ein Laser ist.
Aber kann auch sein, dass es aber... Es geht halt nicht darum,
dass der irgendwo hin projiziert, sondern dass er quasi nur in dein Auge geleitet.
Crosshair wird hier als Reflexvisier.
Das ist es, genau, ein Reflexvisier. Hast du schon mal eins gehabt?
Bring ich ansonsten mal mit, das ist total cool. Wenn man das noch nie gesehen
hat, denkt man auch so, was ist das für ein physikalisches?
Weil normalerweise, wenn du jetzt irgendwie so eine Spielzeugpistole oder was
auch immer vor dir hast mit einem normalen Visier und irgendwie Kimme und Korn
und alles wackelt und so und diese Reflexvisiere, die haben einfach so ein bisschen wie Magie.
Also egal, wo du jetzt reinguckst, Der Zielpunkt ist wirklich immer an der exakt
selben Stelle und bewegt sich quasi also mit in Verhältnis zu dem,
was du mit deinen Augen machst.
Und das führt dazu, da ist halt so ein Reflexvisier drin.
Da hat die Wikipedia ein schönes Animated GIF.
Ah ja, genau, das hilft schon so ein bisschen. Da sieht man jetzt hier so ein
Flugzeug mit einem Reflexvisier erfasst und egal wie ich meinen Kopf bewege,
ich sehe immer, wo ich quasi gerade hinballern würde an der Stelle.
So und das führt dazu schon mal, dass dieses, ich richte mein Teleskop aus und
da wo dieser rote Punkt hin zeigt, das ist dann auch wirklich das,
was ich in einer starken Vergrößerung sehe, bis auf wirklich ganz,
ganz wenige irgendwie Bogenmillimeter,
das entspannt schon mal die Sache ungeheuer.
Also weil das eigentliche Problem ist ja, dass wenn du durchs Teleskop schaust,
dann siehst du einen super vergrößerten Bereich und hast jetzt keine Ahnung
wo und welche Richtung und wie schnell und so weiter und dann findest du irgendwie gar nichts.
Und wenn man halt erstmal sagt, okay ich schau mir das jetzt hier Big Picture
mäßig an und da ist ja Jupiter und dann mach ich den roten Punkt da drauf,
dann weiß ich, das Teleskop zeigt da schon mal drauf und dann passt das.
Genau, das ist also das erste Problem, besorgt euch ein Reflexvisier.
Zweiter Punkt ist, Jupiter und Saturn sind mal echt einfach zu finden.
Es gibt praktisch nichts Helleres da am Himmel.
Das heißt, wenn du so eine App hast, der Mond, klar, und Sirius und sowas noch,
aber wirklich nicht Venus.
Venus vielleicht noch.
Venus, wenn sie auch da ist. Es gibt mittlerweile ja viele so Stargazer-Apps.
Starlink ist auch noch relativ hell.
Ja, da habe ich etliche gesehen, die da durchgehuscht sind in der Tat.
Wenn man immer denkt, da ist so eine Kette plötzlich und es nimmt gar kein Ende
und was ist da los? Das sind keine Sternschnuppen.
Stellarium habe ich verwendet, aber da kommen wir gleich zu,
weil ich habe zu dem Thema auch noch was.
Genau, also man nimmt halt sein iPhone, lädt sich irgendeine beliebige dieser
Sternen-Apps runter, die ich finde auch schwierig sind von der GUI her,
Aber es reicht eben zu sagen, ist überhaupt Jupiter und Saturn gerade irgendwo zu sehen?
Wenn ja, vage in welcher Richtung? Und dann guckt ihr einfach in die Richtung
und das mit Abstand hellste Objekt, das ist euer Planet. Nicht weiter rumfrummeln.
Da muss ich sagen, muss ich wirklich mal eine Lanze brechen für Stellarium.
Stellarium hat nämlich den Gyro-Modus.
Und mit dem Gyro und dem Magnetkompass und so weiter kann der wirklich erkennen,
in welche Richtung ich gucke.
und dann kannst du mit ausgestrecktem Arm, hast du dann das Telefon,
wo die ganzen Sterne drauf sind, dann guckst du an den Himmel und siehst die
Sterne und siehst dann, okay, da und da ist das Objekt, da müsste es ungefähr sein.
Das haben aber all diese Dinge.
Das haben die alle.
Starry Night und wie heißt die alle?
Ich habe jetzt hier Night Sky und da sehe ich, also da vorne ist jetzt hier Jupiter.
Nur beispielsweise jetzt hier Night Sky, finde ich, ist sehr schlecht darin,
irgendwie, da sind einfach schon viel zu viele Sterne, die abgezeichnet werden.
Meistens siehst du ja gar nicht so viele, sondern willst erst mal nur so die
großen Markanten haben.
Wie auch immer. Also wenn ihr dann irgendwie das wirklich helle Objekt seht,
das ist euer Planet, damit versucht es dann mal.
So und was aber ein wirklicher Mindfuck war, da musste ich glaube ich irgendwie
50 Jahre alt werden, um das mal zu sehen und zu begreifen.
Ich habe halt immer versucht...
Sachen wie die Andromeda-Galaxie mir mal anzugucken. Mit den Teleskopen.
So, und dann hast du da halt dein...
Die im Übrigen, das muss man ja vielleicht noch dazu erwähnen,
für die astronomisch nicht so kundigen, unsere große Nachbar-Galaxie ist,
die man halt im Prinzip noch mit einem bloßen Auge erkennen kann,
wenn die Bedingungen wirklich richtig gut sind.
Und die eigenen Augen nicht schon zu schlecht sind.
So, und was habe ich aber gemacht? Du nimmst halt so eine App und hast dann
da dein tolles Teleskop und nimmst eine mittlere Vergrößerung,
wo du dann also auf dem Mond irgendwie gut Krater angucken kannst dir.
Und dann richtest du das halt auf den Ort, wo du ziemlich genau weißt,
da ist jetzt Andromeda. Jetzt wollen wir mal gucken.
Was siehst du? Nichts. So und warum?
Weil dieses Viech absurd groß ist.
Ich habe jetzt hier mal ein Bild reingepostet. Das ist jetzt ein Fake,
das ist eine Montage, was aber mal zeigt, wie groß die Andromeda-Galaxie ist,
wenn sie wahnsinnig hell wäre im Vergleich zum Mond.
Und da siehst du, dass die Ausmaße der Andromeda-Galaxie so das vier- bis fünffache des Mondes ist.
Dieses Viech ist riesig. Wenn du jetzt natürlich ein Teleskop hast mit einer
großen Vergrößerung, wo du dir einen Mondkrater anguckst und jetzt irgendwo
mit der Vergrößerung in die Andromeda-Galaxie reingehst, natürlich siehst du da nichts.
Was sollst du da sehen? Weil du quasi nur einen winzigen Staubhaufen irgendwie auflöst an der Stelle.
Das heißt also, du brauchst eine ganz andere Herangehensweise dafür.
Du musst halt wirklich einen super dunklen Sternenhimmel haben und dann brauchst
du eben ganz wenig Vergrößerung bis gar keine Vergrößerung und musst aber wahnsinnig
viel Licht halt einfach in dein Spiegelteleskop reinkriegen.
Dann hast du eine Chance, zumindest einen milchigen Fleck irgendwie vernünftig
zu sehen, der was hermacht.
Vergrößerung ist das Gegenteil von dem, was du da irgendwie brauchst.
Und das ist bei fast all diesen bekannteren Elementen der Fall.
Orionnebel, genau dasselbe Problem. Der ist auch einfach mal ziemlich groß.
Orion ist ja auch eines der bekanntesten Sternbilder, die man so hat.
Wo du also diese drei Gürtelsterne hast und von da aus hat man dann quasi so
eine Schnalle nach unten und wenn man sich das anguckt, ist das das Schwert, genau.
Und da ist dann eben der Orion-Nebel drin und auch der ist viel zu groß,
als dass du ihn mit einem vergrößernden Teleskop vernünftig irgendwie kriegen könntest.
Also ein sehr teures Fernglas mit wenig Vergrößerung, aber viel Lichteinfall
ist da viel besser geeignet. Und warum hat mir das keiner gesagt als Kind,
dass es völlig witzlos ist, mit einer großen Vergrößerung nach solchen Sachen zu suchen.
Ich finde, das müsste man Leuten irgendwie in der Schule beibringen oder so.
In der DDR gab es Astronomie als Fach in der Schule, aber das ist jetzt lange her.
Ich glaube, in einigen neuen Ländern gibt es es noch als Wahlfach.
So, ich habe jetzt hier nochmal einmal den Orion-Nebel, wie groß der ist im
Vergleich zum Gesamtensemble.
Und dieser etwas hellere Fleck da unten, der ist halt auch hervorgehoben und so unter den Gürteln.
Hinweis?
Audio-Podcast.
Audio-Podcast, genau, darum versuche ich es ja gerade zu beschreiben.
Da muss man mehr Mühe geben noch.
Noch mehr Mühe, okay.
Nein, wir sehen, das ist der Satz.
Der verboten ist. Ihr könntet sehen, googelt es.
Ihr seht nicht. Wenn ihr sehen könntet.
Also der Orion hat außen vier Sterne, die so ein Trapez ausbilden.
Und in der Mitte drei, die sind so schräg waagrecht.
Das ist der Gürtel. und unter dem Gürtel gibt es dieses, was immer als Schwert
bezeichnet wird, nochmal drei Sterne und ich glaube der mittlere, ist das der Nebel?
Genau, der in der Mitte, das ist der Nebel. Und was immer, wenn man jetzt googelt
und halt irgendwie Bilder vom Orion-Nebel halt sucht, was dann von Hubble und
sonstigen Geschichten kommt,
so vergesst es, das werdet ihr nie in einem Teleskop sehen, das sind alles Langzeitbelichtungen.
das ist so ein Level, den ich noch probieren werde, so ich habe auch so eine
Konstruktion, dass ich mein iPhone da dran hänge und eine Langzeitbelichtung
durchs Teleskop machen kann, hat jetzt aber dafür hatte ich jetzt einfach mal
nicht genug Zeit, weil es war nur eine Stunde lang überhaupt was zu sehen,
aber das würde ich irgendwann nochmal ausprobieren, wie weit man damit kommt,
aber das, was ich bisher recherchiert habe, ist, man kann vergessen
irgendeine dieser Deep Sky Geschichten vernünftig durch ein Teleskop selber
zu betrachten, auch diese ganzen Farben sind alle herprozessuiert und genau.
Weil das wollte ich noch hinzufügen, also Hubble schaut nicht nur länger hin und hat,
fängt sowieso mehr Licht ein, es sind auch ganz andere Frequenzbereiche,
die halt außerhalb des für uns sichtbaren Lichts sind, die dann in diesen Bildern,
die man kennt, halt auch noch mit rein koloriert werden.
Das heißt, man sieht eben auch teilweise Infrarot-Anteile und UV-Anteile,
die halt dann, sagen wir mal, schon für das Wesen der Erkennung,
was denn da so ist, relevant ist, aber die eben so sich niemals im Auge abbilden würden,
selbst wenn das Auge so groß wäre wie die ganze Erde.
Und Infrarot und so Zeug.
Genau. Und ja, das muss man dabei bedenken.
Aber darum geht es ja glaube ich auch irgendwie nicht. Ich finde das connectet
schon sehr, wenn man so diese Planeten sieht. Das ist so ein Bestätigungsding.
So ja, die Verschwörungstheoretiker können sich einfach mal ablegen irgendwie.
Raumpatrouille Orion ist ja keine Verschwörungstheorie.
Und von daher kann ich das absolut nachvollziehen, dass so ein Realitätskontakt ganz gut ist.
Kannst du denn noch alle Planeten in der richtigen Reihenfolge aufzählen, Ralf?
Jetzt von der Sonne aus?
Ja, also unsere Planeten.
Gucken wir doch mal. Also erst haben wir Merkur, dann haben wir Venus,
dann haben wir Erde, dann haben wir Mars, dann haben wir Jupiter,
dann haben wir Saturn, dann haben wir Neptun, Uranus und Pluto ist ja nicht mehr.
Fast.
War da irgendwo ein Haken drin?
Mein Vater erklärt uns.
Uns jede Nacht, nee, wie war das?
Unser Vater erklärt uns jeden Sonntag unsere neuen Planeten.
Unsere Nachthimmel.
Also Uranus erst und Neptun und alles, was dahinter ist, Pluto und Eris und
wie sie alle heißen, sind die transneptunischen Objekte.
Daran kann man sich mal merken, dass Neptun sozusagen derzeit die aktuelle Begrenzung ist.
Auch wenn ja die Debatte um Planet 9 immer noch heiß läuft.
Ist nicht mehr Planet X, aber wenn man halt einen weg macht,
dann rückt der halt auf Platz 9 vor.
Wo war denn der Fehler bei mir? War doch eigentlich richtig, oder?
Nee, du hast erst Neptun und dann Uranus genannt, aber das kann ich jetzt verzeihen.
Das sind wirklich die beiden, die man schnell mal durcheinander bekommt.
Man kann es sich halt ganz gut merken an den transneptunischen Objekten.
Und vor allen Dingen nicht erklärt uns, sondern erklärt mir, weil das ist ja der Mars.
Der Mars, ja.
Ja, genau. Genau.
Mars finde ich ja eher langweilig durch Teleskop, das lohnt nicht,
aber also geht auf die Planeten und Jupiter und Saturn.
Das rockt schon, wobei der Saturn gerade ja so gedreht ist zur Erde,
dass man die Ringe wirklich nur so als durchgehenden Strich sieht und nicht richtig schön.
Das verschiebt sich ja alle paar Jahre und wir haben jetzt irgendwie so fünf
sehr langweilige Saturnbeobachtungsjahre vor uns, bis er sich irgendwann mal wieder… Obwohl.
Wenn der so ein wirklich richtig scharfer Strich ist, das kann auch gut aussehen.
Was man auch beobachten kann, sind Kometen.
Ja, glaube ich.
Und da ist vor zwei Wochen oder wann es war, jetzt muss ich nochmal gucken,
wann habe ich das Foto gemacht? 22. Oktober.
Okay, ist ein bisschen her. ist tatsächlich ein Komet an uns vorbeimarodiert.
Und jetzt werde ich mal, das geht aber wirklich nur so, dass ich das jetzt tatsächlich
mal in den Slack schmeiße, ein Foto, das ich gemacht habe von jenem, ähm,
Von jenem Kometen und zwar, womit?
Mit dem iPhone.
Aus der Hand. Das halte ich nicht erwartet, dass man den so gut fotografieren kann.
Wolltest du ihn so gut sehen?
Nein, man konnte ihn gar nicht sehen. Durchs Fernglas habe ich ihn gesehen.
Aber ansonsten habe ich im Prinzip nur ins Stellarium geguckt.
Wo ist der in dem Sternbild, was da so in der Nähe war? ja, ungefähr da und
dann schräg von dem runter und habe den dann so mit dem Telefon angepeilt und fotografiert.
Mehrere Fotos gemacht. Man sieht auch noch Wolken, also es war noch nicht mal super klar.
Das ist nicht wie bei Samsung gemalt.
Sondern… Das ist, naja gut, wie sehr vertraust du das?
Man weiß es nicht.
Apple hat Apple Intelligence noch nicht so weit am Start. Also ich glaube, das ist noch echt.
Was für eine Uhrzeit ist das denn? Oder hast du das einfach so hochgezogen in der Helligkeit.
Weil es gerade so nach Nachmittagshimmel aussieht? Ich weiß nicht,
ob das jetzt in den Metadaten steht drin, 19.25 Uhr.
Das war auf dem Drachenberg im Grunewald, mitten in der Stadt quasi.
Es gab ja auch vor ein paar Wochen hier erhöhte Aurorenaktivität.
Ja, das ist mir aber nicht gelungen.
Mir auch nicht, aber nach Freundin von mir tatsächlich und zwar ähnlich wie
du das jetzt hier mit dem Kometen gemacht hast sie hat halt einfach mal in den
Himmel hinein fotografiert wo angeblich was sein soll wo man aber so mit dem
Auge nichts sehen konnte und die Kamera des Telefons konnte dann aber wirklich
eine schöne grüne Aurora dort,
auflösen das ist so ein bisschen so dieser,
Image Fulgurator Effekt,
Wenn euch das noch was sagt.
Nee.
Der Image Fulgurator hat mal den Pre-Ars-Elektronika-Preis, den Hauptpreis gewonnen.
Wie ich finde, total zu Recht. Das ist eines der tollsten Kunstprojekte,
die ich überhaupt bisher kennengelernt habe.
Und zwar hat der junge Mann eine ganz normale Spiegelreflexkamera genommen.
Aber er hat sie nicht als Kamera benutzt, sondern als Projektor.
Mit dem besonderen Spin, und da müssen wir uns jetzt auch nochmal 10,
20 Jahre zurückdenken, das ist jetzt so vor 15 Jahren gewesen,
wo die allermeisten Kameras, mit denen die Leute noch rumgelaufen sind,
in der Regel auch Blitz ausgelöst haben, weil sie eben noch nicht so lichtsensibel waren.
Und was er jetzt gemacht hat, also er hat eine relativ große Spiegelreflexkamera
mit so einem dicken fetten Objektiv vorne dran, aber es war halt kein Film eingelegt,
sondern es war quasi ein Blitz dort eingebaut.
Und ein Dia, ne?
Und außerdem gab es noch einen Blitzdetektor. Also da oben, wo normalerweise
man bei einer alten Kamera einen Blitzwürfel oder so etwas oder einen Blitzaufstecker
erwarten würde, war ein Sensor.
Ein Blitzsensor. Und was er jetzt gemacht hat, ist, er ist an Orte gegangen
wie Checkpoint Charlie, wo ganz viele Touristen rumstehen und die ganze Zeit
klick, klick, klick, klick, alles fotografieren.
Hat seine Kamera... da quasi auch platziert an den Ort, wo alle hinzeigen.
Die Leute haben auf ihre Kamera gedrückt, der Blitz wurde ausgelöst.
Seine Kamera hat den Blitz über den Sensor zur Kenntnis genommen,
ihrerseits den internen Blitz ausgelöst und damit das Dia in diese Szenerie
hinein projiziert für diesen kurzen Blitzmoment.
Und alle Touristen hatten dieses Bild, was sie so nicht gesehen haben, auf ihr Kameras.
Geil.
Und damit ist er dann sogar nach China gefahren auf den Tiananmenplatz und hat
das irgendwie so auf diese Mao-Bilder und so weiter eine Friedenstaube drauf projiziert.
Da musst du wirklich richtig Eier haben.
Und ja, das war dann immer der Effekt, die Leute fotografieren das,
gucken sich dann auf ihrem Bildschirm, den es dann schon gab,
irgendwie an, so was habe ich denn da fotografiert? Und so, hä?
Warte mal, gucken dann wieder ungläubig nach oben und wieder auf ihre Kamera,
wo war das denn jetzt? Naja und so ein bisschen ist es hier auch mit diesen
iPhone-Bildern von irgendwelchen Himmelsphänomenen Du siehst halt normalerweise
gar nichts Klickst und auf einmal ist auch irgendwas da Das.
Ist ja total großartig Sag mal wie hieß.
Das? Image Fulgurator, das dürfte auch ganz gut dokumentiert sein,
Das ist ein fantastisches Projekt von Julius von Bismarck.
Da gibt es auch eine Wikipedia-Seite dazu, wie sich das auch gehört. Wirklich fantastisch.
Ich dachte jetzt bis zu vier Fünftel deiner Geschichte so, okay,
what's the point? Was soll das?
Ich hatte davon schon mal gehört.
Klar.
Und auf Fotos gesehen, es ist relativ geil.
Es ist so eine wunderbare Idee auf so vielen Ebenen.
Also es ist technisch, es ist einfach eine geile Umsetzung. Es ist super analog,
es ist einfach, aber es ist dann eben einfach von seinem kulturellen Effekt
her einfach auch irre gut.
Und auch diese ganze Debatte, die du damit hast, mit was ist irgendwie real
und wie ist meine Wahrnehmung durch Technik und so weiter, also da kannst du,
toll. Also wirklich ein fantastisches Projekt.
Gibt es auch Videos, wo er dann halt das Ding zum Einsatz bringt,
da auf dem Platz des himmlischen Friedens und so weiter.
Und eine große weiße Friedenstaubequell über Mao. Ja, sehr schön.
Hier ist die offizielle Seite, der hat auch viele Sachen gemacht,
das war natürlich so gleich sein Durchbruch, genau hier ist die Seite,
wo auch dieses Mao Ding ist,
das genau, ja also toll, einfach nur großartig und das muss man erstmal bringen.
Hier, Bundesadler auf Polizisten auf Demos.
Das ist schon fantastisch. Papst, Obama, alle mussten drin glauben.
Gut.
Oh Mann.
So viel zur modernen Klernenbeobachtung.
Ja, aber ohne so eine Sternen-App kommt man eigentlich wirklich nicht weiter.
Die sind aber auch alle nicht teuer, glaube ich.
Übrigens, deprimierendes Ende. Meine Jungs haben sich da null für interessiert.
Papa hatte Spaß.
Papa hatte Spaß. Ja, ja, genau.
Die Jugend von heute.
Das beruhigt mich in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ja.
So, was haben wir noch auf unserer tollen Liste?
wir könnten mal wieder so ein bisschen in unsere KI-Ecke abdriften.
Vielleicht so eine Kleinigkeit,
vorab. Ich habe so ein bisschen rumgespielt. Man kann jetzt in,
der Macintosh, wahrscheinlich geht es auch woanders, weiß nicht,
aber die Mac-App auf jeden Fall auf dem Mac, die Desktop-App von ChatGPT hat
jetzt ein kleines Feature bekommen.
wo man ChatGPT mit anderen Programmen verbinden kann.
Da ist ja so ein Icon dazu und dann kann man es mit verschiedenen Programmen verbinden.
Zum Beispiel mit dem Terminal.
Es geht mit Visual Code, dem Programmiereditor TextEdit und Xcode.
Vielleicht planen sie noch mehr, aber das geht jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal.
Ich habe das dann mit Visual Code ausprobiert.
Und was es macht, ist quasi, du kannst dann in deinem Programmiereditor,
in dem Visual Code, hast halt irgendwelche Source-Code offen und kannst den
dann quasi einfach befragen.
Du musst da nicht alles reinpasten, sondern kannst halt sagen,
so ja, hier kannst du mal bitte gucken, was da nicht in Ordnung ist.
Und das kam ganz handy, weil ich gerade so ein bisschen das Problem habe auf
meinem Server, dass ich da so eine etwas exzessive Liste an Fehlermeldungen im Log-File habe.
Und das war so veralteter, vergammelter PHP-Code, der aus bestimmten Gründen
da noch laufen muss, aber sozusagen an die modernen Versionen von PHP,
die ja mittlerweile laufen, nicht mehr so ganz angepasst ist.
Und da ich mich eigentlich mit sowas überhaupt nicht beschäftigen kann und will,
Aber trotzdem dieses Problem hatte, dachte ich mir so, fragst du mal die Intelligenz?
Und hab dann halt so, ja, kannst du mir mal sagen, was jetzt hier irgendwie
mal korrigiert werden muss, damit die Fehlermeldungen aufhören,
ohne dass es die Funktionalität jetzt einschränkt?
Und das funktioniert tatsächlich ganz gut, weil es in der Regel immer nur so
Kleinigkeiten sind mit, ja, hier, du musst gucken, ob das hier auch da ist und
wenn du einfach drauf zugreifst und das gibt es nicht, dann gibt es gleich eine
Fehlermeldung und so weiter.
Und so konnte ich dann also mein Fehleraufkommen schon mal so um 90% gefühlt
reduzieren, indem ich einfach da über die Brücke da gemacht habe.
Es wäre natürlich jetzt auch anders gegangen, aber es ging dann halt auch so,
kannst halt auch ein komplettes Repo offenhalten in deinem Code-Editor und dann
kann man theoretisch da ja irgendwie überall rumschauen.
Es geht aber glaube ich nur mit geöffneten Fenstern, also muss man irgendwie
mehrere Files gleichzeitig aufmachen.
Das würde wahrscheinlich auch noch alles funktionieren.
Und dann meinte er so, ja, hier, da gibt es das und das Problem.
Und es ist schon ganz erstaunlich, wie, naja, ich will es nicht akkurat sagen,
aber es wird halt, die Zahl an neu eingetragenen Fehlern ist überschaubar.
Ich bin da relativ gnadenlos vorgegangen und habe gesagt, so ein Fix,
ja, zack, bumm, einfach mal auf
den Server geladen geguckt, so scheint zu laufen, passt schon irgendwie.
ja, es waren jetzt keine wichtigen Dinge, aber ich wollte einfach,
dass die Fehlermeldungen weggehen. Das sah dann auch irgendwie alles ganz sinnvoll aus.
Muss mir auch nochmal genauer anschauen. Also so ein kleiner Hack,
mit dem man jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen rumspielen kann.
Kleine Erweiterung noch. Etwas, was ich heute erst erfahren habe,
da habe ich ja nur ganz kurz mit rumgespielt. Es gibt von Visual Code jetzt einen Fork.
Ist ja Open Source von Microsoft. Und es gibt jetzt einen Fork, der heißt Cursor.
Und Cursor ist quasi dasselbe Visual Code, sieht ein bisschen,
ganz klein bisschen anders aus, aber im Wesentlichen dasselbe Ding.
Und dort sind aber schon die LLMs von Cloud, ChatGPT, noch so ein paar,
alle irgendwie mit integriert.
Das heißt, du hast dann quasi deinen Chat direkt in deinem Code-Editor mit drin,
kannst einfach so Code markieren, Apfel L und kannst dann irgendwie zu diesem
markierten Code direkt Fragestellungen machen und dann,
was weiß ich, formatier mir das um oder find dir den Fehler oder programmiere
was und das habe ich jetzt nur erzählt bekommen,
das soll wohl relativ solide auch schon funktionieren, dann mit so Tab-Completion und baue mal das ein.
Und das heißt, du schreibst halt irgendwas hin und dann ahnt dann sozusagen
die Software auf Basis dieser auf Code optimierten LLMs, was da wohl jetzt geschrieben werden soll.
Und wenn es nicht klar ist, dann kannst du es halt auch einfach dann hinschreiben
und quasi so in Duotamin-Sprache sagen, ja ich hätte jetzt hier,
was weiß ich, gerne eine Loop, die hier fünfmal sich im Kreis dreht und sich
selber aufruft und bau doch mal.
Also das geht ja weiterhin voran in diesem Bereich.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein Einsatzzweck, der eine ganze Menge Produktivität
frei macht bei Programmierern, weil sie einfach von so...
Schreibt-Tasks und Dokumentiert-Tasks auf einmal befreit werden.
Ich habe jetzt ein Paper gesehen, wo jemand argumentiert hat,
dass das nur dann hilfreich ist, wenn die Code-Basis schon in gutem Zustand ist.
Während man mit einer relativ schlechten, mit viel Geschichte behafteten Code-Basis
die Sachen eigentlich nur schlimmer macht.
Da hätte ich jetzt fast das Gegenteil behauptet, weil das hätte ich jetzt gesagt,
wo ich es jetzt in der letzten Zeit für die aktuelle Ultraschall-Release zwei-,
dreimal eingesetzt habe, ist Refactoring.
Also so gewachsener Spaghetti-Code.
It just works. Und wir gucken erstmal lieber ein paar Tage nicht mehr drauf.
Ich reingeworfen habe und sage, so mach mal ein klassisches Refactoring.
Um Refactoring ging es da nicht so richtig, sondern es ging darum,
dann neue Sachen dran zu kleben.
Ah, okay. Also so Christmas-Tree-Approach. So mach mal noch an dem bestehenden Code XY, aber ohne.
Ja, genau.
Das glaube ich.
Eine Sache habe ich noch vergessen. wo du das gerade erwähnst,
also man kann, das habe ich aber jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert,
aber man kann in diesem Cursor, wenn du da so ein Repo hast,
dann liest er, dann kann er auch das ganze Repo indizieren.
Das heißt, nicht nur, dass er weiß, welche Files jetzt alle zu deinem Projekt
gehören, sondern er liest wohl auch die komplette Git-Historie mit ein.
Das heißt, du kannst halt mit dem LLM auch quasi wer hat diese Änderungen gemacht
und kannst du nochmal da, also du kannst dich quasi Wen von den Leuten.
Die da committen, soll ich auswerben?
Genau, wer hat denn hier am meisten schlechten Code produziert?
Wer hat denn Gehaltsöhrung verdient?
Ja, aber nice, oder? Also Cursor, keine Ahnung, noch nicht viel selbst verwendet,
aber war wohl bei ein paar Startups gleich so ein Instant-Hit.
Cursor.com, the AI Code Editor.
Das gucke ich mir doch glatt mal an.
Was ich mir auch angeschaut habe, noch im Nachklapp zur letzten Sendung,
da hatten wir so einen gewissen KI-Schwerpunkt, ist nochmal dieses mittlerweile
legendäre LLM-Paper von Apple.
Wir erinnern uns, das kam eben so relativ knapp vor unserer letzten Sendung raus.
Ich hatte damals nochmal ganz flüchtig drauf geguckt und das hatte ja doch so
viele Wellen geschlagen, bis hin zu Apple hat erkannt, LLM ist doch nicht die
Zukunft und was wird jetzt bloß aus Apple Intelligence werden und so,
dass ich dachte, okay, ich investiere jetzt doch mal zwei Stunden und lese es
mir mal im Original durch.
Und das erstmal vorneweg, also da muss man jetzt auch nicht irgendwie Hardcore,
weder KIler noch Informatiker sein, um das zu tun. Ich finde,
das ist soweit erstmal alles gut verstehbar, was da passiert.
Und da wollte ich jetzt nochmal zwei, drei Eindrücke nochmal von teilen.
Hast du den Link?
Habe ich reingeworfen gerade.
Oh ja, okay.
Wir sind immer noch hier bei Teleskopen. Genau, das ist das Paper.
GSM Symbolic Understanding the Limitations of Mathematical Reasoning in Large
Language Models. Also wir versuchen zu verstehen, was die begrenzten mathematischen Reasonings.
Logisches Denken, Herleitungen, genau.
Genau, so und das ist dann das, was sie eben auch tun und das ist die Anfangssetzung, die sie machen.
Also sie generalisieren sehr stark, sie sagen also dann nicht,
das ist jetzt nur für Mathematik, sondern ihr Grundargument ist,
so Mathematik als irgendwie hier formale Sprache und Grundbausteine der Logik.
Wenn die LLMs noch nicht mal zur Mathematik vernünftig können,
dann können sie auch keine andere Arten von Reasoning und Denken und irgendwie
argumentieren und herleiten.
Wo ich immer mal so ein Fragezeichen schon mal ganz am Start dran machen würde,
weil ja nun mal bekannt ist, dass LLMs einfach große Schwächen in Mathematik haben.
Was nicht unbedingt heißt, dass sie in anderen Punkten von Logik auch schlecht sein müssen. Aber gut.
Was aber schon cool ist, ist der Ansatz, den sie gewählt haben.
Den kann ich schon ganz gut feiern.
Und zwar haben sie also einen der Standard-Tests im Mathematikbereich genommen,
wo glaube ich so eher vierte, fünfte Klasse Mathematikkenntnisse abgefragt werden.
Jetzt also nicht irgendwie Mathematikleistungskurs und Universität und so,
sondern relativ basale Geschichten.
Der hat auch irgendwie einen spezifischen Namen, irgendwas 8000 oder sowas,
leitet sich glaube ich auf den, nach den Anzahl der Fragen oder sowas,
die da gestellt werden, ist auch egal.
Und sie konstatieren halt erstmal, dass die Modelle immer besser werden,
in diesem Test, diesem hochstandardisierten Test abzuschneiden.
Und ihre These ist halt, vielleicht ist dadurch, dass dieser Test einfach so
bekannt ist, mittlerweile auch einfach in das Lernmaterial eingeflossen,
was die richtigen Lösungen sind.
Und was kommt denn eigentlich raus, wenn wir mal, das sind also Textaufgaben,
die da gestellt werden, wenn wir mal die Namen der Person ändern oder mal andere Zahlen.
Das hattest du ja im Prinzip letztes Mal auch schon gemacht.
Das hatte ich auch schon mal ansatzweise gemacht. Da bin ich dann gefreut,
dass die schlauesten Leute bei Apple auf dieselbe Gedanken gekommen sind.
Sehr gut, alles richtig gemacht.
Und die Ergebnisse sind schon erstmal verstörend. Weil sie wirklich signifikante
Unterschiede bekommen, ob es nun Edgar hat fünf Äpfel versus Monika hat fünf Äpfel.
Und bei dem einen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass die mathematische Formel
richtig berechnet wird und bei dem anderen ist sie niedriger.
So, den Punkt muss man Ihnen jetzt erstmal geben, der ist da.
Und Sie testen halt insgesamt, ich glaube 20 Modelle haben Sie drin,
von Open Source über Closed Source.
Und man sieht innerhalb dieser Modelle da eine sehr starke Spreizung.
Sie gehen sehr stark auf den Punkt immer ein, so alle Modelle werden schlechter,
wenn ich das verändere. Sie haben dann auch noch andere Parameter,
wie sie werden auch nochmal signifikant schlechter, wenn zusätzliche gleichartige
Mathematikschritte hinzukommen.
Das heißt, wenn du also nicht nur 3 plus 4 als Aufgabe hast,
sondern 3 plus 4 plus 8, dann brechen die auch richtig signifikant ein,
obwohl, okay, das ist jetzt more of the same, würde man sagen.
Das sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht die Modelle vor größere Probleme stürzen, stürzt es sie aber.
An zwei Punkten würde ich sagen, ist das Paper dann problematisch und die sind
aber auch beide schon, finde ich, jetzt in der Literatur ganz gut diskutiert worden.
Also von daher ist es jetzt auch nichts bahnbrechend Neues, was ich hier bringe.
Das erste ist halt, dass überdeutlich ist, dass sie das ganze Paper geschrieben
haben, bevor OpenAI die O1-Modelle rausgebracht hat.
und dann wurde ihnen klar, okay, die müssen wir jetzt noch irgendwie reinbringen,
und das führt wirklich zu der Situation, dass sie in den Charts drin sind und
dann in den besprechenden Texten dann aber nicht auftauchen,
dass sie Aussagen machen, die
deutlich dem widersprechen, was der Chart aussagt in der Relation dazu.
Das ist, finde ich, schon schwierig. Also da war das Proofreading am Ende auch
mal einfach Mist, was ich dann auf so einer Ebene von Weltklasse-Publikationen
dann, das sollte eigentlich nicht passieren.
Archiv hat eigentlich nur Preprints, ne?
Naja, aber das ist die Version, die von Apple selber auch verlinkt ist.
Achso, du meinst, dass das irgendwann nochmal eine Revision davon gibt?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Das Ding ist jetzt so draußen.
Da glaube ich nicht, dass sie da nochmal nachziehen. Und der zweite Punkt,
den finde ich fast noch relevanter ist.
Dass eben jetzt die O1-Modelle, sowohl das Mini als auch das Preview,
sich bei den meisten ihrer Verfahren mit Abstand an die Spitze setzen.
Und zwar in der Größenordnung von so, die anderen krauchen irgendwie so bei
86% Akkuratheit rum, was jetzt auch mal nicht nichts ist und nicht schlecht ist.
Und die O1-Modelle sind halt irgendwie so bei 98, 99% Exaktheit. Es ist halt nicht 100.
Und dann stellen sie sich auch wieder hin und sagen, wir können ja erst von
Reasoning sprechen, wenn das Modell auf 100% kommt. Ansonsten.
Wo ich dann aber auch sage, ja, das ist irgendwie auf einer theoretischen Ebene
ist das schon richtig, aber wenn ich da jetzt halt irgendwie 100 Menschen hinsetze,
ja, die werde ich im Mittel mehr Fehler draußen haben.
Heißt das, dass diese Menschen nicht denken können oder nicht irgendwie mathematisch
Reasoning beherrschen?
finde ich daraus dann diese Grundfolgerung abzuleiten, finde ich schwierig würde
ich deshalb jetzt auch so ein Modell,
wo ich weiß, okay ich komme statistisch auf 98% akkurat halt bei solchen Sachen,
da fallen mir halt 30.000 Use Cases ein für die das total good enough ist den
Punkt hatten wir auch schon in der letzten Sendung es gibt unendlich viele Szenarien
wo ich nicht auf 100% muss deshalb ist es doch trotzdem wahnsinnig nützlich Aber.
Du kannst natürlich argumentieren, so ein LLM ist ja im Prinzip eine Vervollständigungsmaschine
für die Aufgabe, die du ihm gegeben hast.
Und wenn das Ding halt immer wieder an komischen Ecken und Enden bricht,
weil es nicht wirklich eine logische Schlussfolgerung macht,
dann ist es halt trotzdem schlecht.
Ungeeignet ist es nicht.
Oder ungeeignet.
Kommt halt auf den Justus. Ja, aber die Frage ist halt, wofür braucht man denn
wirklich ein hundertprozentiges, also mal aus einer menschlichen Perspektive.
Mit 98 Prozent hast du immer noch eine 1.0 im Mathe-Test.
Dafür reicht es dann offensichtlich.
Flüchtigkeitsfehler passieren halt Menschen auch. Das heißt also jetzt selbst
in irgendwelchen anspruchsvollen Mathe-Projekten.
Das kann man, finde ich, ist jetzt schön reden.
Solange du noch irgendjemand hast, der hinterher halt noch einen Test hinterher
schickt und die Ergebnisse nachkontrolliert.
Also, naja.
Naja, Flüchtigkeitsfehler ist das eine, aber wenn du halt da noch was änderst,
dann versteht er das Modell nicht mehr. Also versteht er die Aufgabe nicht mehr, ist halt was anderes.
Ja, aber da würde ich dann auch nochmal unterteilen. Also die O1-Ergebnisse
sind dann eben schon ganz schön gut und sehr viel besser als die anderen.
Und auch wenn jetzt immer gesagt wird, so das Plateau ist erreicht,
die LLMs entwickeln sich nicht mehr weiter, ja das würde ich für O1 mal echt nicht unterschreiben.
Ich finde hier wird der Envelope schon wieder eine Menge aufgemacht in neue Richtungen.
Und dieses Paper überzeugt mich nicht vom Gegenteil.
Das nochmal.
Haben Sie das denn als Schlussfolgerung geschrieben?
Ja.
Aber ich meine, O1 ist doch im Prinzip, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
im Kern einfach auch nur eine Kaskade von LLMs.
Also es ist sozusagen ein LLM, liest LLMs Ergebnisse gegen und prüft dann nochmal
auf andere Aspekte, sodass du mehr als nur einen Kontext hast,
auf den sich alles bezieht, sondern du verschränkst sozusagen verschiedene Aussagen,
die aber in sich immer noch alle auf derselben Art und Weise der Herleitung basieren.
Das ist also eigentlich nur ein Wahrscheinlichkeitsgame, wo du dann eben durch
die Kombination mehrerer Modelle, also mehrerer Abfragen gleichzeitig damit
einfach nur so die Kommastelle nach hinten treibst.
Aber es ändert ja nichts daran, dass zu keinem Zeitpunkt das System überhaupt
eine Ahnung hat, worüber es redet.
Das ist ja das Kernproblem.
Und wir haben halt das Hauptproblem dieser ganzen AI, Chat-GPT,
Chat-Interaktion, ich rede mit einer Intelligenzwelle, die uns ja alle irgendwie
erfasst hat, weil sie halt so...
Irgendwie erstmal irre ist, dass das überhaupt, also dass man da so diesen,
wieder mal so einen entscheidenden Durchbruch gehabt hat, um erstmal das eigentliche
Ziel zu machen, was nämlich so, verstehe die Sprache, übersetze,
irgendwie red mit mir wie ein Mensch, das waren so die Ziele.
Und dann hat man festgestellt, oh holla, die Waldfee, dieses Prinzip,
was das sehr gut sicherstellt,
wo die Kommastelle so weit nach hinten verschwunden ist, dass das schon nicht
mehr relevant ist, das funktioniert jetzt auf einmal auch mit Code.
Das funktioniert jetzt auf einmal sogar mit mathematischen Herleitungen,
weil sie es immer größer machen, weil sie immer noch mehr Wälder verbrennen
und irgendwie die Datenzentren da bereit zu stellen, das eben auch noch alles auszurechnen.
Nur ändert es eben nichts an der Methode, die irgendwo endlich ist,
weil sie eben nicht im eigentlichen Sinne logisch arbeitet.
Eine Ausnahme mag sein, und das habe ich jetzt nicht so richtig verfolgt,
aber war es nicht schon mit 4O oder so, dass sie dann für Python-Code auch tatsächlich
dann irgendwie so einen Interpreter noch am Start haben, wo sie den Code dann laufen lassen?
Um dann quasi solche Behinderungen ausgleichen zu können.
LLMs können nicht rechnen, okay, dann machen wir halt einfach,
aber LLMs können Python-Code schreiben, übersetzt deine mathematische Aufgabe
in ein einfaches Python-Skript, rechnet es durch, sieht man ja sogar auch,
wie es aufgebaut wird und spuckt dann die Antwort wieder in den Chat raus.
Habe ich aber jetzt lange nicht gesehen.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob sie das noch so prominent drin haben.
Ja, da bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher, ob dann dieser Ansatz auch zu wirklich
belastbaren Ergebnissen führt.
Eigentlich brauchst du ja sowas wie Mathematiker, also wirklich so eine richtige
Mathemaschine, die du dann eben damit kombinierst.
Wenn ich mir jetzt gerade angucke, wie mein Großer, der ist in der zweiten Klasse,
wie der auch Mathematik lernt gerade, um mal bei dem Thema zu bleiben, so Kopfrechnen.
Da hast du doch aber auch den Fall, dass es eigentlich ab einem gewissen Grad
gar nichts mehr mit Logik zu tun hat und mit Zählen, sondern mit auswendig lernen
und Mustererkennung und Musteranwenden.
Ja klar, bei uns beim Hirn, aber wenn du halt jetzt wirklich die Aufgabe eines
Computers in Anspruch nehmen willst, wo etwas akkurat berechnet wird,
weil davon hängt ab, ob die Brücke umfällt oder nicht.
Es wird bei uns dann ja eben auch in Synapsen gespeichert. Und wenn man jetzt
sagt, okay, das lässt sich in einem LLM einigermaßen abbilden,
dieses antrainierte, gelernte Kopfrechnenwissen,
würde ich mal sagen, da ist nicht unbedingt eine technische Barriere,
die das verhindert, dass ein LLM genauso gut Kopfrechnen kann wie ein Mensch.
Ja, aber der Mensch ist ja schon lange nicht mehr der Benchmark,
wenn wir so Fragestellungen haben wie, was ist wahr?
Erzählt ist das jetzt hier nur so dahergeseierter Slop,
den mir die Maschine sich jetzt einfach ausgedacht hat, weil ich sie dazu gezwungen
habe, mir zu sagen, wo eine Halloween-Party ist und die Halloween-Party,
ja die ist halt heute in Dublin, da gibt es eine große Parade und dann stehen
da tausend Leute rum und warten auf die Halloween-Parade und es findet keine
Stadt. This has happened.
Dann hat das halt keinen Wert.
Und natürlich sind Menschen genauso schlecht.
Die Erfahrung hat man ja vor Gerichten schon oft gemacht.
Du kannst halt Zeugen mit der richtigen Fragestellung dazu bringen,
was zu sagen, was sie so nie gesehen haben.
Leute erinnern sich schlecht, auch unmittelbar betroffene Leute erinnern sich
einfach falsch, weil wir nicht gut da drin sind. Wir sind nicht gut oder sagen
wir mal, die Fehleranfälligkeit ist relativ hoch.
Nur unsere Intelligenz reicht halt dann um so die Basic-Tasks,
die jetzt wirklich wichtig sind, nicht auf die Fresse fallen,
nicht gegen den Baum laufen und so weiter, die kriegen wir halt hin.
Und einzelne Individuen unter uns, bei denen funktioniert halt der ganze Apparat
so gut, dass sie eben besonders gute Physiker,
Mathematiker, Herleiter, Superprogrammierer und was weiß ich für Literaten geworden
sind, die auch alle irgendwie ihre Schwächen haben, aber die nur dadurch auffallen,
dass sie eben besonders gut sind.
Und eigentlich ist es mit diesen LLMs genauso.
Nur jetzt ist natürlich die Erwartung der Bevölkerung und diesen ganzen Hype
ist so dieses so, oh die künstliche Intelligenz, die irgendwie ja wie hell alles weiß,
alles beobachtet, alles liest, alles interpretiert und jetzt auch so ein eigenes
Consciousness hat und pipapo.
Das wird enttäuscht werden, weil...
Dass eben auch, obwohl die Kommastelle so weit nach rechts gedreht wurde,
dass es für unsere Wahrnehmung und im Vergleich zu unseren Fähigkeiten alles
super geil ist, trotzdem am Ende immer noch Unsinn erzählen kann.
Und deswegen kann man sich halt nicht drauf verlassen. Und ich glaube,
das ist so ein bisschen die Essenz aus diesem Paper.
Auch wenn Sie jetzt vielleicht da mit der sehr schnell parallel laufenden Entwicklung
jetzt nicht noch das letzte Datum getestet haben.
Aber im Kern ist es ja immer nur so, du sagst halt zwischendurch noch fünfmal,
der Video-Hopf ist blöd und dann läuft auf einmal alles komplett gegen die Wand.
Naja, weil es ein Textprediktor ist. Also es ist halt, da ist ja keine Intelligenz dahinter.
Es ist halt ein Textprediktor. Ein sehr, sehr guter, aber halt ein Textprediktor.
Und keine Ahnung. Also ich finde das auch nicht problematisch, dass es einer ist.
Und nur, was ich ja problematisch finde, ist halt die Leute,
die dem dann glauben. Und dann, wie war das?
Zu einer Halloween-Parade angereist kommen, die nicht stattfindet?
Ja, das war so eine Webseite in Pakistan, die hat halt irgendwie so SEO-mäßig
sich auf Search-Requests,
wo Leute einfach weltweit nach Halloween-Partys suchen und die haben dann halt
irgendwie alle Halloween-Partys zusammen versucht sich zu suchen und haben natürlich
dann auch irgendwann ChatGPT benutzt,
um das alles irgendwie noch zu refinen und dabei hat ihnen halt irgendwie ChatGPT
so ein bisschen die Fakten verdreht und einfach noch irgendwelche Events dazu halluziniert.
Und dann wurde halt eine Halloween-Parade in Dublin angekündigt,
was dann irgendwelche Leute entdeckt haben, was dann wiederum von irgendwelchen
Influencern auf YouTube und Instagram aufgegriffen wurde.
So, oh ja, Halloween-Parade und so weiter, kommt alle.
Und dann kamen halt auch alle, nur die Parade kam halt nicht.
Spaß hatten sie trotzdem mein Mitleid hält sich die Grenzen ja,
meins auch, aber das ist dann so der Effekt und das ist halt die Frage,
okay, was ist jetzt hier mit der Wahrheit.
Kleiner Aufruf noch, in der letzten Sendung hatte ich ja mal so eine Liste vorgestellt,
die ich pflege mit so etwas kniffligeren Aufgaben für LMs, wo die also gerne
mal aus der Kurve fliegen ich mache nächste Woche wieder so eine kleine Lab-Aktion hier in Berlin.
Am Nachmittag dann sogar öffentlich. Wo und wie und in welchem Kontext darf
ich jetzt noch nicht verraten, aber das ist dann auf Mastodon beiseiten zu lesen.
Da könnt ihr auch gerne vorbeikommen.
Dafür suche ich aber noch gerne knifflige, lustige, absurde Probleme,
die LLMs gerade immer noch so haben. Schick mir da gerne mal was drauf.
Darfst du sagen, wann, an welchem Tag und wie viel Uhr und in welcher Stadt?
Es ist Berlin und es wird sein der Donnerstag und es wird sein ab 14 Uhr.
Aber ich darf nicht sagen, wo und was, aus Gründen.
Ja, aber man kann es ja zumindest schon mal, dass ein paar Leute sich schon
mal rausnehmen können aus der Anspannung.
Nicht, dass sie sich die ganze Zeit so, oh Gott, ich muss dabei sein.
Das ist öffentlich, aber ich darf nicht sagen, wo, ist natürlich auch ein schwieriges Konzept.
Also wenn ihr da draußen so Standardchecks habt,
die für Normalsterbliche einigermaßen nachvollziehbar sind, also jetzt nicht
die höchsten Stufen der Integralrechnung, sondern eher so common Logikgeschichten,
dann gerne mir nochmal rüber schicken vorher.
Naja, dann nehme ich das dann in unseren Testparcours auf.
Weil das Setting, was ich da machen möchte, ist, dass die Leute können sich
sowohl knifflige Probleme für LLMs ausdenken, wo sie denken, so daran scheitern sie.
Und wenn sie daran scheitern, haben andere Leute die Möglichkeit zu versuchen,
mit besseren Prompting diese Probleme doch zu lösen.
Sodass man quasi zwei Teams hat, die gegeneinander arbeiten und versuchen,
auf dem Wege hoffentlich auch zu Erkenntnissen zu gelangen. Ich glaube,
das wird ganz lustig. Gucken wir mal.
Kleine Zwischenanmerkung. Wir hatten ja vor zwei Sendungen oder so,
da habe ich ja moniert, dass irgendwie so diese ganze Steuerung von Macs und
so nicht da ist, wo ich will.
Und dann wurde ich darauf hingewiesen, dass es Universal Control gibt,
was ich ja eigentlich schon wusste, aber komplett vergessen hatte und noch nie
richtig ausprobiert habe.
Mittlerweile habe ich das hier im Einsatz und das ist so toll.
ich gelobe Verbesserung. Also ich habe hier meinen Laptop stehen,
ich habe hier diesen Mac Studio stehen und im Mac Studio sind drei Bildschirme
und ich kann hier wirklich mit einem Trackpad mit der Maus hier so von Bildschirm
zu Bildschirm gehen, egal von welchem Rechner aus, ist einfach so toll.
Ja, ich habe das hier jetzt schon die ganze Zeit mit diesem iPad gemacht.
Kann man den Cursor ja auch rüberschieben und dann tippen.
Und Copy und Paste geht auch alles, also ich muss echt Abbitte leisten,
das war alles da. Ich habe es bloß nicht gesehen.
Ich habe da irgendwie immer das Handicap, dass irgendeine meiner Komponenten
immer zu alt ist und das nicht unterstützt. Ich müsste einmal so alles modernisieren, dass es klappt.
Meine iPads sind, glaube ich, zu alt, die ich zu Hause rumlungern habe.
Naja, bald sind die sowieso alle zerstört von den Kindern. Dann muss man irgendwann
mal was Neues anschaffen.
Mein iPad Pro von 2008 hält immer noch super von 2018.
Aber damit geht das zum Beispiel nicht, ne?
Was? Doch, doch, das geht alles ganz wunderbar.
Da kriegst du noch eine aktuelle iOS-Version drauf?
Ja. Okay.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade ein iPad aus dem Betrieb genommen,
weil es keine aktuelle Version bekommt.
Das 18er ist gerade noch in allem drin und wenn es rausfällt,
dann habe ich wieder die Qual, weil Apple ja natürlich mein Lieblings-Keyboard
mitgekillt hat mit dem neuen iPads.
das finde ich ja ganz furchtbar das ist ja dein Lieblings-Keyboard ich habe
dieses Folio-Keyboard das ist von Apple das von Apple was viel gescholten ist
wie ich finde völlig zu Unrecht also das ist das Keyboard das kann man also
komplett einfach detachen,
das ist nur so magnetisch ja,
besteht unten aus dieser Tastatur und dann eben dem Teil, was sich hinten an
das iPad ranlegt und wenn ich das iPad da jetzt so drauflege,
dann ist da so ein Loch für die Kamera drin.
Magnetisch passt sich das ein, soweit so gut. Dann kann ich einfach auch die
Tastatur so nach hinten klappen und ohne, dass ich dieses Cover abnehmen muss,
kann ich das einfach so als normales iPad benutzen.
Wenn ich dann aber gerne das Ding irgendwie in meine Tasche stecke,
klappe ich das einfach zu und dann ist es irgendwie zu.
Wenn ich es aufbocken will, kann ich das auch ganz einfach machen.
Ich habe hier so zwei kleine Kerben, wo wo ich das halt irgendwie in der einen
und dem anderen Winkel mit reinmachen kann.
Und soweit so gut. Das Keyboard ist halt jetzt nur so ein Folio-Keyboard und
ist jetzt auch schon ziemlich zerfetzt, aber es funktioniert alles.
Neulich habe ich dann allerdings eine unfassbar coole Anwendung von diesem Ding
gefunden, die mich wirklich umgehauen hat und die alle meine Probleme gelöst hat im Bett.
Apple löst meine Probleme im Bett.
Und zwar, jetzt guckt mal, jetzt haben wir wieder dieses Cook-Problem,
aber ich werde es gleich mal akkurat beschreiben.
Also die Problematik ist ja immer, man will einen Film gucken und man will im Bett liegen.
Ja.
Aber man hat irgendwie keinen Bock, irgendwie aufrecht zu sitzen und wo hält man das Ding?
Da hilft dir eine Quest-Brille, aber ja.
Es geht auch noch einfach, da hilft mir auch dieses Folio-Keyboard.
Jetzt pass mal auf, Wir werden das gleich im Audio-Podcast beschreiben.
Das ist jetzt so aufgeklappt, dass sich so ein T ergibt.
Genau.
Und das steht auf seiner kurzen Seite.
Das ganze iPad liegt sozusagen auf der Seite, aber es wird dann dadurch,
dass dieses Folio-Keyboard ganz nach hinten ausgeklappt wird,
also die Tastatur wie so ein T geformt, dann das Ding hält und das ist super stabil.
Also das ist wirklich eine Fantastik. Da kippt nichts um. Das kann auch umkippen,
aber es ist vollkommen ausreichend.
So kann man dann einfach so daneben liegen und irgendwie Film gucken.
Genau, weil dein Kopf ist eben dann auch seitlich.
Aber ich verstehe, dass das jetzt sehr schwierig zu beschreiben ist.
Ich werde also jetzt erstmal ein Foto für den Slack machen.
Also der Slack geht schon steil.
Wie macht man denn das?
Ich wiederhole das jetzt nicht, was da steht.
Ich habe es ja auch herausgefordert. Ähm...
Für mein altes iPad hatte ich auch so eine Tastatur.
Das Problem war nur, dass die Kabel an den Knickstellen irgendwann dann durchgeknickt
sind und dann ging das nicht mehr.
Dann hat das einen Kurzschluss gehabt, hat fürchterlich Strom abgezogen und
dann habe ich irgendwann die Faxen dicke gehabt und habe die Kontakte mit Klebeband abgeklebt.
Jetzt ist es nur noch eine Hülle und man kann nicht mehr tippen.
Ich nutze mal kurz hier die Fotopause. Wir hatten ja auch die neuen AirPod Pros
mal besprochen, hatte ich ja ein bisschen was zu erzählt.
Könnt ihr auf euren AirPod Pro 2, die mit Isolation, könnt ihr da eigentlich
nicken und Kopf schütteln?
Ist jetzt auch bei euch in dem letzten Update mit angekommen.
weil das finde ich total fantastisch wenn ich da auf dem Fahrrad bin und er
mich fragt, willst du dein Training aufzeichnen, bist du dann immer irgendwie ja, verstehst du mich,
einmal mit dem Kopf nicken und hast auch so ein lustiges Audiofeedback,
genau es klackt und dann wird es gleich akzeptiert, also Kopfschütteln und nicken
super Gesten mit Kopfhörern,
schon mal probiert, Tim ist cool ich wüsste nicht.
Wann soll ich denn das gebrauchen?
Irgendwie willst du XY-Telefonanruf annehmen kriegst du wenig Telefonanruf an
Willst du das Training, also ich habe das ständig mit Training halt, so.
Ich setze mich aufs Fahrrad, fahre los. Du fährst ja kein Fahrrad mehr,
du fährst ja nur noch hier E-Roller und so.
Dann Montorat, wirst du natürlich auch nicht gefragt.
Schon klar.
Keiner fragt dich. So, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das besser beschreiben soll.
Auf jeden Fall, dieses Folio-Keyboard kann man einfach super einfach so nach
hinten ausstrecken und dadurch steht das Ding einfach akkurat auf der Seite
und das ist einfach toll.
Das Besondere ist halt, dass es wirklich exakt im 90-Grad-Winkel aufrecht steht.
Und wer sich wundert, warum mein Folio-Kiefer so zerfleddert ist,
ich benutze das einfach intensiv, dieses Gerät.
Das wird die ganze Zeit in Taschen reingesteckt und das ist ein fantastisches
Produkt und ich würde es auch wieder kaufen, aber man kann es für die neuen
iPad Pros leider nicht kaufen. Und das ist nicht gut.
Aber da gibt es auch andere Folio-Dinger für.
Nicht von Apple.
Doch, doch.
Also nicht das.
Ja gut, vielleicht nicht genau das. Also ich habe noch ein ganz altes Keyboard,
was so eine Art Hülle auch ist, für ein Mac Mini, für ein iPad Mini damals.
Das war aber mit Bluetooth. Und das Lustige ist, das lässt sich nach wie vor
als Bluetooth-Keyboard ganz einfach benutzen.
Ist halt als Hüllenfunktion jetzt nicht mehr so richtig gut. Aber na ja.
Ich gebe zu, mein Cover sieht wirklich, super abgeranzt aus,
aber es ist einfach, es funktioniert einfach und ich werde mir vielleicht auch
demnächst nochmal ein neues kaufen, solange es das noch gibt.
Jetzt kriegt ihr auch noch das Foto hier, das wird euch irgendwie richtig um...
Mit diesem sehr schönen Spruch.
Mit diesem sehr schönen Spruch, weil der ist ja da drauf.
Und ranzig.
Oh my.
So, Themenwechsel. Ähm...
Was war denn noch? Ah ja, Vision Pro.
Ich habe immer noch keine aufgehabt.
Ich auch immer noch nicht.
Irgendwann wird das passieren.
Okay, dann kann ich dir das empfehlen, dass du das, das kannst du jetzt im Apple Store tun.
Ja, Zeit müsste man haben.
Also viel Zeit braucht man dafür nicht. Termine kriegt man problemlos geklickt.
Ich habe das nämlich diese Woche einfach mal gemacht, weil ich wollte nochmal
herausfinden, ob denn eigentlich meine Scharfstelle,
Anstellprobleme sich vielleicht durch den Einsatz eines Lesebrilleneinsatzes korrigieren lassen.
Und sowas haben die da auch im Store?
Ja, ja. Also wenn du irgendwie Brillenbedarf hast, dann kannst du diesen dort anmelden.
Das wirst du auch, wenn du den Termin schon machst, wirst du schon gefragt,
ob das für dich sozusagen überhaupt ein Aspekt ist.
und ich habe dann halt irgendwie Lesebrille angeklickt und dann sagst du halt, dann haben sie so drei,
vier Kategorien von so Lesebrillenkorrekturen, das geht glaube ich so bei 0,75
bis 1,25 los und dann nochmal eine Kategorie, nochmal eine Kategorie und dann,
dann dauert es einen Moment, dann wird nämlich hinten quasi das Gerät für dich
präpariert also hinten setzt dann irgendjemand in Ruhe jemand dann diese richtigen
Dinger schon ein und dann wird das auf so einem Tablett nach fünf Minuten so
nach vorne gereicht und dann Mit.
Handtuch über dem Arm.
Naja, also du hast halt die ganze Zeit da so deine Betreuerin oder Betreuer,
so Erklärerin da neben dir, also in meinem Fall war es halt ein Mädel und hat
das auch super gemacht, ich bin sowieso immer sehr beeindruckt wie,
gute Manieren, die da haben bei Apple. Also die sind wirklich...
Dafür werden sie ja bezahlt.
Ansonsten fliegst du glaube ich auch sehr schnell raus.
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch Teil des Trainings. Aber ich finde auch,
dass sie das wirklich gut hinkriegen.
Also erstmal sind sie nicht cheesy, sie sind nicht pushy.
Also sie versuchen dir nie irgendwas aufzudrängen.
Sie haben so eine charmante Höflichkeit, die auch nicht... Also eine gute Mischung. Mir gefällt das.
Ich möchte gerne manchmal noch mal so die Glaswand noch ein bisschen weiter aufbrechen.
Darauf lassen sich dann nur manchmal ein. Wie auch immer.
Ich habe dann gleich gesagt, ich brauche diesen ganzen Demo-Klimpeln nicht,
weil das habe ich irgendwie alles schon gehabt.
Mir geht es halt eigentlich nur um diese Macintosh-Sache.
Leider fahren sie noch nicht so die allerneueste Version oder vielleicht ist
das auch gerade nur in der aktuellen Beta, das wusste ich nicht,
wo dieser Mac-Bildschirm auch quasi so ein großer Curve-Monitor sein kann.
Das wäre jetzt auch nochmal so ein Faktor gewesen. Mir ging es aber jetzt primär
eigentlich um die Schärfe.
Lange Story kurz, auch mit dieser Einlage, die halt für 0,75 bis 1,25 Dioptrien gedacht sei,
konnte ich keine Änderung feststellen.
Und sie konnte mir leider auch nicht so richtig genau erklären,
wie denn das eigentlich jetzt genau funktioniert, weil man hat ja irgendwie
diesen Bildschirm vor der Nase, dann hast du diese optische Korrektur,
dann wollte ich halt wissen….
Ich gehe mal davon aus, weil man muss diese Lesebrillen einsetzen,
die müssen auch so gepairt werden.
Also man muss so richtig diesem Gerät sagen, dass die da jetzt so drinnen sind und total obskur.
Das war irgendwie so ein Anmeldevorgang, der mich gerade so ein bisschen überrascht
hat, aber der fand statt.
und ich hab mich halt gefragt, ob die Darstellung auf dem Bildschirm sich selbst
auch ändert oder ob nur diese Optik sozusagen dazukommt.
Weil die Optik ändert ja dann auch nochmal so ein bisschen, wie weit du guckst
und ich könnte mir also vorstellen, dass die Vision Pro tatsächlich auch das
tatsächlich auf dem internen Bildschirm dargestellte Bild ändert, in Abhängigkeit davon,
was für ein Brilleneinsatz da drin ist.
Weiß ich aber nicht. Keine Ahnung. Und es ist ja eh alles so ein bisschen obskur,
weil man blickt in irgendwas, was irgendwie dreidimensional ist,
aber du hast ja nicht die Fokussierung unter Kontrolle.
Du kannst ja nicht mit deinem Auge sagen, ich gucke jetzt mal ganz nach hinten,
ich gucke jetzt mal vorne.
Also du kannst nicht sagen, wo dein Schärfepunkt liegt, sondern der Schärfepunkt
wird dir ja von diesem Teil nach wie vor vorgegeben.
Das ist eine generelle Schwäche und ich weiß nicht, ob man da jemals noch Technologie
für erfinden kann, die das irgendwie auch noch aufgelöst bekommt,
aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Also für mich war es am Ende immer noch zu unscharf.
Ich habe dann mal gefragt, was denn so ihre Erfahrung oder ihr Gefühl ist,
wofür denn die Leute das so primär verwenden und meinte so, ja die meisten schon
so wirklich der Macintosh Modus,
also wirklich so als Arbeitsterminal und ansonsten so im Entertainment irgendwie Filme gucken.
Das wäre so eigentlich ein bisschen so die Killer-App.
Bin ich überraschend, aber war auch mal interessant zu hören.
Wobei mich ehrlich gesagt schon überrascht hat, dass diese Macintosh-Nutzung
quasi, also diese Screen-Nutzung so ein wichtiger Punkt ist.
vielleicht hat sie es auch nur so gesagt, aber ich hatte so den Eindruck,
so ist es auch ja also klickt euch mal ein Date, weil es ist.
Das kann ich echt nur noch betonen. Also bei allen Einschränkungen,
die ich da sehe und bei aller Skepsis für diese Technologie als solche,
als auch konkret für die Vision Pro und bei dem großen Fragezeichen,
was denn jetzt wirklich die potenziellen Killer-Apps sind, ob das jetzt sich
irgendwie so Enterprise-mäßig in so einem super vertikalen Markt durchsetzt.
Also es gab ja jetzt diese Berichte, wo sehr erfolgreich das zum Beispiel von
Ärzten eingesetzt wird bei der Operation und zwar gar nicht mal,
was man erst so denken würde für Remote,
sondern tatsächlich für im Operationssaal, weil sie quasi mit der Brille immer
noch genug Auflösung haben, um ihre Tätigkeiten durchzuführen,
aber sich dann eben AR-mäßig die ganzen, wie nennt man das, die ganzen Lebensdaten,
also Herzschlag und was halt in dem Moment noch relevant ist,
was sie immer im Blick haben müssen.
Das Dashboard.
Um das sozusagen alles gleichzeitig im Blick zu haben und das sei schon so ein Grund.
Und in so einem Bereich, wo wahrscheinlich der Monitor, auf den sie normalerweise
gucken, schon mal 10.000 Euro
kostet, sind diese 3.500 Euro für die Vision Pro, da lachen die drüber.
Was kostet die? Gib mir 10 davon.
Ja, so diese großen NEC-Anzeigemonitore für den professionellen Bereich sind so absurd teuer.
Genau, oder bei Radiologen.
Da sind auch keine anderen Panels drin, als in irgendwelchen Wald- und Wiesenfernsehern
und trotzdem zahlst du da nicht tot.
Bei Radiologen hast du halt diese 16-Bit Schwarz-Weiß-Schirme zum Beispiel gehabt.
Ja, okay, das ist nochmal was anderes.
Da spielt das schon eine Rolle. Aber generell ist im medizinischen Bereich halt
alles teuer. Da ist halt diese Vision Pro kein Thema.
Das ist jetzt auch nur so ein Bereich, aber das war für mich so ein Beispiel,
wo ich mir dachte so, ah okay, da kann das irgendwie Sinn machen,
aber das ist natürlich kein Massenmarkt.
Es kann halt nur sein, dass sie so viele solche Nischen erschließen,
dass quasi darüber so ein Effekt entsteht, wie einst beim Macintosh mit dem Desktop-Publishing.
Weil das Desktop-Publishing war ja das Killer-App. Das war die Killer-App.
Man konnte einfach was ausdrucken und Laserdrucker noch dazu und es war einfach,
es hat komplette Drucksysteme und Agenturen und mehrere Arbeitsplätze auf einmal
in so eine Maschine reingemacht und da waren dann irgendwie die 10.000,
20.000 Mark, die du dafür ausgegeben hast, waren halt ein Scherz.
Und ähnlich denke ich meist auch bei der Vision Pro. Aber für mich selber,
funktioniert es noch nicht und ich habe dafür keine Anwendung und ich schaue mal, was noch so kommt.
Nee gut, du hast natürlich in dem Bereich OP-Saal und so weiter hast du natürlich
so Desinfektions Anforderungen, wo so ein Gerät vielleicht dann auf die Dauer nicht lange lebt.
Also da müsste Apple dann schon eine Apple Vision Med oder so rausbringen,
die du dann auch einmal abkochen kannst.
oder weiß ich nicht, Autoklaver, wie heißen diese Geräte?
Naja, wird es aber nicht geben natürlich.
Ja, Thema sehen, wir können noch mal kurz Thema hören machen.
Bisschen unangenehmes Thema, ich habe letzte Woche Dienstag im Probenraum,
so wie ich das immer tue, Gehörschutz getragen.
Und zwar diesmal ein neues Produkt, was ich kurz vorher bei Rossmann aus dem Regal genommen hatte.
Die Dinger heißen Oropax Profi und sind so diese tannenbaumförmigen Silikondinger.
Ja, und da hatte ich dann das Problem, dass sich das Teil so gut festgesaugt hat,
dass ich mir das Trommelfell mit rausgezogen habe, also nicht das Ganze,
sondern es ist irgendwie nur leicht angerissen gewesen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt davor warnen sollte, dieses Produkt einzusetzen
oder was jetzt eigentlich die…,
Ich weiß.
Tim ist ja auch etwas empfindlich bei solchen. Hast du das in dem Moment sofort gemerkt?
Oder also weil unaufassbarer Schmerz und Audio sofort alles im Arsch.
Schmerz, das hat einmal dick geknackt. Und ich bin dann, weil ich dann direkt
einen dumpfes Höreindruck hatte, links war das,
bin ich dann direkt am nächsten Tag zum Ohrenarzt gegangen.
Das war ein bisschen unerfreulich, weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
dass der mich nicht so richtig ernst nimmt. So nachdem, in ihrem Alter,
dass man da nicht mehr so gut hört.
Also so kam der rüber, fand ich ein bisschen sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Lag vielleicht auch daran, dass er das Loch oder was auch immer da kaputt war,
nicht gesehen hat, weil da war auch ein bisschen Blut und es war auch verkrustet und so weiter.
Also auf jeden Fall habe ich dann, jetzt ist es auch so, dass man da wohl auch nicht viel machen kann.
Also man muss halt warten, bis es zugewachsen ist. Ich habe jetzt quasi,
also nicht Duschverbot bekommen, aber er meinte, ich sollte alles dran setzen,
dass kein Wasser ins Ohr kommt.
Weil es ist natürlich logisch, wenn das Trommelfellen ein Loch hat,
das dann das Wasser auch ins Innenohr kann und das will man so gar nicht.
Ja, im Moment ist es jetzt wieder besser geworden, aber es ist noch nicht völlig
in Ordnung. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie es mit Druckausgleich und allem drum und dran ist.
Ich habe nächste Woche Freitag, war das glaube ich, nochmal einen Hörtest.
Da wird er wahrscheinlich auch nochmal ins Ohr gucken und nochmal nichts sehen.
Ja, in diesem Sinne, Vorsicht mit solchen Hörtesten.
Mit solchen In-Ear-Gehörschutzdingern, wenn die zu fest sitzen,
muss man wirklich ganz, ganz vorsichtig sein, die wieder rauszuziehen.
Zumindest nicht einfach mit Schmackes rausziehen, sondern eher an der Seite
nochmal mit irgendwas spitzen.
Vor allen Dingen dieses Ding, das hat so ein Benzel, wo beide Seiten mit verbunden
werden, was, wenn ich mir das so angucke, doch relativ stabil ist.
Da kann es einem halt auch passieren, dass mit der blöden Bewegung sich das
Ding einfach mal so aus dem Ohr rupft.
Also wie gesagt, dieses Produkt kann ich nicht empfehlen.
Und allgemein den Umfang, also ich habe vorher immer die Ohrstöpsel von Alpine
benutzt und die haben eigentlich immer gut funktioniert und würde die auch weiter empfehlen.
Das Oropax Dings war jetzt nicht so eine geile Idee.
Alpine oder Alpine. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die sich aussprechen.
Mit denen habe ich ganz gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Also sie halten natürlich auch nicht ewig,
da muss man ab und zu mal neue kaufen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser als
diese komischen Gummidinger, Schaumstoffgummidinger,
die man da immer zusammenknetet und dann versucht, dass sie irgendwie halten
und dann machen die aber untenrum auch dämmen die nicht richtig und dann hörst
du halt nur noch Bass und so, das ist irgendwie, genau,
alpine Gehörschutz-Collections.
Habt ihr denn für eure jetzt schon diesen neuen Modus mit Kompensation und sowas ausprobiert?
Ich sage mal so, ich hatte jetzt eine Weile lang meine In-Ear-Kopfhörer nicht im Ohr.
Verstehe, ja.
Ansonsten hätte ich dir diese Frage gerne beantwortet. Ich weiß auch nicht,
wann ich die dann tatsächlich wieder reintue.
Ja, genau. Also sicherlich nicht, bevor der Arzt nicht sagt,
ja, ist wieder okay, sie können das wieder machen. Ja.
Ich habe übrigens diesen neuen Hörtest bei den AirPods Pro 2 mal ausprobiert
und zu meiner größten Überraschung hat mir Apple bestätigt, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Na guck, du selber siehst das glaube ich anders.
Wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Ja, ich habe halt Tinnitus und hätte jetzt mal schwer damit gerechnet,
dass er so eine Austastlücke feststellt.
Ja, aber eine Tinnitus ist schwer zu messen, das weißt du. Oder hat er tatsächlich Töne abgefragt?
Naja, also was passiert ist, das glaube ich auch bei so einem normalen Hörtest beim Ohrenarzt läuft,
dann werden dir also links und rechts separat Töne unterschiedlicher Frequenz
in unterschiedlicher Lautstärke vorgespielt.
Du musst immer, dreimal und dann tippst du einfach auf den Bildschirm,
genau legst das iPhone hin und wenn du halt das gehört hast,
tappst du halt irgendwie drauf und dann machst du so piep piep piep.
Piep piep piep.
Piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep
piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep
piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep piep.
Es gibt noch eine andere Art von Hörtest, das ist so eine Art Reaktionshörtest
und zwar hat das Ohr so einen Muskel und dieser Muskel kann bedämpfen,
also irgendwie da Steigbügel und so weiter, da kann der Muskel anziehen und
dann ändert sich die Impedanz von dem Ohr und dann hörst du im Prinzip schlechter.
Das ist eigentlich so eine Vorrichtung, die dazu führt, dass wenn du dich in
Lautem aufhältst, dass das Ohr so ein bisschen dämpfen kann.
Dieser Muskel funktioniert aber nur im Zusammenhang mit, das Ohr hört tatsächlich was.
Und dadurch, also ich weiß nicht so hundertprozentig, wie es funktioniert,
aber du kannst das Ohr anregen und kannst hinterher aber die Impedanz von dem Trommelfell messen.
Und wenn die sich verändert, dann ist es ein Hinweis darauf,
dass dieser Muskel angesprochen hat und das Ohr diesen Ton tatsächlich wahrgenommen hat.
Mit dieser Art von Messung misst man zum Beispiel bei Söcklingen,
die können ja nicht sagen, habe ich jetzt gehört oder habe ich nicht gehört.
Ein Muskel, der quasi zumacht, der die Lautstärke reduziert.
Naja, der verstimmt im Prinzip die Wellenanpassung zwischen Trommelfell und
der ovalen Öffnung von der Schnecke.
Also du hast ja irgendwie, das ist das Trommelfell und dann sind da die drei Gehörknöchelchen,
die dafür sorgen, dass der Wellenwiderstand am Trommelfell angepasst wird zu
dem Wellenwiderstand von dem ovalen Fenster von der Schnecke.
Diese Steigbügel und wie die alle heißen, egal.
Musculus tensor tympani und musculus stapedius.
Genau, die da. Keine Ahnung. Also ich glaube, diesen Test kann das sicherlich
nicht, können die AirPods nicht, aber den normalen, ich spiele dir Töne vor
und du sagst mir, ob du sie gehört hast, das ist eigentlich Standard.
Normalerweise hat man das auch so, dass die immer lauter werden.
Sobald du ihn hörst, drückst du dann da drauf.
Ja, naja, ich dachte ja irgendwie, ich kriege jetzt hier berichtet,
dass ich irgendwas tun soll oder dass er mir das jetzt irgendwie anpasst und
mir so ein Profil macht oder so, aber,
muss ich nochmal ausprobieren.
Naja, vielleicht dadurch, dass du nicht die,
Original-Muffen dran hast?
Das glaube ich jetzt nicht, dass das einen großen Unterschied macht.
Also glauben heißt nicht wissen, aber.
Musculus sind so Tympani und ja genau, irgendwie diese beiden Muskeln.
Das Ohr ist faszinierend, das ist wirklich irre. Also da kann ich auch gerne
nochmal meinen Lieblingspodcast, den ich mal gemacht habe, plangen.
Ich habe ja mal einen vier Stunden langen Podcast zum Ohr gemacht,
auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt glaube, dieser Muskel kam dort nicht zur Sprache,
da kann ich mich zumindest nicht dran,
erinnern, aber das war ein schönes Gespräch, was ich einst geführt habe mit Stefan Brill.
C-R-E 206. Naja, nur 10 Jahre.
Und das war so eine Reise irgendwie in vier Stunden so vom Ohrläppchen bis zum
Hörnerv und das war schon echt gut.
Ja, das ist sehr spannend. Ich habe das im Studium halt auch gemacht und auch
so dieses dieses Modell, wie das Ohr, also wie die Membran, die,
heißt die Basilarmembran?
Ja, ich glaube, in der Schnecke, wie die tatsächlich schwingt und wie man durch
die Schwingung der Basilarmembran wiederum erklären kann, warum,
manche lossless Audioformate du nicht hören kannst, dass die was weglassen.
Weil so wie die Membran schwingt, bist du gar nicht, physisch nicht in der Lage,
diese Artefakte zu hören. Das ist super fasziniert.
Ah ja.
Gut. Dann haben wir noch ein Fotothema.
Vom Ohr wieder zum Auge.
Zurück zur Vision.
Zurück zur Vision, genau. Das ist ein Thema, an dem ich jetzt schon seit vielen Wochen bastle.
Da freue ich mich diebisch drauf. Ich hoffe, ihr habt gleich auch den entsprechenden
Spaß, weil ich glaube, dass das
doch hoffentlich das ein oder andere Aha-Erlebnis hier produzieren wird.
Also, was ist der Hergang?
Was mich an der Vision Pro schon eigentlich immer sehr interessiert hat,
sind die 3D-Fotos und 3D-Videos, die man damit aufzeichnen konnte und wieder abspielen.
Das wurde ja in der Werbung auch sehr breit gemacht mit, ja deine Lieblingserinnerungen
kannst du wieder nachvollziehen und so.
Wir haben das hier in der Sendung auch diskutiert und es wird allgemein behauptet,
dass es in der Tat sehr eindrucksvoll sei und schon irgendwie ein mindestens
mal cooler bis hin zu berauschender Effekt.
Und der Schönheitsfehler, das haben wir auch schon herausgearbeitet, ist natürlich okay,
dafür musst du jetzt halt mal diese olle Brille auf dem Kopf haben,
um irgendwie damit halt die echten 3D-Fotos zu machen mit zwei verschiedenen
Kameras, die da ja eingebaut sind, ungefähr im Augenabstand,
damit du überhaupt diese 3D-Informationen hast.
und das macht natürlich die Anwendung dann schon irgendwie, wir hatten glaube
ich irgendwie, okay, dann bist du jetzt auf dem Kindergeburtstag von deinem
Kleinen und setzt die Kamera auf, um die irgendwie in 3D, willst du alles nicht machen.
Machst aber dann doch.
Echt? Naja, musst du ja nicht mehr.
Weil Das Thema hatten wir schon mal, das ist so ein bisschen wie der Decke schwere
VHS-Rekorder, den Papa irgendwie die ganze Zeit mit rum geschleppt hat,
das sah damals auch aus, als ob du mit einem Lastwagen durch die Gegend läufst.
Naja, aber man muss es ja nicht, weil Apple hat ja nachgelegt.
Und hat dann relativ zeitnah dahinter gesagt, hey, das könnt ihr übrigens mit
aktuellen iPhones auch machen.
Das heißt, alles mit iPhone 15 und iPhone 16 hat plötzlich in der ganz normalen
Foto-App einen zusätzlichen Modus bekommen, der da wo heißt,
müsste irgendwo unten zu sehen sein. dann hat einer die Standard...
Räumlich heißt das.
Musst du dann auch im Querformat machen.
Muss man im Querformat machen. Und dann kann man damit 3D-Fotos aufnehmen in
diesem sogenannten HIC-Format, was Apple auch in der Vision Pro verwendet. Und...
Das habe ich mir halt irgendwie so alles durchgelesen und angeguckt und dann hatte ich Fragen.
Und die erste Frage ist mal, okay, warum geht das jetzt eigentlich nur mit den neuesten iPhones?
Warum geht das nicht mit meinem iPhone 14? Das finde ich natürlich erstmal immer total doof.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich anguckt, was die Hardware angeht,
sind unsere beiden iPhones jetzt ja mal, was die Kameratechnik angeht,
nicht so radikal unterschiedlich.
Also zumindest was die Objektive und die Platzierung betrifft.
Genau, die sind eben jetzt auch hier nebeneinander platziert,
im selben Abstand wie deine Objektive und das ist mal echt nicht Augenbreite auseinander.
Augen sind im Schnitt bei Menschen glaube ich 6,5 Zentimeter auseinander,
im statistischen Mittel und die hier sind vielleicht mal anderthalb Zentimeter
oder sowas, das reicht eigentlich überhaupt nicht, um irgendwie einen vernünftigen… Ja.
Vor allem sind sie ja nicht identisch, sondern es ist ja auch ganz andere Brennweiten.
Das kommt noch dazu, die Brennweiten unterscheiden sich. Das heißt,
das kann nicht eine so in Anführungszeichen saubere oder echte 3D-Aufnahme sein,
wie das, was in der Vision Pro rauskommt.
So und dann bin ich halt neugierig geworden und habe mal angefangen zu experimentieren
und zu forschen und dann kam im September noch eine Neuerung und dann bin ich
richtig wuschig geworden, nämlich,
dass mit dem Vision Pro 2 Software Update Apple plötzlich auch die Möglichkeit gegeben hat,
alte 2D-Fotos in 3D zu transferieren, ohne dass du es überhaupt jemals mit irgendeiner
3D-Technik aufgenommen hättest.
und ich so, hm Mit KI Dank des Adapters So und,
Das war dann der Beginn einer Software-Reise durch verschiedene Tool-Unschärfen,
weil meine Grundthese war,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jetzt Apple plötzlich völlig genialisch
das ganze Feld 2D, 3D-Konversion komplett neu erfunden, komplett neu gedacht hat.
Die setzen doch da wahrscheinlich auch auf irgendwas auf, was schon längst irgendwo da ist.
Was, du meinst, die kochen auch nur mit Wasser?
Die kochen auch nur mit Wasser, war so meine Arbeitsthese.
Open-Source-Wasser.
Mit von Open Source geklautem Wasser. Und in der Tat, wenn man jetzt also einfach
mal in den normalen Store geht, in den App Store von iOS oder macOS,
dann findet man dort gar nicht mal so wenige Software-Pakete, die genau das anbieten.
Versprechen.
Oder versprechen. Und sprich, man lädt sich eine App runter.
Das, was ich jetzt im Moment hauptsächlich verwende, ist, so,
Moment mal, wo habe ich sie hier in meinen Notizen?
das Spatial Media Toolkit. Ich schmeiß das mal hier rein.
Das ist ein Entwicklerbude. In New York sitzt der Gute.
Ich hab den dann auch mal auf Reddit angeschrieben. Da ist er ganz rührig.
Und diese Software ist sehr übersichtlich. Kann ich mich mal jetzt hier auf den Beamer schalten?
Du? Du dich auf meinen Beamer?
Auf deinen Beamer.
Ja, kannst du machen.
So, Beamer.
Ausnahmsweise. Ja, Beamer.
Damit wir sehen, was die Leute nicht sehen können.
Wir müssen jetzt viel beschreiben, aber ich schmeiße jetzt zum einen viel in
den Slack-Kanal rein, zum anderen werde ich auch mal irgendwo in dem Pad eine
Dokumentationsseite machen, wo ich dann gleich die ganzen Demo-Bilder dann alle für,
die Nachhörenden.
Ich werde es fleißig beschreiben, was du hier machst. Genau,
wir mühen uns nach Griften. Wir beschreiben 3D-Bilder in einem Audio-Podcast. Wow.
Genau.
Die Leute jetzt schon so, oh, Augenroll.
Wie sie sehen, sehen sie eine Katze.
Katzenbilder, na toll.
So, Katzenbilder. So, der Startpunkt, warum der das entwickelt hat,
jetzt, wie gesagt, es gibt mehrere dieser Software, aber das ist die,
würde ich sagen, mit den besten Ergebnissen und der einfachsten UX,
war, dass sein Hund gestorben ist.
und er hatte irgendwie eine Vision Pro und hatte noch ein paar 3D-Bilder von
seinem Hund noch in 3D aufgenommen und hat sich dann gewünscht,
hätte ich mal viel früher das gehabt und viel mehr Bilder von dem gemacht,
ich hätte ganz gerne meine alten Hunde-Bilder auch in 3D.
Und dann hat er dieses Tool halt sich gebaut, auf Basis von bestehenden Frameworks.
Das war jetzt noch bevor dieses Update rauskam.
Das war bevor das Update rauskam, genau. Und jetzt ist er quasi geschörlockt
worden dadurch, bis zu einem gewissen Grad. Wobei, da er das jetzt auch auf
die fest ausrollt und so weiter.
Hatte da glaube ich trotzdem noch seine gute Nische.
Und ich habe das jetzt einfach mal mit meinem toten Kater gemacht,
um jetzt hier also in der Tradition zu bleiben.
Sprich, ich habe jetzt also mein Kater, Liam.
Also mit Fotos wo er noch lebendig war. Muss man jetzt vielleicht erklärnderweise dazu sagen, oder?
Ganz genau, ja. Der ist jetzt also alt.
Hat nicht Fotos vom toten Kater.
Sondern als er noch fit lebendig wie ein Turnschuh war.
Aber jetzt ist er auch schon tot oder was?
Mittlerweile ist er tot, genau
seit eineinhalb Jahren. Und ich wollte ihn jetzt aber halt in 3D gucken.
Und ich schmeiß jetzt mal hier das Bild, was wir gerade sehen.
Das ist jetzt also einfach mein Kater und der regelt sich auf dem Boden und
ist also jetzt in zwei Bilder aufgeteilt.
Ein linkes Bild, ein rechtes Bild.
Womit ist das jetzt fotografiert?
Das ist damals mit meinem, ich glaube das ist sogar nicht mit dem iPhone,
sondern schon mit einer etwas besseren Kamera gemacht.
Damit habe ich glaube ich, weiß ich gar nicht, was das für eine war.
Aber das war jetzt ein normales oder so ein räumlich?
Nein, nein, nein, das ist ein ganz normales Bild. Das ist irgendwie fünf,
sechs Jahre alt, das Bild.
Und warum hast du das jetzt zweimal hier nebeneinander?
Weil das einmal fürs linke Auge ist und einmal fürs rechte Auge.
Achso, das ist jetzt bearbeitete.
Das ist jetzt schon das Ergebnis, genau. Das heißt, du nimmst irgendein beliebiges,
perspektivisches Bild.
Es sollte natürlich schon irgendwie ein Foto sein, schmeiß das in die App rein
und sofort binnen einer Viertelsekunde erzeugt.
Er dir ein linkes und ein.
Rechtes Bild. Aufgrund von Informationen, die unklar sind.
Also sprich, es ist halt ein KI-System hinter, ein neuronales Netz,
was halt darauf trainiert wurde,
Aus 2D-Bildern 3D-Bilder zu machen. Und das ist insofern technisch natürlich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so der anspruchsvollste Job, weil du ja perfekten Ground-Truth-Daten hast.
Das heißt, du kannst ja hingehen mit einer echten 3D-Kamera zwei echte Bilder
machen und davon wirfst du eins quasi dem neuronalen Netz vor und sagst,
bemühe dich mal und das da vorne ist dein Target, dein perfektes,
an dem du dich immer wieder messen musst.
Das machst du halt ein paar Millionen Mal und irgendwann hat dann eben das System
genug Erfahrungsdaten,
was irgendwie wie ein Baum perspektivisch auf einer Wiese steht oder jetzt hier
in dem Fall halt eine Katze auf dem Boden und wie der Boden perspektivisch verdreht ist.
Ja, es gibt jetzt keine weiteren Informationen, außer wirklich dieses ursprüngliche
2D-Bild, was ich reingeworfen habe.
So, und das kannst du jetzt halt wieder in die Vision Pro reinladen oder halt auch in die Quest.
Da zähle ich hinterher noch, was da dann quasi der Toolstack ist.
Und so kannst du dann zu deinem, was auch immer, alten Familienfotos,
Urlaubsbildern oder sowas, kannst du dir also im Nachhinein 3D-fizieren.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die erste Frage.
Naja, jetzt habe ich aber irgendwie keine, will ich nicht ständig jetzt hier
meine, ein Headset irgendwie tragen und trotzdem interessiert mich jetzt dieses 3D.
Könnt ihr eigentlich 3D schielen?
Ja, hab's mir gerade schon angeguckt.
Du kannst es? Kannst du das auch, Tim?
Weiß ich nicht.
Weißt du, was das ist?
Seit Magic Eye hat man es dann oft genug gemacht.
Erinnerst du dich an das magische Auge, diese Bücher?
Diese Bilder, die so komisches Muster hatten.
Ach so.
Und wo man sich dann so tief drin...
Nicht das Dungeons & Dragons magische Auge.
Nein, das nicht. Sondern es
gab diese Bilder mit diesen abstrakten Mustergeschichten drauf gedruckt.
Und wenn du lange genug ins Nichts gestartet hast, entstanden dann plötzlich
so dreidimensionale Strukturen.
Steganographie, genau so hießen
die. Ich hatte irgendwann auch mal eine Software, um das selber zu machen.
Genau.
Die hat aber nur so mittelgut funktioniert.
Und ich habe mich damals immer irgendwie ein bisschen geärgert,
weil das viel zu kompliziert ist.
Und dieses stereoskopisch schielen oder Kreuzblick ist viel einfacher als das,
was man da bei diesen magischen Bildern immer machen musste.
So Tim, dann machen wir jetzt mal einen Workshop mit dir. Dann müsstest du mal
hier so rüber und ich sage euch auch gleich, wie ihr das in deinen Empfangsgeräten
jetzt versuchen könnt nachzustellen, wenn ihr dieses Bild nicht seht.
Also hört gut hin. Hört gut hin.
Dann seht ihr das auch.
Wir nehmen noch ein einfacheres Bild, das daraufhin quasi optimiert ist.
Ihr lernt jetzt wirklich was fürs Leben, glaubt mir. Es kommt hinterher,
wie ihr damit wetten, dass ihr das gewinnen könnt.
Es ist so passiert.
So, das ist jetzt ein Bild, das habe ich jetzt in den Slack reingeworfen und
wird in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Ihr könnt aber auch, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie gerade keine Computer habt und
es trotzdem ausprobieren wollt, legt zwei beliebige identische Objekte vor euch hin.
Also zwei Wassergläser, die gleich sind.
Zwei, was weiß ich, Spielzeugfiguren. Also irgendetwas, was ihr gerade um euch
rum findet, was ihr zweimal habt, exakt identisch und stellt das vor euch auf den Tisch.
So, nicht allzu weit weg.
Ja.
So, jetzt geht ihr hin.
Diese beiden Bierflaschen hier zum Beispiel.
Diese beiden Bierflaschen, genau, mit denen wir das auch schon gehen.
Aber nicht identisch befüllt.
Nicht identisch befüllt.
Ja, und jetzt?
So, und jetzt nimmst du deinen Finger.
Links ist aber was anderes, als links ist ein Stern und rechts ist so ein...
Genau, das beschreibt jetzt Tim gerade nicht von den Bierflaschen,
sondern von dem Testbild, was ich hier drin habe.
Das ist zur Hilfe, damit man das ganze Verfahren leichter lernen kann,
sind dort noch Marker angebracht, nämlich in dem einen Bild einen Stern und
in dem anderen ein schwarzes Achteck und was es mit denen auf sich hat, dazu kommen wir jetzt.
So, jetzt machst du folgendes, du musst möglichst gerade davor sitzen,
hier da draußen auch. Jetzt nimmst du deinen Finger,
und hältst ihn...
Wo soll ich jetzt hinschauen? Auf dem Beamer oder auf deinem Bildschirm?
Es ist ein bisschen egal, was du nimmst. Wahrscheinlich ist es einfacher,
das mit dem Laptop zu machen. Jetzt nimmst du deinen Finger und...
Wie nah muss ich da jetzt ran?
Ist fast egal. Nicht zu dicht dran, nimm ruhig ein bisschen Abstand,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich einfacher.
So, jetzt nimmst du deinen Finger und hältst ihn ungefähr zwischen diese beiden Bilder.
Ruhig noch ein bisschen dichter dran und fokussiert auf eure Fingerspitze.
Das heißt also, wenn ihr jetzt zwei Bierflaschen habt, habt euer Finger jetzt
zwischen den beiden Bierflaschen.
So und jetzt kommt der Douglas Adams Moment. Wie lernt man fliegen bei Douglas Adams?
Man wirft sich auf den Boden aber daneben.
Exakt. Genau das machen wir jetzt.
Also nicht auf den Boden werfen jetzt.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach den Finger weg und gucke auf das Bild.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, pass auf. Du guckst weiter auf den Finger und führst ihn
langsam an deine Nase und guckst dabei aber weiterhin auf dem Finger,
dass du den Finger scharf hast und siehst,
wie im Hintergrund die beiden Objekte anfangen sich übereinander zu bewegen.
Bis du irgendwo einen Punkt hast, wo sie exakt deckungsgleich sind und dann
schaltet, wenn man das ein bisschen übt, das Gehirn um, schaltet das Gehirn
um und stellt nicht mehr den Finger scharf, sondern plötzlich das Bild im Hintergrund.
Ja.
Das muss man ein bisschen üben,
aber normalerweise so innerhalb von fünf Minuten ist es gut erlernbar.
Und der Effekt ist dann der, dass dein rechtes Auge das linke Bild wahrnimmt,
dein linkes Auge das rechte Bild und dadurch hast du plötzlich einen astreinen
3D-Effekt ohne jede Brille und Spezereien.
Weil jedes Auge mit seiner spezifischen 3D-Bild...
Wenn ich den Finger jetzt an mich rangeführt habe und dann immer drauf schaue,
dann muss ich das dann so weitermachen?
Genau, du musst halt quasi dann irgendwann den Blick vom Finger lösen und auf
den Hintergrund achten.
Muss ich dann den Finger weg machen?
Den kannst du dann weg machen, dann ist es einfacher, genau.
Und dann müsste hier dieser weiße Stern, müsste genau in der Mitte von dem Schwarzen
sein. Dann ist es perfekt.
Und dann ergibt sich plötzlich das ganze Bild.
Das ist ganz lustig, weil ich kann das relativ gut, wenn ich die Brille absetze
und einfach ein bisschen näher rangehe, weil die Augen dann direkt im Unendlichen
sind und entspannt und dann kann man gut gucken.
So, naja, also.
Also wenn es zum ersten Mal meistens fangen die Leute an zu lachen,
wenn es zum ersten Mal funktioniert, weil es ein völlig ungewöhnlicher Effekt
plötzlich ist, den man da hat
und den man so mit nichts vorher irgendwie kannte oder vergleichen kann.
Ja, ich habe so einen ähnlichen Effekt, aber es geht dann schnell wieder auseinander.
Vielleicht muss es auch mit Brille, das muss man ein bisschen...
Also auf jeden Fall, das ist ein Weg, wie man also 3D-Bilder mit solchen Tools
produziert, sich angucken kann.
Und die Anwendungen gibt es viele dafür, für dieses Verfahren.
Beispielsweise diese Fehlerbilder, die es so gibt.
Sprich irgendwie in irgendwelchen Zeitschriften, finde Fehlerbilder,
wo zweimal ein fast identisches Bild nebeneinander ist und wo irgendwie sechs
kleine Unterschiede reingebaut wurden.
Ja, das kennt ihr, diese Tafel.
Ja.
So, die kannst du, wenn du diese Methode gelernt hast, binnen Sekunden lösen.
Egal, wie kompliziert die sind.
Ach so, weil dann die Unterschiede dann so dreidimensional vorher stehen oder flimmern.
Die flimmern dann. Das heißt also, du hast das linke Bild und das rechte Bild.
Ah, bei einem hat es schon funktioniert im Chat. Ah, das ist ja geil. Genau.
So, das ist jetzt hier ein Fehlersuchbild. Da sind sechs Fehler drin und wenn
man das kann, hast du die innerhalb von drei Sekunden gefunden.
Fantastisches Partyspiel. Weil die Leute denken, du bist Gott.
Such also irgendeinen Teil raus, wo die alle so minutenlang irgendwie,
wo ist da jetzt noch irgendwie das Haar?
Du guckst einmal drauf, sagst da, da, da, da, da, da, da. Dann sagen sie,
ja, das hast du ja vorher gekannt, das Bild. Ja, zeig mir ein beliebiges anderes Bild.
Das klappt einfach, weil die Unterschiede eben hin und her flimmern.
So, das hat sich wiederum einer zunutze gemacht.
Und erinnert ihr euch noch, wir sind ja hier die alte weiße Männer-Show leider,
an Wetten, dass diese Sendung?
Schon mal gehört.
Da gibt es eine Ausgabe und zwar 15 Jahre her, die Wetten, dass Ausgabe vom 27.03.2010.
Ja, uralte Kamellen werden ausgekraten.
Uralte Kamellen, aber ihr werdet gleich sehen, warum. Und da hat sich also der
Wettkandidat hingestellt und hat gesagt.
Lass mich raten, er hat gesagt, ich finde die Unterschiede zwischen zwei Bildern in zehn Sekunden.
Aber nicht nur von Bildern, sondern von einem Sternenhimmel.
Also er hat sich schon Mühe gegeben, das noch zu dramatisieren und die scheinbare
Komplexität anzuheben.
Aha.
So, das heißt, was hat er gemacht? Er hat also jetzt einfach einen Sternenhimmel
mit 1000 Sternen genommen,
dupliziert und also einmal links, einmal rechts und die Aufgabe von Thomas Gottschalk
und Konsorten war also dann rechts immer irgendwo einen Stern mit einer Bildverarbeitung
quasi auf schwarz zu schalten.
Und er hat sich halt da vorgestellt und hat also behauptet, hier,
2000 Sterne, ich erkenne innerhalb von 10 Sekunden, welcher Stern gerade nicht
mehr im Sternenlimmel ist.
Ich stehe ganz im Bild so, was? Oh mein Gott, ein Alien.
Und ich saß da zu Hause auf der Couch. Du Schelm, das kann ich auch.
Warum bin ich da jetzt nicht im Studio? Fuck.
Das Prinzip kanntest du 2010 schon.
Das habe ich irgendwann mit 14 gelernt. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
in was für einen Kontext. irgendjemand hat mit, sowas muss dir halt beigebracht
werden, weil sonst kommst du da halt nicht drauf.
Aber wenn du es dann einmal kannst, verlierst du es halt auch nicht mehr und
es gibt erstaunlich viele Szenarien, in denen das dann plötzlich nützlich ist,
unter anderem zum schnellen Bewerten von 3D-Bildern und diese werden das und
das hat mich so aufgeregt, dass dieser Typ sich da hinstellt und von allen angebetet
wird mit so einem billigen Trick.
Okay.
So und dann hatte ich jetzt also alle Komponenten beisammen,
um jetzt dann aber mal Testreihen zu fahren.
Ich habe dann letzte Woche nochmal auf Mastodon rumgefragt, wer denn eine Vision
Pro hat und irgendwie gleichzeitig auch ein aktuelles iPhone und irgendwie ein
bisschen Grundverstand von Fotografie und mir mal Bilder schicken könnte,
von derselben Szene,
Sowohl einmal mit quasi echtem 3D der Vision Pro fotografiert,
als auch dann mit dem wahrscheinlich irgendwie doch eher Pseudo-3D von dem iPhone.
Und das habe ich dann wiederum getestet mit dieselbe Szene, sprich ich habe
einfach die linke Seite von dem iPhone-Bild genommen und dann hier mein Programm drüber geschickt.
So hast du drei verschiedene Varianten hattest.
Vision Pro Qualität, iPhone Stock 3D Qualität versus nachträglich mit Software bearbeitet.
Also wie dann das rechte Bild dazu aussieht sozusagen.
Genau. Wie dicht man dann da wirklich mit einer reinen Softwarelösung ohne jede
visuelle Komponente drankommt.
So und den Herren wollen wir auch nochmal eben ein bisschen promoten.
Das ist nämlich der Bernd Lutz.
Den findet ihr auf Mastodon unter mapache.bl at mastodonsocial.
Den Account können wir dann auch gerne nochmal verlinken in den Shownotes.
Und der hat mir dann also dankenswerterweise ein relativ umfangreiches Testset gegeben.
Und das war dann echt aufschlussreich. Also ich habe mir die dann in der Quest auch alle angeguckt.
Also jetzt nicht nur mit diesen 3D-Schuelen, weil der Eindruck ist da schon
nicht so stark, wie wenn du eine echte Brille hast.
Das ist nochmal was anderes, einfach alleine von der Größe her.
Trotzdem sind da schon ganz interessante Sachen rausgekommen.
Beispielsweise, warum ist jetzt hier meine Connection weg zum Beamer?
Das liegt glaube ich in meinem HDMI-Matrix-Teil.
So, ich habe jetzt mal reingeladen, ich schmeiße euch das auch wieder in den
Chat rein, ein 3D-Bild, das unbearbeitet jetzt eins zu eins so aus dem iPhone aktuellen kommt.
Links, rechts, so in dem Modus, wie wir es gerade auch kennen.
Und was fällt euch denn dabei auf, wenn ihr euch das jetzt mal anguckt?
Das könnt ihr jetzt auch wieder übereinander schielen, das funktioniert.
Und dann seht ihr auch, es ist wirklich auch 3D.
Also ohne zu schielen sehe ich, dass die Schärfentiefe anders ist.
Ja. Und zwar nicht nur ein bisschen.
Sondern extrem. Das ist das iPhone-Bild.
Das ist ein 1 zu 1 aus dem iPhone-Bild.
Ja, okay. Also auf dem linken ist hinten alles unscharf, so ausgeblurrt.
Und auf dem rechten ist alles scharf.
Es ist gestochen scharf. Da hat offensichtlich irgendein Algorithmus links den
Porträtmodus aktiviert.
Und rechts halt mal so nicht.
Und keine KI der Welt hat das mal wieder gerade gerechnet.
Und was soll ich sagen? Das ist mal nicht das einzige Problem dieser Bilder.
Das ist direkt aus dem iPhone? Ja. Okay, was ich mich jetzt frage ist,
die neueren iPhones haben ja alle noch ein LiDAR drin.
Benutzt ihr das LiDAR auch, um diese Bilder irgendwie zu generieren?
Die Infos, die da drin sind?
Es könnte sein, aber man weiß es nicht. Also aufgrund der Ergebnisse würde ich
sagen unwahrscheinlich.
Also bei den ganzen Vergleichstests, die ich gemacht habe, kommt man dazu,
mindestens ein Drittel der Bilder sind...
Mist, die da aus dem iPhone rauskommen.
Okay.
Also aus dem iPhone 15.
Aus dem iPhone 15. Also aus wirklich unterschiedlichen Gründen.
Das mit der Tiefenschärfe gerade, das reguliert das Auge lustigerweise ziemlich raus.
Also wenn du das in 3D siehst, siehst du, fällt es dir gar nicht auf,
weil das scharfe das andere quasi komplett überlagert in der Wahrnehmung.
Das heißt, der Effekt ist gar nicht so störend, wie man annehmen würde.
Aber es gab andere Motive, beispielsweise hier so ein Gitter,
was so in einem rechten Winkel eigentlich vor einem steht. Es ist komplett dran
gescheitert und die ganze Perspektivität kommt irgendwie überhaupt nicht hin.
Also ich würde sagen, mindestens ein Drittel der iPhone-Bilder,
die er jetzt gemacht hat und das sind ersichtlich so richtige Allerweltsbilder gewesen.
Also jetzt keine super komplizierten Situationen, waren richtig für die Tonne, richtig gehend.
Und hast du die denn mit der Software besser hingekriegt?
Stabiler. Nicht besser, aber stabiler. Das heißt also, da hast du keine Ausreißer,
sondern du hast ein ordentlich aussehendes 3D-Bild.
Stabil, schlecht.
Naja, nicht schlecht, sondern ich würde sagen, es ist ein stabiles Mittelmaß.
Es gab einzelne iPhone-Bilder, die dann besser waren in der Qualität und es
gab aber viele, die schlechter waren.
Sodass ich also sagen würde, macht euch da jetzt mal keinen Kopf,
wenn ihr kein aktuelles iPhone habt und wenn ihr keine Vision Pro habt,
auf der ihr das umrechnen könnt, probiert mal einfach hier diese Software aus.
Das ist mehr als gut enough für das, was ihr eigentlich vorhabt.
Man muss sagen, die Bilder, die aus der Vision Pro kommen, die sind wirklich super.
Nicht in Bezug auf die rein fotografische Qualität, also das seht ihr jetzt
hier auch so ein bisschen.
Das ist jetzt mal hier ein Vision Pro Bild. Das ist schon ganz schön verwaschen
und in der Auflösung nicht so toll wie die iPhone-Geschichten.
Das ist also schon ein Unterschied, aber dafür ist die reine Drehqualität wirklich komplett gut.
Also da kann man nicht meckern. Und das ist jetzt hier auch ein interessantes Bild.
Das letzte, was ich jetzt hier gerade reinlade, das ist eine Wasserfläche,
in der sich Bäume spiegeln, die weiter hinten stehen.
Und das ist dann ein Motiv, wo mein
quasi reingerechnetes 3D dann wirklich komplett an seine Grenzen kommt.
Also sprich, da siehst du zwar, es ist eine Wasserfläche und vorne ist es dichter dran als hinten.
Aber bei der Vision Pro ist es so, dass die Spiegelungen der Bäume in der Wasserfläche
wirklich auf derselben Tiefenebene sind wie die Bäume selber.
Weil das ist optisch nun mal so.
Bei mir sind die quasi, bei der gerechneten Variante sind die obendrauf geklebt
auf dem Wasser, die Baumspiegelungen.
Du hast also nicht diesen zusätzlichen Tiefeneffekt in der Reflexion.
Das heißt also, da sind die Algorithmen jetzt einfach noch nicht so weit,
dass sie hier solche Feinheiten dann auch noch vernünftig aufgelöst bekommen.
Was ich mich jetzt gerade frage, also ich habe irgendwann mal gelernt,
dass du echten 3D-Blick nur hast für alles, was du mit der Hand noch erreichen
kannst und danach gaukelt dir das Hirn nur noch 3D vor,
weil die Augen gar nicht weit genug auseinander sind. Stimmt das denn eigentlich?
Naja, der Effekt wird halt immer schwächer nach hinten.
Jaja, schon, aber irgendwann kommst du natürlich auch an Auflösungsgrenzen von deinen Augen.
Ja, also es ist ja ohnehin nicht so ganz einfach festzulegen,
also diese echte Links-Rechts-Information ist ja nicht das Einzige,
was das Gehirn braucht, um eine tiefe Information zu machen.
Schatten spielen, noch eine Erfahrungswerte.
Bewegung vor allen Dingen, weil wir ja nie komplett still stehen,
sondern immer eine ganz leichte Bewegung in den Augen und im Körper drin haben
und der gesamte Mix macht dann normalerweise.
Naja, der Rest wird über Ni gerechnet.
Schon, um da gewisse Sachen auszugleichen. Es gibt etliche Menschen,
die gar nicht 3D gucken können. Das ist ja auch etwas, was einem so nicht bewusst ist.
Ja, die kriegen auch diese Magic Eye Bilder nicht gemacht.
Schon gar nicht, aber auch wenn die im 3D-Kino sitzen, denken die immer nur,
what's the fuss? Ja, was wollt ihr hier von mir? Meine Mutter hatte das, meine Frau hat das.
Der Effekt ist häufig, ein Auge ist stark weitsichtig und das andere ist stark
kurzsichtig, Sodass das also von Kindheitstagen an das Gehirn nie genug Informationen
bekommen hat in Deckung, um überhaupt eine 3D-Staffelung hinzubekommen.
Auch das kann man allerdings sich dann im Alter nochmal antrainieren.
Da gibt es einen coolen TED-Talk zu.
Ist allerdings auch zig Jahre alt, habe ich mal geguckt. Wo sich eine Frau das
im Dreivierteljahr antrainiert hat, die es also auch von Geburt aus nie konnte.
Und da mit diversen Tricks und Tools, das dann sich doch irgendwann drauf geschafft hat.
Den darfst du gerne mal raussuchen.
Also ein interessantes Thema. Was ich jetzt noch zum Schluss draufwerfen würde,
ist nochmal meine Toolchain, wie man das Ganze in die Quest reinbekommt.
Weil die wenigsten von uns können sich eine Vision Pro leisten und ich möchte
ja jetzt meinen toten Kater auch in meiner Quest mir angucken können.
und ist das eigentlich irgendwie pietätslos? Egal.
Ja, ist es, aber macht nichts.
Okay.
So, und da kommt dieses Programm hier zum Einsatz.
Das ist von der Firma ImmerVR für Immersion. Immersiv.
Ach, nicht von jeder Zeit?
Und dort, nee, obwohl es in Deutschland, der sitzt, glaube ich, in München.
Zu dem habe ich auch einen losen Kontakt. Das ist auch ein Dev-Bude und der
ist auch total gut, was irgendwie, man fragt ihm was und er erklärt Dinge und
man kann Feature-Quests loswerfen und sowas.
Ich liebe ja wirklich so diese einen Dev-Buden, wo Leute antworten und man mit
denen irgendwie in den Dialog reingehen können. Ich finde, das ist echt immer
das Schönste so überhaupt.
So, der hat eine Software halt gebaut, um 3D-Bilder in der Quest sich anschauen
zu können und seit dem letzten Updates, nach viel Quengeln von etlichen Leuten,
nicht nur mir, Hat er jetzt also einen generischen Import dieser Apple Hike
Bilder mit aufgenommen.
Und von daher kann man sich also sowohl die Sachen, die jetzt direkt aus der
Quest kommen, als auch die Sachen, die aus einem iPhone kommen,
als auch das, was wir hier mit dem Tool, diesem Spatial Toolkit,
sich selber zusammenrechnet,
kann man auf einem sehr einfachen, simplen Wege sich hier auf der Quest in tollem 3D angucken.
Und das ist wirklich wild, wenn du also einfach deine letzten Urlaubsbilder
oder Kindheitsbilder von XY plötzlich wirklich einen riesengroß mitten bei dir
im Wohnzimmer stehen hast.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es bei der Quest noch eine Umdrehung beeindruckender
ist, weil noch bessere Auflösung und Farbtiefe und so weiter.
Aber dass es auch auf jetzt einer Quest 3 habe ich, ist das schon sehr,
sehr cool. Dafür, dass es dann keinen Cent kostet.
Jetzt muss man fragen, wenn man so eine Brille auf hat, macht er dann auch Parallaxe
mit den Objekten, wenn man den Kopf bewegt?
Nee, die Fragen werde ich als nächstes mal stellen, weil theoretisch müsste
das eigentlich dann sogar auch noch möglich sein.
Aber da muss halt irgendwie nochmal eine andere Art von drei...
Da musst du Hintergrund ergänzen.
Das müssen sie jetzt auch schon. Das heißt also, wenn du nur ein Bild hast und
daraus eine zweite Perspektive errechnest, fantasieren sie ja auch schon Elemente hinzu.
Aber du musst es natürlich auch in irgendeinem Dateiformat überhaupt erstmal
speichern können, was dann diese tiefen Informationen dynamisch abrufbar macht.
In dem Hike wird nämlich, es gibt glaube ich zwei Arten, wie 3D in den Hike abgelegt wird.
Das eine ist über wirklich linkes Bild, rechtes Bild und die andere Variante
ist über eine Death-Bild.
Death? Nicht Death Map, nicht Todes...
Diff.
Nee, Tiefeninformationen.
Depths.
Oh Gott, ja, Map, danke. Ihr sprecht das alles für mich aus.
Das ist dann so eine schwarz-weiß Grafik, wo man dann quasi über den Helligkeitsgrad
die eigentliche Tiefeninformationen mitnimmt.
Das ist allerdings nicht so sauber, wie wenn du einfach ein linkes, rechtes Bild hast.
Und welche Variante dann da wiederum geeignet wäre, um dann auch so eine leichte
Parallaxe-Verschiebung live machen zu können, das wäre auch sicherlich nochmal
interessant. sind, aber das kann Apple auch nicht.
Du hast da so ein Gerät.
Es gibt einen Husten.
Da kannst du es draufdrücken.
Ein Hustenbutton.
Was sie auch noch gemacht haben, was ich aber nicht überprüft habe bisher,
ist, dass sie aus diesen Live-Fotos, die ja im Prinzip kurze Videoclips sind,
wo du dann immer noch die Bewegung mit drin hast, also quasi,
auch wenn du es nur über eine Kamera aufnimmst,
hast Das ist quasi so eine kurzzeitige Bewegung von einer Sekunde oder so.
Daraus können sie wohl jetzt auch sehr gut Dreidimensionalität herausrechnen aus den Fotos.
Also wenn du deine Fotos als Live-Fotos gemacht hast, dann geht es nochmal ein
bisschen besser laut Berichten.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es selber jetzt nicht vergleichen können.
So, ich werfe nochmal ein paar Links ab. Das ist hier nochmal so eine Übungsseite,
womit man dieses 3D-Schielen sich nochmal drauf schaffen kann.
Und was für Freunde der Kommandozeile noch einen Blick wert ist,
ist dieses hier von Mike Swanson,
das Spatial Video Tool.
Das ist eigentlich für Video entwickelt worden, funktioniert aber genauso für Fotos.
Also den ganzen Bereich Video habe ich jetzt mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Das ist dann irgendwie so der nächste Entgegen, den man sich vielleicht nochmal anschaut.
Dann müssen wir hier ein Video-Format und YouTube-Kanal starten, glaube ich.
Ich fürchte auch. So, aber das ist nochmal ein ganz praktisches Kommando-Zeilen-Tool,
um Umrechnungen von 3D-Bildern vorzunehmen.
Das heißt also, wenn man eben jetzt ein Apple Vision-Format hat in diesem Hike-Format
und will das in irgendwas total Landläufiges konvertieren, einfach nur ein JPEG
oder PNG mit linkes Bild, rechtes Bild nebeneinander, dann nimmt man genau dieses Werkzeug hier.
Da kann man dann also ein paar Parameter reinschmeißen und dann transferiert er das entsprechend.
Spatial.
Das hatte ich zwischenzeitlich mal in der Pipeline drin, als diese beiden Tools
noch nicht miteinander gesprochen haben.
Also sprich hier auf der Quest die Immer Gallery auf der einen Seite und das
Spatial Media Toolkit Pro auf der anderen Seite.
Die waren quasi Datei-inkompatibel und dann habe ich halt beide Entwickler gleichzeitig
belatschert und hatte währenddessen dazwischen noch diese Kommandozeilenlösung, um das umzurechnen.
Mittlerweile haben sie es aber beide auf ihren Seiten kompatibel gemacht,
sodass man also jetzt dieses Problem da mal schlicht nicht mehr hat und die
Welt ist wieder ein Stück besser geworden.
Ja, also guckt euch das mal an, experimentiert damit, 3D-Bilder,
lustiges Areal und es gibt auch schon so die ein oder andere Anwendung,
wie gesagt, gerade irgendwie so alte Kinderbilder von einem selber oder sowas,
die dann plötzlich in 3D zu sehen, das ist schon weird.
Natürlich gilt Garbage in, Garbage out. Das heißt also, wenn ihr hier irgendwie
so verwackelte, alte, verwaschene Bilder habt, ist der Effekt natürlich bei
weitem auch nicht so eindrucksvoll und cool, wie wenn es jetzt halt was richtig
mit einer guten Kamera aufgenommen ist.
Also je besser das Eingangsmaterial, desto besser auch das 3D-Ergebnis.
What a time to be alive.
Ja, what a time to be awake. Ich bin ganz schön müde.
Jetzt sind wir eigentlich durch, ne? Mit allem. Mehr haben wir heute nicht.
Heute mal keine 4-Stunden-Sendung. Muss ja nicht immer sein.
Boah, alle Checkboxen abgehakt.
Ja.
Aber man muss ja auch nicht mehr sagen, als man weiß. Das wird dann immer schwierig.
Dann ist man wie so ein LLM.
Wie, ich soll immer noch was sagen. Ich denke mir mal irgendwas aus.
Lückenfüller. So ist es nämlich dann auch, wenn euch die Freakshow von so einer
LLM kredenzt wird. Das ist nicht wie das Echte.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht gemacht. Dieses Tool hier auf unsere Sendung jagen.
Da reizt mich auch gerade gar nichts zu, muss ich sagen.
Das können die Leute, die Langeweile haben, auch zu Hause als Hausaufgabe machen.
Bitte nicht. Also muss nicht sein.
Nur für den Privatgebrauch.
Macht was anderes.
Nicht veröffentlicht.
Ja, was steht noch an? Also Kongress ist,
Und wir könnten vielleicht nochmal kurz, ich weiß nicht, subscribe,
du hast ja leider nicht teilnehmen können. Ja.
Hast du zumindest den einen oder anderen Talk nochmal angeschaut?
Jeweils noch nicht zu Ende, ich habe da so eine Pile of Shame,
die ich noch nacharbeiten muss.
Aber das ist auch dein neues Ultraschall noch nicht pluggen.
Wir können es ja mal kurz erwähnen und du kannst es dann nächstes Mal Genau.
Wir können es einordnen und dann kann ich es nächstes Mal nochmal ein bisschen,
Genau, wir haben also die neue Version vorgestellt dort 5.1.
Ultraschall ist das Podcasting-Tool was diesen Podcast hier gerade aufnimmt.
Und tausende andere in Deutschland.
Wirklich? Tausende?
Tausende, ja Also der letzte Download war irgendwie 12.000 von der vierten Version.
Da müssen wir ein Wasserzeichen da reinmachen.
Das ist teilweise lustig, wo das aufpoppt. In manchen YouTuber-Kreisen ist es
lustigerweise auch beliebt.
Und in China sind wir groß.
Das Land nach Deutschland mit den meisten Ultraschall-Nutzern ist China.
Und wir haben jetzt durch die auch eine chinesische Übersetzung unseres neuen Manuals. Kein Scheiß.
Die lieben uns da drüben. Das ist eine der, also wir haben nun nur eine 5.1
Version gemacht, keine 6er Version,
weil eben dann doch keine richtigen grundlegenden Philosophieänderungen oder
Mega-Features dazugekommen sind, aber dafür ein Strauß von ich glaube doch 30
oder 40 Einzelfeatures.
Also es ist irgendwo was zwischen der Punkt 1 und Haupt-3Ds.
Und vor allem, gibt es das jetzt auch für Lunix?
Für Linux.
So ist es. Aber das können wir dann nochmal im Detail ausformen.
Aber Joram hat ja eine tolle Keynote in Vertretung für mich gehalten und ich
nehme gerade jetzt noch den Release Screencast auf, wo ich die ganzen Features
nochmal einzeln durchgehe.
Und wir haben jetzt wirklich eine schriftliche Dokumentation endlich nach all
diesen Jahren und nicht nur die Videos, sondern jetzt auch mal was zum Nachlesen.
Und da könnt ihr also oben in der Tat die Sprache auf Chinesisch umstellen und
das ist keine automatisierte Übersetzung, sondern die wurde uns wirklich von,
chinesischen Freunden und Kooperationsmenschen da ins Git geladen.
Da ist irgendwas kaputt. Es wird nicht chinesisch.
Es wird nicht chinesisch. Natürlich seien das noch nicht alle Seiten von denen gearbeitet sind.
Aber eigentlich.
Das wird nach einem methodischen Fehler und nicht einem, dass da was fehlt.
Also wir haben es eigentlich auf Deutsch, Englisch und Chinesisch,
aber du hast recht, Chinesisch passiert hier sehr wenig. Na,
da müssen wir nochmal gucken, weil das lief schon mal.
Bis zur nächsten Sendung haben wir das.
Hast du denn einen Talk von der Subscribe schauen können? Hast du irgendwie Zeit gefunden?
Wie gesagt, ich bin noch dabei. Deinen habe ich zu zwei Drittel durch.
Ah.
Da, deine Eröffnungskinaute im Dunkeln ist alles viel spannender.
Aufregender.
Aufregend. Guter Titel natürlich. Guter Titel. Nein, aber ich habe im Moment
leider sehr wenig Zeit in meinem Leben.
Ja, deswegen vielleicht ein Tipp. Schaut euch nicht meinen Kram an,
sondern der beste Talk oder heilsamste Talk war auf jeden Fall der von Dani Frede.
ich kann so nicht arbeite, Albtraum Comedy Podcast.
Zehn Dinge, die man besser machen kann. Das ist wirklich fantastisch.
Grandios. Das war eine echte Erweckung. Und ja, das ist alles auf media.ccc.de,
kann man auch nochmal verlinken.
Und wir sind ja dann mit dem,
mit dem Sendezentrum auch auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress wieder vertreten,
am Ort, wo wir auch letztes Mal waren, da im Bereich X und dort wird es auch
ein kleines Workshop Programm noch geben.
Da ist aber noch nichts online, glaube ich, oder wenn, dann weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht wo.
Kommt aber auf jeden Fall alles noch. Wir machen auf jeden Fall nochmal eine
Sendung vor dem Kongress, würde ich sagen. Das passt ja noch ganz gut rein.
Rodi, du bist auch auf dem Kongress, ne? Ich komme mit Kindern.
Das wird spannend. Mal gucken, was der Kidspace so kann.
Das wird mich dann da auch ganz schön binden vor Ort, aber das wird ganz lustig.
Alles klar, dann kann ich sagen, machen wir doch hier mal unsere schöne Outro-Musik.
Die kündigt an, dass es jetzt vorbei ist mit der Freakshow für heute und wie
gesagt, eine Sendung machen wir noch dieses Jahr.
Das auf jeden Fall. und bis dahin sagen wir Tschüss und bis bald, oder?
Ja.
Okay. Dann ist es dann. Tschüss.